Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wie war Weihnachten? Wie fandest du die Weihnachtsansprache? Hast du sie gesehen?
Ja, Steinmeier wünscht uns Mut.
Oh toll. An einem ganz sonnigen Weihnachtstag, aber es ist bitterkalt, sitzen wir hier und sind mutig.
Ja, der Funkemut, den braucht es.
Funke?
Ja.
Das muss ein Funke.
Ja, hat der Bundespräsident gesagt, wir wollen da ja nicht widersprechen.
Nö, gar nicht. Der Bundespräsident hat immer recht und ich freue mich aber auch schon auf März Ansprache dann.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich bin dann doch, wer weiß. Ich werde es erstmal nachlesen, mir einen Reim drauf machen und dann werde ich gucken, wie es wirkt, wenn der alte Mann spricht.
Ich habe sie mir gestern angesehen und dachte, vielleicht wirft diese Räder wenigstens einen Clip für die Neuen Zwanziger ab, aber das war nicht der Fall. Insofern, ja, wir hoffen auf März.
Aber war eine Weihnachtsbaum schön.
Ja, ganz, ganz prächtig alles.
Typischerweise ist ja Schloss Bellevue ein bisschen höher. Da steht man ja auf Augenhöhe, hat der Baum noch drei Meter Durchmesser. Jaja, naja, sehr gut, du hast dich gefehlt.
Kein sozialer Wohnungsbau.
Nein.
Nun, wir müssen uns heute mit sehr ernsten Themen beschäftigen, werden aber auch ein bisschen zurückblicken. Du hast da, glaube ich, das ein oder andere vorbereitet, journalistisch, was du so gesammelt hast.
Journalisten machen Jahresrückblicke typischerweise.
Ja.
Etwas, was wir hier nie machen würden.
Nein.
Denn was unterscheidet den Januar vom Dezember gar nichts. Also Kalendereinträge, es wird halt gezählt. Also herzlichen Glückwunsch an alle Journalisten, die in der Lage sind zu zählen. Nächstes Jahr ist ein Zahl plus eins im Jahr. Ja, es ist, wenn sie wenigstens die Jahresrückblicke schon, wie soll man sagen, bezahm machen würden, also einfach angemessen.
Ja.
Man ist kurz davor zu sagen, wo ist denn hier die Diversität bei diesem Meinungskorridor, der einem serviert wird? Also es ist wirklich, sei gespannt.
Dieser Podcast wird unterstützt von Procon. Was ist Procon? Procon ist eine Energiegenossenschaft. Wir wissen Genossenschaften, da schließen sich Bürger zusammen, um ein großes Ziel zu verfolgen und es gemeinsam zu erreichen. Und bei einer Energiegenossenschaft liegt der Zweck meist entweder in der Energieerzeugung oder im Handel von Energie. Es gibt sehr viele Energiegenossenschaften in Deutschland und Procon ist eine besonders große Genossenschaft. 40.000 Mitglieder vertreten es Procon in Deutschland, Polen, Finnland und Spanien. Procon setzt auf Wind onshore, auf Speichertechnologien, PV und Biomethan. Und mit dem Kauf von Genossenschaftsanteilen liefern die Mitglieder wichtiges Eigenkapital für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien. Bereits mit 50 Euro kann jeder Mitglied werden und somit dann ein bisschen die Energiewende selbst in die Hand nehmen. Man kann natürlich auch Mitgliedschaften verschenken.
Ja, und wenn das nicht mal eine gute Idee ist, an jemanden, der schon alles hat, während man selber nicht mal eine gute Geschenkidee hat, dies Jahr einfach ein ganzes Windrad verschenken. Ihr habt dann Anteile an Procon, wenn ihr für 50 Euro da einsteigt. Euch gehört genauso viel Stimmrecht über die Windräder wie jedem anderen der 40.000 Mitglieder, egal wie viel man reinbringt. Die anderen holen nur mehr Rendite raus, aber ihr seid genauso Teil dieser sehr großen Gemeinschaft mit einer sehr guten Idee. Und ihr könnt damit richtig auftrumpfen und pralen. Stellt euch vor, wie ihr unterm Weihnachtsbaum sitzt und der Onkel erfährt, dass er ein Windrad bekommt. Da erspart sich auch jede andere Diskussion über, wer ist hier der Beste. Das ist die Idee, die wir gerne weitertragen. Wir danken Procon sehr dafür, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen, also auch euch.
Und man hat natürlich als Mitglied dann auch Zugang zu vergünstigtem Strom. Und in den letzten Jahren wurden erfolgsabhängige Dividenden in Höhe von drei bis fünf Prozent ausgezahlt. Es kann sich also lohnen.
Alle Informationen zu Procon in unseren Show Notes, also greift mal in eure Hosentasche.
Meinungskorridor ist schon ein gutes Stichwort für unser Thema. Wir müssen natürlich über die Ukraine sprechen, darüber, dass es da diesen nominösen 28-Punkte-Plan der Trump-Administration gibt. Es geht darum, wird jetzt nun endlich der Zeitpunkt kommen, an dem man an den Verhandlungstisch geht. Was ich so feststelle, und ich habe da jetzt keine Clips mitgebracht, weil ich auch nicht die Leute vorführen will, dass in Podcasts, in denen es eigentlich nicht um das Politische geht und man lange Zeit aber immer so nebensetzen fallen, die es ja, wir müssen weiter kämpfen, gehört man jetzt einfach, es wird ja auch mal Zeit, dass das Blutvergießen aufhört. Also das wird einfach so kurz eingestreut und dann merkt man so, ah, da scheint irgendetwas in Bewegung zu sein. Jetzt bezieht man sich also nicht mehr auf das alte Mantra, sondern es gibt bald so ein neues Mantra. Jetzt muss aber auch bald mal das Blutvergießen aufhören. Natürlich ist das nicht überall angekommen. Es gibt ja die ewig Vorderen oder ewig Gästregeln, wie man möchte, die nach wie vor voll reingehen. Beim Ronzheimer Podcast war ein Streitgespräch zwischen Johannes Warwick und Marie-Akne Strack-Zimmermann. Wir werden jetzt nicht dieses ganze Gespräch durchdeklinieren. Man kann sich das anhören. Der eine bleibt sehr ruhig, die andere eher nicht. Jedenfalls ist es interessant, einmal abzubilden, wie dort kommuniziert wird. Also Warwick hatte ja dann erst mal so gesagt, nun das Problem war auch zum Beispiel, dass Europa nie eine Strategie mal vorgelegt hat. Wie soll es denn aussehen? Sondern nur Maximalforderungen gestellt hat, beziehungsweise Wünsche artikuliert hat, die nicht mit der Realität in eins gesetzt werden können.
Ons Heim ist ja einer dieser Podcasts, die produziert werden, fast wie so ein Hörspiel. Das heißt, man macht ihn an und dann kommt erst mal eine Minute Rücksicht auf, Rückblick auf das, was eigentlich erst kommt. So, also da werden ja keine Argumente entfaltet. Da wartet man ja sowieso nicht groß. Sondern man wird schon mal überfahren, so ein bisschen. Und ich hab das auf dem Fahrrad gehört, hab keine Clips gemacht, weil ich dachte, es ist kalt, ich müsste jetzt meine Handschuhe ausziehen, mach ich nicht. Und ich weiß noch, dass der Podcast losging mit Stragg Zimmermann sagt, Herr Warwick, dann sagen Sie mir doch mal jetzt, was Putin will. Jetzt legen Sie doch mal die Karten auf den Tisch.
Ziehen Sie mal die Hose runter, sagt sie.
Ziehen Sie mal die Hose runter. Da hab ich so gedacht, das ist eigentlich, also warum merken Sie es nicht? Ja, hab ich mich gefragt. Denn seit Anbeginn wird uns ja erzählt, wir müssen Putin, also im Grunde war es ja, wir haben es ja ein bisschen, auch es ist ja fast ein bisschen zu pointenhaft, aber auf No-Covid folgte No-Putin oder Zero-Putin. Zero-Putin und Zero-Covid. Genau, man hat einfach das Muster einer medialen Debatte genommen und dann auf ein anderes Thema draufgelegen. Was ja bedeutet, dieser Spruch, mit dem Virus kannst du nicht diskutieren, der hätte ja auch Putin gelten müssen. Jetzt kleine Verdrehung, weil wir haben ja schon immer so ein bisschen Nähe. Es wäre schon gut, wenn man da immer mal ein bisschen miteinander redet und während da nicht geredet wurde. Nur jetzt, wo die Fälle eigentlich davongeschwommen sind, damit meine ich nicht auf dem ukrainischen Boden, denn wie es da zugeht, kann man halt in Was nun Herr General oder so sich wirklich anhören.
Machen wir auch gleich.
Sehr gut, sondern so weltpolitisch einfach. Was ist mit Indien? Was ist mit dem globalen Süden und so weiter? Also die Fälle sind ja komplett davon geschwommen. So und ich verstehe nicht, warum man jetzt viel zu spät plötzlich wissen möchte, was Putin möchte, was er wirklich will, wie auch immer, statt jetzt zu sagen, ne die Europäer entscheiden jetzt einfach, was mit der Ukraine ist und reden gar nicht mit Putin, sondern dann, ja, also das ist ja das Wort Eskalationsdominanz. Man sagt einfach, was Sache ist und der andere, wenn er dagegen eskalieren will und es ist halt der alte Trick und ich habe ja sehr dafür plädiert, muss dann halt sagen, okay, gut, dann gebe ich mich jetzt geschlagen, weil Atomwaffen will ich nicht. Und diese Eskalation, also es pendelt ja nur zwischen so verschiedenen Denkmodellen, die man so hat. Ja, also alle kommen hier mit der Bizeps muss jetzt die Ukraine verteidigen und am besten Deiner und ich sage mir nein, es sind bitte Atomwaffen und so. Und dieses, dass man jetzt, wo es eigentlich zu spät ist und man auch immer sagte, wir reden nicht mit Putin, so in einem Podcast auftritt, das gleich am Anfang heißt, die Redaktion hat sich für den Snippet entschieden, ja was will denn jetzt der Putin, so als ob der Warwick jetzt ein Sprecher von Putin wäre und als ob es für irgendwen von Belang wäre, was Putin will oder irgendwer wirklich noch nicht weiß, was Putin will. Also ich habe sozusagen, der Podcast ging los und ich habe gedacht, okay sorry, bin schon verloren. Die ersten drei Sekunden habe ich schon verloren.
Aber hat Herr Warwick nicht bei einer Sache recht, wenn er sagt, wir können oder wir Europäer können momentan ihm gar nichts auf den Tisch legen. Also wenn wir sagen, wir stimmen meinem Deal nicht zu oder wir wollen diesem Deal nicht zustimmen, dann ist es ja nicht so, dass wir militärische Möglichkeiten hätten, so massiv oder zumindest die Bereitschaft nicht, um die Ukraine so zu stärken, dass sie militärisch besser dasteht. Und wenn wir die Entwicklung uns anschauen, dann ist es ja so, auch wenn die Ukrainer sich massiv verteidigen und im Donbass die Russen große Probleme haben, dass es jetzt in den letzten Monaten oder in den letzten Jahren, muss man mittlerweile sagen, so ist, dass Ukraine Stück um Stück Territorium verliert. Und wenn ich mit einigen Ukrainern spreche, die sagen das noch nicht im On, aber da gibt es durchaus einige, die sagen, ja, es ist ein schlechter Deal, aber wie sieht das in sechs Monaten und in einem Jahr aus? Und wir glauben nicht daran, dass die Europäer uns irgendetwas geben, was diese Sache verändern würde.
Kommen wir gleich ja nochmal zurück, wir werden Oberst Reisner dazu hören, denn die Lage ist tatsächlich nicht besonders gut, aber es könnte ja noch schlechter werden. Wir haben jetzt ja immer von Ronzheimer Kurz so ein Resümee bekommen, wie gerade der Stand ist. Und wir haben ja auch jetzt gerade erlebt in den vergangenen Wochen, dass Friedrich Merz auftrumpfend aufgetreten ist und gesagt hat, wir werden diese russischen Assets jetzt nehmen und werden damit den Krieg weiterfinanzieren. Belgien macht er aber aus guten Gründen nicht mit. Die EZB ist nicht begeistert davon. Dann hat Friedrich Merz noch mal kurz so eine Karte gespielt und auch die russischen Vermögen, die in Deutschland noch sind, das scheint nicht viel zu sein, paar Milliarden oder so sind es wohl, aber doch, die würde man dann auch mit reinwerfen. Also wollte noch mal zeigen, auch wir Deutschland, wir involvieren uns in das Ganze. Das ist ja alles nicht aufgegangen. Und jetzt hat man sich einfach nur auf neue Kredite geeinigt. Das heißt, gerade das, was man nicht machen wollte, hat man jetzt gemacht. Mich wundert eigentlich, dass Friedrich Merz dann nicht viel mehr für kritisiert wurde, weil er doch eigentlich mal wieder mit seinem großen Projekt, was er davor hatte, gescheitert ist.
Also, Merz wird ja nicht mehr kritisiert, sondern man macht sich nur noch über ihn lustig. Ich habe jedenfalls unendlich viele Podcasts im Ohr gerade, in denen es einfach, ja, der Merz, dann hat er das nicht hingekriegt und dann ist ihm auch noch die Gramm-Karrenbauer in die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung gesprungen und so. Also es gibt gar keine handfeste Kritik mehr an Merz, sondern alle stehen nur so bedauernd daneben eigentlich.
Ja, so könntest du natürlich auch sagen.
Und leiden so ein bisschen mit, zeigen Mitleiden. Das ist schon sehr pietätvoll eigentlich.
Die Antwort von Strack Zimmermann jetzt?
Aber das ist ja der springende Punkt, dass die Ukrainer selber eben diese Hilfe, diese Unterstützung brauchen. Und wir haben ja in unserem Gespräch noch gar nicht erwähnt und das ist ja sehr relevant, dass die Ukraine ja nicht ausschließlich auf Europa angewiesen ist, sondern in der Zwischenzeit, und das ist natürlich eine Tragödie, Learning by doing, diese Angriffe auf die Ukraine insofern ausabwehren, weil sie inzwischen selber Rüstung herstellen, selber enorm technologischen Fortschritt haben.
Du hast ja den Clip gespielt.
Rondsheimer fragt jetzt, was hat die EU anzubieten? Und sie sagt, ja, ja, das ist ja alles die Tragödie und so weiter. Die machen ja jetzt so ganz viel selbst.
Also ich finde das alles, das ist einfach absurd. Also jeder einzelne Satz absolut. Du hast ja diesen Clip gespielt, wie Palantir sich darüber freut, dass so ein Battlefield da ist, wo man mal die Sachen so richtig testen kann. Also macht die Ukraine das gerade alles selbst? Na ja, da sind gerade 200 Firmen neu entstanden, die Drohnen bauen. Da weiß man, das ging halt nicht von alleine, sondern da gibt es einfach Interessengruppen, die sagen, coole Ort, um das mal zu machen und so. Es gibt ja auch Videos jetzt von Städten, wo einfach diese Glasfaserkabel, die Drohne fliegt ja los, das Kabel fällt halt einfach zu Boden. Und die Stadt sieht aus wie unter Spinnweben. Aber das finde ich wirklich sehr gut. Bei jedem Clip, wir müssen eigentlich so richtig tief reichen, Ronsheimer so, ja Waffenlieferung, sie sagt jetzt, ja wir haben ja gar nichts zu bieten, wie auch immer. Diese Linie, die Straks Zimmermann vertreten hat, war jetzt drei Jahre lang, wir rüsten die Ukraine hoch. Das ist nicht an Putin gescheitert, dass die Ukraine nicht hochgerüstet wurde, sondern offenbar gab es doch andere politische Anliegen auf unserer Seite, auf die sie gar nicht so richtig einwirkte, weil sie immer Putin verteufelt, statt sich mal das vor Ort anzuschauen. Und jetzt, wo diese Linie also irgendwie schon als gescheitert gelten kann, die Ukraine hat sich da eben nicht entsprechend verteidigt und Zelensky sehnt den Weißen Haus Termin entgegen, lässt er jetzt verlautbaren, wo er dann auch Gebietsverluste anerkennt und wie auch immer. Und jetzt wollen sie plötzlich reden und jetzt verdreht sich's aber. Und wir fragen uns, warum wollt ihr denn jetzt mit Putin reden? Also gibt's noch was zu klären?
Ich glaube, sie will gar nicht mehr, will gar nicht reden. Ich glaube, sie will einfach an ihrer Linie festhalten und kann aber wirklich nichts anbieten. Also die Frage war ja, was bietet Europa denn der Ukraine an?
In der Abwehr, also in der in der Abwehr dessen, was dort kommt und nicht umsonst, die Europäer und andere Staaten der Ukraine zuschauen, gerade in der Drohnenentwicklung. Ich will das jetzt nicht vertiefen. In der Lage sind, eben aus dieser Lage heraus, derart industriell Fortschritte zu machen, um mögliche Angriffe in Zukunft zu wehren. Tatsache ist aber...
Also sie gibt immer noch keine Antwort auf die Frage, erzählt irgendwas von Drohnen, die da getestet werden. Wir haben ja im Leipziger, du hast es gerade gesagt, den Palantir-Gründer Alex Grab gehört und dann auch noch seinen UK-CO, der dann ausführt, das ist momentan besser als jedes Labor, was wir dort vorfinden. Leider müssen die Ukrainer das aushalten, aber wir sind natürlich trotzdem sehr glücklich, dass wir hier alles testen können.
Die Ukraine braucht und das, was sie sagten, dass die Ukrainer selber nicht daran glauben, dass die Europäer wirklich 100 Prozent sie unterstützen. Das bestätigt ja eben auch meine Beobachtung. Die Ukraine braucht Geld, damit die Wirtschaft und das militärische Equipment, was sie brauchen, um sich zu schützen, ausschließlich um sich zu schützen. Übrigens ein Angriff auf militärische Ziele in Russland ist ein Schutz, nämlich Angriffe zu verhindern, dass sie Geld brauchen dafür. Das können wir ihnen jetzt geben. Das kann der Rat morgen bzw. übermorgen entscheiden. Das wird Putin immens schwächen, weil er jeden Cent selber braucht. Und das zweite ist nach wie vor, dass Europa der Ukraine zumindest die Möglichkeit geben muss, auch militärische Mittel einzusetzen, um Angriffe zu verhindern. Das tun wir nicht. Das haben wir bisher zumindest nicht getan. Und Herr Warwick hat ja gerade selber das ewige Thema Taurus auf den Weg gebracht.
Das kommt jetzt nochmal zur Taurus-Achtung.
Es gibt auch andere Länder, die den Taurus haben. Und ich weiß, dort wird gerade darüber gesprochen, ob sie den frei geben, bis dahin, dass die Ukraine selber ein vergleichbares... Das ist zum Beispiel Schweden. Die haben den Taurus ja auch. Das heißt, da haben ihn einige. Da ist ein deutsches Waffensystem, es müssten die Deutschen grünes Licht geben, zugegebenermaßen.
Aber darüber wird durchaus diskutiert. Wir sind wieder bei der alten Debatte. Jetzt noch mal Taurus. Antwort Teil 2. Also es geht eigentlich noch viel länger, aber noch einen Clip dazu.
Aber die Tatsache, mehr Geld Resilienz zu schaffen, ihnen die Möglichkeit zu geben, weil letztendlich die Ukraine nur aus der Stärke heraus, wirtschaftlich und militärisch, ein Druck erzeugen kann, dass man dann gemeinsam an einen Tisch sitzt.
Wir werden nachher mal hören von Reisner, wann dieser Moment der Stärke da gewesen war.
Wie Stärke hat sie gerade?
Wie Stärke verliert sie gerade? Lassen Sie mich, Entschuldigung, Herr Farwick, nein, nein, nein. Sie leben in einer Fantasiewelt. Lassen Sie mich. Wir leben in einer Fantasiewelt.
Der Moment, der sich in der Menge ist umgreifend da, wenn man nur lange durchhält.
Der Blick auf die Landfahrte und das Schlachtspiel. Ich kehr da einmal ein, ganz kurz, Frau Stolz, noch ganz kurz und dann darf er farbig antworten bitte.
Ja selbstverständlich, selbstverständlich. Aber die, die uns zuhören, möchten vielleicht auch ihre Gedanken hören. Und das, was ich zu Ende sage, auch wenn ihnen das gerade nicht gefällt, was ich sage. Also mehr Geld, mehr Unterstützung, eigene Initiativen. Nur so werden wir in Europa eine Chance haben. Und deswegen Putin ist nicht irgendeiner, der was macht, sondern er will diese Weltordnung verändern. Das wollen übrigens die USA tragischerweise. Also das Weiße Haus will das auf. Und deswegen ist es so hochrelevant, dass Europa jetzt steht am Ende. Und wenn sie so sagen, dann wird man die Front bereinigt. Am Ende wird die Ukraine entscheiden. Und deswegen müssen wir an der Seite der Ukraine stehen, um das, was die Ukrainer mittragen, dann eben auch abzusichern.
Ja, die Ukraine entscheidet ja leider gerade sehr wenig, sondern das wird sehr stark aus Washington delegiert. Sie sagt ja dann auch, Washington will auch eine andere Weltordnung. Bedeutet ja eigentlich, was sie hier aufmachen möchte, wäre ja ein Zweifrontenkrieg. Also man müsste ja dann sagen, wir kämpfen also gegen Washington und gegen Moskau. Wie soll das eigentlich umsetzbar sein mit einer EU, die sich noch nicht mal einheitlich dahinter stellt? Es ist ja tragisch und auch sinnbildlich für die Debatte, die wir in den letzten Jahren geführt haben. Und das haben wir eben auf Kosten von Menschenleben getan. Das war ja nicht einfach nur so, dass man sich ein bisschen verhakt hat und dann sagt man, gut, man kam argumentativ nicht weiter, sondern das bedeutet ja ganz reales Leid. Was das bedeutet, das können wir sehr gut nachvollziehen, wenn wir Oberst Reisner vom österreichischen Bundesheer zuhören. Der war bei NTV zu Gast und schildert jetzt erstmal die Lage.
Das hat sich tatsächlich verändert. Ich würde sogar sagen, dass der 28-Punkte-Friedensplan und die Diskussion darum eine neue Phase dieses Krieges eingeleitet hat. Aus meiner Zählung hat die Phase neuen und wir sehen auch, dass das auch verknüpft ist mit Offensivanstrengungen an der Front. Aus meiner Sicht kann man hier bereits von einer neuen Minto-Offensive sprechen. Achtung, wieder natürlich die Herausforderung für die russische Seite, dass jetzt nicht es gelingt, im großen Stil Raum zu gewinnen. Aber trotzdem, man sieht, ich gebe Ihnen nur ein Beispiel, im Raum Südifunk Bogorowsk, dass die Russen es sehr wohl schaffen, in kurzer Zeit auf relativ großer Breite vorzumarschieren. Südifunk Bogorowsk, das sind also die beiden Städte Hohle-Polle und Dobrobilja. Wir haben hier eine Ausprägung von einem Angriff auf einer Breite von 35 Kilometern knapp. Und die Russen haben es geschafft, in den letzten drei Wochen fast 15 Kilometer vorzustoßen. Und das ist doch signifikant. Und wir sehen gerade, dass die Russen dabei sind, zu versuchen, die Städte Dobrobilja und Hohle-Polle, die relativ klein sind im Vergleich zu Bogorowsk oder Parkmutter, quasi stromreif zu bomben und quasi hier vorzustoßen. Und diese Anstrengungen sind auch noch zusätzlich begleitet von weiteren Angriffen, weiter westlich davon, zum Beispiel bei Ruhiv und auch bei Malatok-Marschka oder quasi auch südlich von Saporizhje, um also dort die ukrainischen Reserven, die von mir angesprochenen, zu binden, damit quasi eben nicht etwas den Ukrainern, etwas die Ukraine in die Lage versetzt, sich quasi gegen diesen russischen Vorstoß, wie die von Bogorowsk zu währzusetzen.
Das heißt, das sind sehr, sehr tödliche Aktionen, die da durchgeführt werden. Da werden jetzt Menschen verschlissen nach und nach. Die Ukraine kommt also da nicht entsprechend weiter, sondern ist da eher auf dem Rückzug, wenn auch zäh. Aber man kann sich vorstellen, was das dann immer in Menschenleben bedeutet. Weshalb die Ukraine ja dann auch vermehrt versucht, in Russland entscheidende Positionen zu treffen. Auch darauf geht Reisner ein.
Aber wenn man das jetzt im Hinterkopf behält, was haben die Ukrainer denn dann noch, um zu verhandeln, in ihrem Sinne zu verhandeln?
Die Ukraine versucht natürlich auf anderen Ebenen, so auch in der Vergangenheit immer wieder gezeigt, Initiative zu zeigen. Denken sie zum Beispiel daran, an die Angriffe auf die beiden Tanker im Schwarzen Meer. Oder denken sie auch an die laufenden Angriffe, auch gestern Nacht wieder von weiter reichen ukrainischen Drohnen auf Ziele in Russland. Und damit möchte man natürlich zeigen, dass man sehr wohl noch Initiative setzen kann, unabhängig von dem, was operativ-taktisch an der Front passiert. Aber sie haben natürlich Recht, die Ukraine hatte zunehmend weniger Handlungsoptionen.
Ich frage mich, ob das hier nicht sowieso auf einer besonderen Art und Weise so ein Elitendiskurs ist. Also die Verteidigungsausschussvorsitzende des EU-Parlaments ist halt mal in einem Podcast und hier so ein Professor des Krieges, wo man sich denkt, der sagt jetzt irgendwas, wer soll etwas dagegen sagen, so ja. Dann ist dieser MDR Podcast, den ich ja sehr gut finde, mit dem immer krass geruhsamen General, was weiß ich, wie er heißt, jedenfalls, was nun Herr General heißt der Podcast. Und ich war in der Oper und dort findet ja traditionell im Dezember eine kurze Ansprache ans Publikum statt mit Wir sammeln hier in einem Hut und so, ne? Da hab ich auch so gedacht, okay, die Oper macht so pro Abend, keine Ahnung, was so eine Inszenierung kostet 100.000, 200.000 Euro oder so. Also ist schon teuer. Man hat ein bisschen die Karten abgedeckt und ein bisschen über die Stadt steuert bei und so. Und dann ist da halt so ein Hut und man wirft so Geld rein. Und das ist schon also grundsätzlich einfach eine kleine Aktion, die wenig bringt für die Ukraine. Und es war die einzige, die mir überhaupt begegnet ist in diesem ganzen Dezember. Und das fand ich auch sehr erstaunlich irgendwie. Also ich weiß noch, kann man ja selber dran erinnern. Und das hat mich schon beschäftigt, obwohl ich in Thüringen gar nichts mit Karneval und so zu tun habe, aber das Golfkrieg stattfindet und man dann sagt, okay, aus Solidaritäten fallen wir jetzt kein Karneval und solche Sachen. Oder irgendwie in der Schule das auch bedacht wird. Also die Erkinder erzählen mir nichts aus der Schule, dass da irgendwie Ukraine Thema wird. Ich bin auf tausenden Weihnachtsveranstaltungen, wo das auch nicht thematisiert wird. In der Oper wird mal kurz ein Hut aufgestellt. Und das war es im Grunde. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wenn man einen Krieg hat, bei dem einige behaupten, wie krass es dazu geht, und dann hört man aber sofort, wie irgendwelche Firmen das ausbeuten. Und bei Politikern, ich finde ja auch, dieses Bild, was wir da gesehen haben von Stama, Merz, Zelensky und Macron, die einfach auf so Stühlen ohne Tisch vor so einer Wand sitzen und eine Pressekonferenz veranstalten, das ist doch bei allem, was man weiß, wie diese Leute typischerweise ihre Medienansprachen machen. In London, in Paris, in Berlin. Also das wird auch bewusst runtergedimmt irgendwie.
Ja.
Also ich find's auch ein bisschen sass ehrlich gesagt, wie die Gesamtlage so ist. Also fast wirkt es so, als sollten wir jetzt noch fünf Jahre lang das einfach aushalten, wie es da so vor sich geht und keiner wird mit irgendwas belästigt.
Naja, den Eindruck hab ich ja, dass man sagt, das ist ein Abnutzungskrieg, wir müssen Russland abnutzen und deswegen macht man noch lange weiter, aber dann schaut man auch nicht so genau hin. Wir wollen jetzt ein bisschen genauer hinschauen, was wären denn überhaupt die drei möglichen Szenarien, wenn erfolgreich verhandelt würde? Reissner, skizziert sie.
Ja, aus meiner Sicht gibt es, und das wurde ja auch in den letzten Monaten immer wieder diskutiert, drei realistische Szenarien, die wir kurz ansprechen können. Das ist das sogenannte koreanische Szenario, es ist das deutsche Szenario und es ist das finnische Szenario. Lassen sie mich ganz kurz zwei, drei Sätze über zur jeweiligen Szenario sagen. Das koreanische Szenario wäre quasi ein Waffenstillstand in langer Waffenspielstandslinie, vorzugsweise die jetzige Frontlinie. Es gibt zwar keine Friedensverhandlungen, es gibt auch keinen Friedensvertrag, aber im Prinzip der Krieg kommt zum Erliegen und das Sterben hat quasi ein Ende.
Ja, dann gibt es das deutsche Szenario.
Das deutsche Szenario wäre ein sehr positives Szenario, denken sie daran. Deutschland war am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs geteilt. Die DDR war in der Sowjet-Einflusszone, aber Westdeutschland war faktisch westlich orientiert und Teil der NATO. Das heißt, das könnte theoretisch der Fall sein, dass es dann in diesem Abtausch, der jetzt gerade vorhanden wird, sehr wohl dazu kommt, dass es möglicherweise eine West-Ukraine in der NATO gibt. Aber man kann aus meiner Sicht das nicht völlig ausschließen und sagen vom Vorheren, das geht nicht. Das ist die Frage nur, wie weit Russland quasi bereit ist oder kompromissbereit ist und darum versucht die Ukraine auch jetzt bei sich Druck aufzubringen.
So und ich glaube, da werden wir schon rangewöhnt, im Sinne von Millionen eingesperrte Uiguren in China. Ja, wir müssen halt mit denen Handel treiben, wo sollen denn die Weihnachtsgeschenke herkommen? Pädophil am Weißen Haus, wo jetzt nach und nach offenbar wird, was da vor sich ging und so. Und alle so, nee, aber der März hat voll den guten Kontakt zu dem. Ja, also man muss so richtig die Bevölkerung entpolitisieren, weil das kriegt man nirgendwo. Ja, also sobald man das anspricht.
Ja, wir werden noch ganz zum Schluss Werner Annoh hören am Ende dieses Podcasts. Da können wir uns mal anschauen, wie wohl so der Modus sein wird, wie man so damit umgeht, zum Beispiel mit einem Trump. Aber ja, man könnte das auch vielleicht als die große Gewöhnung bezeichnen, die jetzt flächendeckend stattfinden muss in jeder Hinsicht. Es gibt auch das finnische Szenario.
Und das dritte Szenario ist das finnische Szenario. Das erinnert sich ja an den Krieg von 1930-1940, den sogenannten Winterkrieg, wo dann am Ende Finland bitter einen Friedensvertrag unterschreiben musste. Der damalige finnische Außenminister hat gesagt, es möge ihm die Hand abfallen, mit der er jetzt die Unterschriften unter diesen Friedensvertrag setzt. Finland hat also einiges an Territorium verloren, aber es hat einen Überraschungssieg gegen die sowjetischen Streitkräfte erzielt und es hat als eigener Staat weiter bestanden. Das tragische an diesem Szenario ist, dass es dann einen sogenannten Fortsetzungskrieg gab. Also quasi nur kurze Zeit später kam es dann zu weiteren Auseinandersetzungen, die dann noch angedauert haben mehrere Jahre. Das könnte natürlich auch denkbar sein im Falle der Ukraine.
Ja, das ist ja auch dann die Frage, würde das überhaupt akzeptiert werden? Wer hat da wiederum innerhalb der Ukraine dann Interessen oder innerhalb Russlands Interessen, dass das wieder neu aufgemischt wird, dass wieder neu kriegerische Handlungen stattfinden? Was all diese drei Szenarien eint ist?
All diese drei Szenarien und damit schließt sich jetzt der Kreis meiner Ausführungen im Hinblick auf das, was der deutsche Außenminister gesagt hat, haben eines gemeinsam, die Ukraine verliert Territorium.
Etwas, was die ganze Zeit gesagt wird, das kann man nicht dulden. Jetzt sind ja fast alle so, vielleicht bis auf Trakt Zimmermann, die sagen, naja, man muss wohl auch irgendetwas abtreten. Also das heißt, diese Idee, die da einst formuliert wurde, dass man ja sogar noch Gebiete zurück haben wollte, eigentlich auf den Status der 90er-Jahre zurückkommen wollte, das muss man schon sagen, ist ein großes Versagen auch von Leuten wie Kaya Callas, also die Außenbeauftragte der EU, dass man in dieser Art und Weise glaubte, Politik zu machen, moralisch dann immer natürlich auf der allerbesten Seite stand. Nur das hat sich mit der Realität nie gedeckt. Und das ist auch das, was Reisner den Europäern vorwirft. Und ich finde, das tut er zu Recht.
Dieser Täuschungssinn wird mehrere Jahre auflegen. Und ich habe das von vornherein immer gesagt, entweder man geht all in und nimmt die Sache ernst, aber man macht es nicht halbherzig, wie man es bis jetzt gemacht hat. Oder man sagt, der Söklansklammern ist nicht bereit. Da muss man das aber auch den Ukrainern sagen und muss sagen, okay, da müssen wir über das Friedensverhandeln durchführen. Weil das, was wir jetzt tun, aus meiner Sicht, ist höchst unmoralisch. Weil das verlängert aus meiner Sicht das Elend nur von Woche zu Woche, von Monat zu Monat, von Jahr zu Jahr. Und da sterben Zehntausende, Hunderttausende Menschen für einen sehr ungewissen Ausgang.
Und mit dem All-in-Gehen gibt es eben dieses Problem mit den Atomwaffen. Auch das hören wir jetzt gleich nochmal. Die Moderatorin fragt dann nach, ob dann jetzt verhandelt werden muss.
Also würden Sie sagen, es ist jetzt der Moment, in dem die Ukraine auch zustimmen muss, in dem es zu einem Waffenstillstand kommen muss, weil die Ukraine keine Chance mehr hat zu gewinnen?
Die Ukraine muss im Prinzip jetzt versuchen, genau und realistisch zu realisieren, welche Möglichkeiten haben wir noch. Ich gebe Ihnen ein historisches Beispiel in diesem Krieg betreffend, wo wir das bereits hatten. Und zwar bereits im ersten Jahr des Krieges, wenn Sie sich erinnern können.
Das heißt, das historische Beispiel ist aus dem Krieg selbst. Wir sind jetzt also im Herbst 2022. Da war die ukrainische Armee ziemlich erfolgreich.
Die Ukraine hat den Abwehrfolg bei Kiev verzielt. Sie hat den spektakulären Formus bei Haki verzielt. Sie hat es geschafft, die Russen bei Kasoni auf die andere Seite zu drängen. Da gab es dann auch diese russische Atomwaffendrohung, die man dann im Prinzip regeln konnte.
Das war genau der Punkt. Die Russen standen so ziemlich mit dem Rücken zur Wand. Und Biden und Scholz, wohl im engen Austausch, hatten sehr große Angst, dass Putin da jetzt diese Karte zieht. Und dann gab es ja auch von China aus die Mahnung, denkt nicht daran, macht das nicht. Ja, also es kam auch dann weltweiter Druck darauf, dass Putin das nicht macht. Also es war eine sehr heikle Situation, weshalb man auch die Zögerlichkeit von Scholz eigentlich noch mal sehr gut nachvollziehen kann. Und das war ja eine mit Biden abgestimmte Zögerlichkeit. Also es wurde ja immer hier als ein deutscher Sonderweg begriffen. Das war ja nicht der Fall. Die haben ja wirklich sehr eng zusammengearbeitet. Was sich ja auch noch mal zeigt in diesem Gefangenaustausch, den man dann machte, den man ja auch sehr zuliebe von Biden gemacht hat, wo dann Biden sagte, der Kanzler war unglaublich bei diesen Verhandlungen. Das heißt, er war ein sehr enges Band. Und das Interessante ist jetzt, dass Reisner, also jetzt sprechend über diese Zeit, noch einmal auf Mark Milley kommt. Und wir haben damals diese Rede, haben wir ja hier im Podcast gehabt, das war glaube ich November 22. Und er kommt jetzt auch darauf zu sprechen.
Aber wenn Sie sich erinnern können, damals war es so, dass der amerikanische Generalstabschef Mark Milley gesagt hat, und zwar für alle öffentlich auch, ja, aber beide Seiten haben jetzt ca. 140.000 Mann an Tod und Verbundung erlitten, plus die entsprechenden toten Zivilisten. Nach den Erfolgen der Ukraine wäre das jetzt genau der Moment, wo man verhandeln müsste. Und er wurde damals sehr gescholten dafür. Man hat ihm also vorgeworfen, sich quasi hier pro-russisch zu geben. Wie gesagt, Mark Milley war der damalige Generalchefschef der Biden-Administration. Es ist der Mann, dessen Bild Trump jetzt abhängen hat lassen im Pentagon, weil Milley sehr kritisch war gegenüber Trump. Aber da hatten wir ein gutes Beispiel und viele sagen, das wäre der Moment gewesen, wo die Russen am geschwächtesten waren, wo auch die Unterstützung Chinas und Anderen noch nicht so groß vor Bomen vorhanden hätte können.
Ja, damals haben wir uns noch gefragt, wann kommt der Film über Mark Milley? Und jetzt wissen wir mittlerweile, Hollywood ist tot und der Wind weht eh in eine andere Richtung. Ja, ja, aber das wird nochmal erzählen, das dauern wir nicht überhaupt.
Das wäre das interessante Werk. Und deswegen ist wohl jetzt eigentlich der Punkt da, wo man sagen kann, das wird nicht besser. Interessant ist ja auch hier nochmal, damals hätte man ja, wenn man sich darauf eingelassen hätte, auf Verhandlungen hätte man eben Scholz und Biden gehabt. Und jetzt hat man Merz und Trump und eine ganz andere Konstellation. Wer sitzt da auch gerade am Verhandlungstisch? Hier mal ganz kurz Kuppersbusch beim RBB dazu.
Denn im Moment redet Zelensky mit zwei Immobilienmaklern, mit dem US-Sondergesandten Stephen Witkoff und mit dem Schwiegersohn von Donald Trump mit Jared Kushner. Also da sind Bewegungen drin. Offiziell heißt es, es wird auch über Wirtschaftsthemen gesprochen. Und Zelensky, ja, das ist so eine feine Art der Diplomatie, postete ein Foto von den Gesprächen und da war auf einem Monitor zugeschaltet, der Chef von Blackrock, also der frühere Arbeitgeber von Friedrich Merz. Die sollen das organisieren, das amerikanische Unternehmen, viel Geld investieren in die Öl- und Gasförderung in Russland. Und das soll dann an Europa verkauft werden. Mit anderen Worten, an dem Tag, an dem Nord Stream 2 den Amerikanern gehört, ist es immer schon eine supergeile Idee gewesen.
In der Situation, so wie jetzt BlackRock sitzt damit am Tisch und verhandelt mit Kushner.
Genau, man darf das jetzt eh nicht zu verkopfen. Also Trump kommt aus dieser Great Deal, Great-Television-Richtung. Da gibt es keinen Verhandlungsausgleichs-irgendwas-Vergleich. Da gibt es nur Gewinner und Verlierer.
Ja.
Und das, was wir immer China unterstellten, die schauen sich das sehr genau an, wie es in der Ukraine läuft, um zu gucken, wie ihre Taiwan-Chancen sind. Genau dasselbe läuft gerade bei Trump mit Grönland, mit Venezuela und so. Das sind einfach keine Leute, die sich um irgendwas da kümmern.
Nee. Also deswegen wundert mich das auch, dass viele in der EU, also zum Beispiel auch Kaya Callas, immer noch so diese transatlantische Partnerschaft jetzt beschwört, wo sie doch eigentlich sieht, ihre Richtung, sie wird ja noch nicht mal irgendwo mehr groß empfangen. Also das interessiert die ja gar nicht, aber trotzdem hält man merkwürdigerweise daran fest. Und dann gibt es natürlich auch die Leute, die ja an was eigentlich glauben. Also die Werbeauftragte der Grünen Sarah Nanni hat jetzt getwittert, so einen langen Thread, meine diesjährige Reise ins Baltikum geht dem Ende entgegen. Und es ist mir ein großes Bedürfnis zu sagen, was alle längst wissen sollten, Russland bereitet sich auf einen Angriff gegen die NATO vor. Der Kreml schlägt alle diplomatischen Angebote aus. Dieses Russland ist unser Feind. So was machen wir jetzt damit? Sie sagt dann, der Überlebensdrang der Balten ist auch deshalb so groß, weil tatsächlich das Überleben ihres Kollektivs auf dem Spiel steht. Etwas, was wir uns mit 82 Millionen Deutschen gar nicht vorstellen können. Niemand wird uns alle ermorden. Bei 1,4 Millionen Ästen vielleicht schon. Und man fragt sich, also das ist ein Vernichtungskrieg, plant Putin jetzt und bei 1,4 Millionen Ästen sollen getötet werden. Was sind das für Fantasien? Dann schreibt sie zum Schluss, Europa wird überall demokratisch sein. Europa wird überall frei sein. Europa wird überall voller Liebe sein. Davon bin ich überzeugt. Freut euch drauf, es wird großartig. Was sind das für Fantasien?
Also ich weiß auch nicht, warum das in Europa keiner so richtig ernst nimmt und man hier so eine große Art draus strickt irgendwie. Jeder ist ergriffen von irgendwelchen Besuchen. Ich erzähle ja auch mal, wie es in der Sagrada Familia ist oder in Wien. Nur wenn ich jetzt ins Baldi-Kum fahre, schreibe ich dann auch sowas. Also mal sehen.
Ja, also ich meine, die treffen da ein paar Leute. Hier ein anderes Beispiel vom Parteitag der Grünen im November. Rede von Franziska Brandner.
Und schaut, was in der Ukraine passiert. Ich war vor kurzem dort. Ich habe viele müde Menschen getroffen. Jede Nacht Luftalarm. Keiner wollte aber aufgeben. Für ihre Freiheit geben die Ukrainerinnen, geben sie alles.
Sehr gut, ja. Also es ist wie in Hollywood Filmen. Keiner will aufgeben. Der Simon Dressler, der jetzt bei, ich hab's nicht gesehen, aber bei Fleischhauer war. Und ich dachte mir nach seiner Kritik, dass da zweieinhalb Stunden, wie nennt man das, es Caperoom veranstaltet wurde, aber nur 30 Minuten gesendet. Denke ich mir, ja, man hat wahrscheinlich genau die falschen 30 Minuten gesendet. Also ich hätte gern die anderen zwei Stunden, das Rohmaterial, aber das kriegt man wohl nicht zu sehen. Der macht immer wieder dieses Argument, das finde ich auch sehr gut. Die Europäer kommen jetzt immer mit diesem Werbpflichtsargument. Also jeder fordert einfach eine Werbpflicht, auch im Deutschlandfunk Jahresrückblick mit Robin Alexander und Anne Will und Ulf Bohrmeier. Um was geht es da wohl, Werbpflicht? Und diese Werbpflicht, ich mache mich ja immer drüber lustig, weil was hat mein Bizeps oder der meines Sohnes oder irgendwas, was soll der Unterschied sein? So und Bizeps und Menschen, die an diesen Bizeps hängen, braucht man natürlich für diese filigranen Aufgaben, für die das ja auch alles konzipiert ist, wenn man sich ehrlich eingesteht, wofür es konzipiert ist. Und das Argument entwickelt eben Simon im Gespräch mit, wie heißt unser CDUler, der immer allen voran der ehemalige selbst mal Generalbundeswehr Roderich Kiesewetter und fragt ihn, wird uns Russland angreifen? Kiesewetter drückt sich um die Antwort. Simon fragt nach, er wird uns Russland jetzt angreifen. Nee, sehe ich nicht so richtig. Ich sage Kiesewetter.
Ah ja.
Also stellt sich die Frage, wozu dann so eine Bundeswehr, die mit Schiffen irgendwie und wo so Leute drauf sind, naja, um das zu machen, wofür wir typischerweise Bundespräsidenten, wenn sie es aussprechen, feuern, nämlich diese kleinen Seewege freischießen, die die deutsche Industrie braucht, aber jetzt eben nicht mehr, das macht einfach nicht mehr Amerika. Wir brauchen es jetzt.
Wurde ja auch bei der Lage der Nation, wir haben es ja damals gespielt, so gesagt, dass man dann die Huttis zur Not in die Steinzeit zurückbomben kann. Also das ist die Aufgabe dann.
Genau, der Suas-Kanal muss erreichbar sein, die Huttis müssen halt zur Not weggeschossen werden. So, was bedeutet, all diese Bemühungen, die wir jetzt gerade sehen, sind ganz verlogen, weil sie mit Landesverteidigung gar nichts zu tun haben, sondern die haben mit Leuten, die auf Schnellbooten, mit Entscheidungsbefugnis irgendwie, sie sollen jetzt mal hier so ein Seeweg freischießen. Also so filigranes, handwerkliches Kriegszeug halt so. Landesverteidigung, finde ich, läuft ganz anders. Atomwaffen, große Schutzschirme, die organisiert und bezahlt werden, also wo wirklich Städte geschützt werden. Ich meine, wir haben jetzt drei Jahre diesen Krieg, drei Jahre lang, hier Strack Zimmermann, die Plädoyer hält und so. Die Deutschen kriegen es doch nicht mal hin zu regeln, wie einzelne Drohnen vom Himmel geschossen werden, falls mal wo eine auftaucht. Ist da jetzt die Bundespolizei, die Landespolizei oder irgendwer? Wer ist eigentlich zuständig? Die Bundeswehr? Die darf ja in Land nicht schießen und so. Also in Sachen Landesverteidigung hat genau niemand irgendetwas organisiert, außer so reinzuschreiben, Tagesordnungspunkt für die übernächste Wahl. Dann machen wir noch mal so eine Wehrpflicht, falls es mit den Freiwilligen nicht reicht. In der großen Hoffnung, dass es einfach mit diesen Freiwilligen reicht, um dann mal ein paar Vasehwege freizuschießen. Aber in Sachen Landesverteidigung fühle ich mich komplett veralbert von allen. Und klar, ich sage jetzt immer Atomwaffen, aber das ist ja nur mein Podcast-Argument, um einfach ein bisschen zu übertreiben. Wo sind denn die anderen Maßnahmen, um hier mal Landesverteidigung zu machen? Ich sehe das nicht, nirgendwo.
Kommen wir nochmal auf diese Idee. Also die Ukrainer, die stehen zwar müde, aber immer noch ganz gewähr bei Fuß und wollen nicht aufgeben. Das wurde jetzt von Brandner nochmal beschrieben. Und die Balken können wir uns ja offenbar auch als Kollektiv vorstellen. So hat das hier Sarah Nanja beschrieben. Also ich weiß, weil das nur 1,4 Millionen Ästen sind, dann denke ich mir, ist man mit 1,4 Millionen Menschen kollektiv? Ich denke doch eher nein.
Die Kinder sind eine Community, die Schwulen und die Ästen.
Ja, das ist doch so ein Unsinn. Wir wollen uns aber mal die Realität ansehen. Und ihr auch interessant, das ist ja jetzt Springer WeltTV. Und dort gibt es schon die Realität. Ich finde es schon interessant, dass wir eine Diskussion haben, wo man nicht sagen kann, die Realität ist nicht zu finden. Und man muss jetzt in irgendwelche obskuren Blogs gehen, um überhaupt mal zu wissen, was los ist. Nein, man kann auch einfach WeltTV sich angucken und sich fragen, sind die Ukrainer so kampfesbereit, wie Franziska Brandner das meint?
In der Ukraine gibt es einen neuen Negativrekord.
Das ist jetzt der Korrespondent Christoph Wanner.
Und zwar in Bezug auf Dessertionen, also Fahnenflucht. Laut den Angaben der ukrainischen Nachrichtenagentur UNYAN sind im Oktober um die 21.600 Soldaten abgehauen, das heißt haben Fahnenflucht begangen. Seit Jahresbeginn sollen circa 180.000 Mann desertiert sein und seit Kriegsbeginn circa 300.000 Mann.
Das ist eine gigantische Zahl. Wann errechnet ihr das jetzt mal vor?
30.000 Mann können die Ukrainer im Monat mobil machen. 20.000 Mann sollen Fahnenflucht begehen, circa nach Angaben der Nachrichtenagentur UNYAN. Dazu kommen dann die Verluste. Wie hoch die genau sind, kann ich nicht sagen. Vielleicht um die 10.000 Mann im Monat Tote und Verletzte. Und da sieht man, bei dieser Tendenz dürfte die ukrainische Armee schrumpfen.
Das finde ich sehr gut. Wir Europäer haben uns immer gewundert, was die Amerikaner mit ihrem Super Bowl haben. Von den 50 größten TV-Ereignissen sind 49 football related. Und das andere ist die Mondlandung. Und bei der Mondlandung war so ein bisschen klar, okay, das ist die große Schicksalsfrage. Schaffen wir es auf einem anderen Planeten, wie auch immer? Warum? Keine Ahnung. Hauptsache, wir haben es also sozusagen Meilenstein einfach, den man mal so macht, zivilisatorisch. Der Rest ist dieses Klein-Klein-Gehacke, wo typischerweise immer mega Berichterstattung gemacht wird zu er hat sich jetzt am Knie verletzt, er fällt vielleicht fünf Wochen aus, dann gucken alle schon in den Spielkalender. Was bedeutet das? Wird er gegen die Green Bay Packers wieder dabei sein oder nicht? Und dann heißt es, es sind doch sieben Wochen. Dann wird so klein-klein jeder kleine Muskelfaser so beurachtet. Hier 10.000 Mann, 30.000 Tote, 300.000 Desartierte. Ja, das ist wirklich eine Verrohung auch. Ja, dieser Krieg, also ich sag mal so, er kommt jetzt mit irgendwelchen Zahlen und sagt, das ist ja ganz dramatisch. Und ich denke mir so, ja, das ist alles wahnsinnig dramatisch. Ich kenne ein paar Leute und es wäre eine Lebensaufgabe, die an irgendeine Front zu bringen. Ich müsste die so lange überreden, zwingen, was auch immer und so. Man fragt sich so ein bisschen, wie klappt das da in der Ukraine? Wie geht das? Wie kann man 10.000 Leuten sagen, geht jetzt mal dahin, wahrscheinlich werdet ihr sterben, ihr habt ja alle Smartphones, also wir können euch ja jetzt nicht verheimlichen, was die letzten drei Jahre da passiert ist, so und trotzdem klappt es. Also wundert man sich irgendwann, wo diese Kräfte herkommt, die das ermöglichen, dass der Krieg überhaupt noch läuft. Alle wundern sich immer, dass er noch läuft. Ich frage mich, also dass er nicht endet, dass keiner Anstrengungen unternimmt. Ich frage mich, kann mal jemand eine Reportage darüber schreiben, wie groß die Anstrengungen sind, damit da noch Krieg ist?
Ja, sagt Waller hier auch.
Die ukrainische Armee versucht also zu mobilisieren, rekrutieren und dabei muss man leider sagen, greifen diese Rekrutierungseinheiten immer noch zu diesen unsäglichen Methoden. Gewaltsame Rekrutierung, das ist leider an der Tagesordnung nach wie vor hier in der Ukraine, das passiert nicht an jeder Ecke, aber es kommt eben regelmäßig vor und das Ganze ist der Bevölkerung ein Riesendorn im Auge, das läuft dann wie folgt ab. Die Rekrutierungsbehörden greifen auf der Straße Männer im wehrfähigen Alter ab, zwischen 25 und 60 Jahren und wenn die keine Freistellung haben vom Kriegsdienst, vom Wehrdienst, dann werden die in die Minibusse gestopft, häufig. Das Ganze heißt dann hier Bussi Ficazia, also rein in die Minibusse, dann auf die Kreiswehrersatzämter, soll heißen Rekrutierungsbehörde und dann ins Trainingslager und ab an die Front und das wird eben von vielen als reiner Fleischwolf bezeichnet.
Ja genial und jetzt wundern sich deutsche Journalisten, dass das in Deutschland komisch, dass die Leute das nicht so akzeptieren, wenn es heißt wir hätten dich gerne mal an der Front.
Ja, aber da sehen wir, da wird in der Demokratie Zwang ausgeübt in einer Weise, wie man sich das eigentlich kaum vorstellen kann, aber hier wird es ganz klar beschrieben und hier sind wir also in der Mitte des Mainstreams, wo das so berichtet wird und zugleich haben wir eine völlig verkehrte Debatte. Also das begreife ich nicht, man hat ja in der Vergangenheit immer wieder mal Debatten gehabt, wo man sagte, da wurden Informationen unterdrückt oder da waren die so randständig, dass das dann nur wenige wussten. Aber hier, das findet ja alles in der Mitte statt und trotzdem haben wir so eine absurde Debatte darüber oder haben wir solche Aussagen dann wie von Brandner, die dann sagen, die wollen aber weiter kämpfen. Wir hören hier nochmal aus der Rede von Franziska Brandner über die Friedensverhandlungen. Da weiß man auch nicht, wo soll es denn jetzt hinführen, wenn dir das nicht gefällt, was gerade stattfindet.
Aber was macht Trump? Er fällt ihnen in den Rücken. Während die Ukraine brennt, schmiedet dieser Nero aus Washington mit dem Wladimir einen Trump-Putin-Pakt. Das ist ein Unterwerfungspakt, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde. Das ist Verrat. Das ist München 2. Das ist eine Kapitulation des Westens durch die Hintertür.
Wenn man das so sieht, dann muss man aber jetzt wirklich das Gegenangebot machen können.
Ich würde da auch mal Konsequenzen draus ziehen, Frau Brandner.
Sie senden jetzt ein Signal aus Hannover. Das hilft den Männern in der Ukraine an der Front bestimmt sehr.
Nicht mit uns, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde. Wir stehen an der Seite der Ukrainerinnen und der Ukrainer, nie an der Seite des imperialistischen Aggressors, immer an der Seite der Angegriffenen. Und deswegen bin ich so stolz und so froh über diese Partei, die hier seit Jahren glasklar steht. Wir, wir sind die Partei der Selbstbestimmung. Wir sind die Partei des Völkerrechts und des Selbstbestimmungsrechts der Völker.
Wer hat denn noch mal gesagt, es gibt keine richtige Partei in der falschen Politik? Hier haben wir doch dieses dauerhafte Problem. Warum, also man hört sie ja auch in ihrer Methode, diese Rede zu gestalten. Warum glaubt sie denn, muss es, also warum bedarf es dieser Ansprache?
Ja, das ist eine Selbstbewahreräucherung.
Offensichtlich liegt ja strukturell etwas im Argen, dass man versucht wird, mit Semantik zu überdecken. Und jetzt könnte man ja den Versuch wagen, sich das strukturelle mal anzuschauen. Was auch bedeutet für die Grünen, die ja nun zu den etablierten Parteien gehören, dass sie relativ viel Verantwortung tragen. Zum Beispiel, ich will jetzt nur kurz, für Palantir-Einsatz in Baden-Württemberg. Man könnte ja vielleicht so eine Kommune auch anders organisieren als mit einer Palantir-Software von Peter Thiel. Ja. So, Ahad, ich würde gerne diesen Redenausschnitt hören, wo sie darüber spricht, was jetzt zu verteidigen ist, wie wir Bürger kommunalpolitisch an unser konkretes Lebensumfeld angebunden sind und wie wir das künftig verteidigen.
Also ich habe die gesamten 30 Minuten gehört und das kam nicht vor.
Kam nicht vor, okay.
Man fragt sich ja auch, also du hast jetzt eben das geschildert, in der Frankfurter Oper wird nochmal für die Ukraine gesammelt. So, dann wirst du da 20 Euro rein und stell dir vor, du würdest die 20 Euro nicht nur reinwerfen, sondern da nochmal sagen, ich stehe an der Seite der Ukraine und werfe jetzt die 20 Euro, dann würde jeder sagen, er ist verrückt geworden, nimmt ihn weg.
Ich spende ja sehr viel Geld, aber an solchen Hüten laufe ich ja ein bisschen verschämmt vorbei und gucke auch nur in die Augen.
Du hast ja auch nie Bargeld, mein Lieber.
Das kommt noch dazu, ich habe nie Bargeld. So, das ist wirklich, was sie fordert, was sie macht gerade, ist ja wirklich, dass der Strom geht raus aus der Oper und du drehst dich auf der Treppe nochmal um und brüllst ins Foyer rein.
Ja, ja, und mehr nicht. Und da ist keiner einzigen operiert.
Ich fühle mich jetzt so gut, ich habe mir nochmal ein Zeichen gegeben.
Und das machen wir eben jetzt seit drei Jahren so. Nur noch ein Ausschnitt aus dieser Rede, dann lassen wir es auch gut sein. Da geht es um den Föderalismus. Und wir hören mal so den Anfang.
Mein Lieblingsthema an alle Landesministerinnen und Landesminister im Raum.
Man denkt jetzt, kommt irgendetwas zum Thema Länderfinanzausgleich oder irgendetwas in dieser Richtung, aber...
Mein Lieblingsthema an alle Landesministerinnen und Landesminister im Raum. Unser Föderalstaat mit 16 Bundesländern. Wenn wir ehrlich sind, ganz schön häufig eine Bremse. Und wir brauchen Bundesländer, die kapieren, dass es nicht um München oder Berlin geht. Nicht um Mainz gegen Frankfurt, sondern um Europa gegen China, liebe Freundinnen und Freunde.
Und das lässt sie einfach so stehen. Also sie führt jetzt nicht aus, was sie damit meint gegen China. Ich habe es auch nicht verstanden. Also müssen alle Bundesländer jetzt zusammenhalten gegen China. Was heißt das? Wie sähe diese Politik aus?
Genau, also die grünen die ja immer so auf ein, ja die Bürger müssen sich wieder spüren, eine Wirkung, eine Effektivität im eigenen Handeln. Da ist es natürlich genau richtig zu sagen, du als Europäer kämpfst jetzt gegen China. Finde ich auch sehr gut. Ich bin ja am 9. Januar in Erlangen, um mit dem Oberbürgermeister Florian Janik dort zu reden. Und im Vorgespräch hat er einen wahnsinnigen Gedanken gemacht. Der ist so simpel, aber mir ist er selber nicht gekommen. Das ist wirklich so irre. Also ich bin eingeladen, um über die Kinderwüste, Familie zu reden. Und die Familie ist sozusagen diese Fallback-Organisation, die, ah ja, wir müssen gerade Betriebe schließen und Corona, Scheiße, Schule müssen auch zu. Macht mal Homeschooling, Homesoffice gleichzeitig so, ne? Alle Familien scheitern. Staatsminister steht daneben und denkt, na, wir haben dir doch 1000 Euro gezahlt. Wieso scheiterst du jetzt so? So. Und er meinte, die Kommunalpolitik ist im Grunde die Familie im Staat. Alle fallen aus, machen irgendwelche Fölle-Fans-Diskussionen in Berlin, irgendetwas. Währenddessen muss aber das echte Leben organisiert werden. Und das machen dann die Kommunen. Und die sagen einfach, sorry, also wir haben jetzt 30 Milliarden Miese und ich hab jetzt einen Apel und ein Ei, das war's. So. Wir wissen, dass wir eigentlich dafür zuständig sind, das hier zu machen. Und währenddessen läuft weiter heute schon mal mit irgendwelchem Bundes Champions League Theater. Kanzler hat halt eine Reise gemacht oder wie auch immer. So. Und das, was sie jetzt hier fordert, ist ja genau das. Du lebst in deiner Kommune, benutzt die Straße, die du halt vor der Haustür findest. Die Schule sieht halt aus, wie sie aussieht. So. Und im Fernsehen läuft aber das große Theater, März, Antrittsbesuch irgendwo. So. Und dann sollst du das, was da im Fernsehen läuft, ganz wichtig nehmen für dein Leben. Und auch ein bisschen übersehen einfach, dass du hier gerade nur von Appel und Ei, von Hand in Mund und lieber die Spatze auf der Hand und so weiter.
Ja.
Und man denkt sich so, nein, liebe Frau Brandner, wenn die Politik das kommunalpolitische Leben nicht geregelt bekommt, dann wird alles andere nichtig. Und mit nichtig meine ich wirklich gar nicht relevant. Dann ist wirklich ganz egal, ob die Alpen untergehen oder in China, was auch immer, wenn es in Stuttgart brennt, dann brennt es halt in Stuttgart.
So das ist wie, wenn der Weihnachtsbaum brennt, dann löscht man den Weihnachtsbaum und redet sich nicht raus mit im Keller ist doch auch schön oder im Dachgeschoss haben wir noch ein Zimmer frei oder irgendetwas. Wenn der Baum brennt, muss der Baum gelöscht werden und der Baum brennt halt. Sie steht da und hält eine Rede und macht einen Appell an die Landes- und Bundespolitiker.
Ja und die Landespolitiker sollen jetzt gegen China kämpfen oder was?
Die sollen nicht etwa nach unten denken, in die Kommune rein, sondern die sollen nach oben, nach China denken. Das ist ja wirklich alles genau falsch.
Wie sieht eigentlich auch diese Weltordnung aus, die einem da vorschügt oder wie will man sie in Stand setzen? Wird man also jetzt nach der Rede sagen, Russland sowieso ist unser Feind, USA wegen Trump ist unser Feind, China ist auch unser Feind, wie wir gerade hören, dann noch die europäischen Länder, die nicht liberaldemokratisch sind und noch die antiliberalen Parteien in Deutschland selbst. Also was ist denn das für eine Welt?
Das kann ich mit einer Pointe beantworten. Ich habe erst 20 Minuten von dieser Serie gesehen, Pluribus.
Das muss ich noch sehen, ja.
Aber das Prinzip ist, Aliens infizieren die ganze Menschheit mit sich und dann sind wohl alle einfach nur noch wir. Also dann steht Europa endlich als wir die Europäer und das war's, das ist der Satz. Und da drüben sind die Chinesen.
Ja, aber dann muss man sich wirklich abschotten mit ganz hohen Mauern. Dann muss man das Leben ausschalten. Ja, ja, ja. Wir hören jetzt mal einen Beitrag, schon zwei Monate alt vom Deutschlandfunk Europa heute über die Indoktrination, die in Russland erfolgt.
In Russland beginnt heute das neue Schuljahr. Zum Unterrichtsstart gibt es hier aber vor allem Indoktrination. In einem Schulfach namens Gespräche über Wichtiges werden Kinder seit Beginn der russischen Vollinversion gegen die Ukraine auf Linie gebracht. In diesem Jahr starten die Gespräche über Wichtiges sogar schon im Kindergarten, zumindest in ausgewählten Pilotprojekten. Gesine Dornblüt berichtet.
Immer montags nach dem fahnen Appell versammeln sich russische Schüler zu Gesprächen über Wichtiges. Das staatliche Institut für das Studium von Kindheit, Familie und Erziehung stellt das Unterrichtsmaterial dafür zur Verfügung, unter anderem Videos. Zum Schuljahresende vor drei Monaten gab es ein Video mit einem Rückblick auf die Inhalte der vergangenen Monate. Es ging um Liebe, Heimat und die Frage, wie man Erfolg hat. Andrei Kandraschow trat auf, Generaldirektor der staatlichen russischen Nachrichtenagentur TASS.
Das Wichtigste ist, die Heimat zu lieben. Wenn du die Heimat liebst, gelingt dir alles.
Super, so wir haben zum Glück in Deutschland Föderalismus. Bildungspolitik ist Landessache. Wenn das Bundessache wäre, hätten Kiesewetter aus Deutschland und Stragg Zimmermann aus Europa schon längst das Unterrichtsfach Gespräche über Wichtiges eingeführt.
Genau, und dann würde mal erklärt werden, wie das auch mit China zum Beispiel auch ist. An Vorschulen jetzt auch dann in Russland.
Von heute an sollen solche Inhalte auch russischen Kindergartenkindern vermittelt werden, zunächst in einem Pilotprojekt in ausgewählten Regionen. Erziehungsminister Sergej Kraftsov betonte vor zwei Wochen bei einem Pädagogenkongress.
Wir haben beschlossen, im kommenden Jahr die Vorschulerziehung in den Mittelpunkt zu stellen. Denn das ist ein sehr wichtiges Alter, in dem vieles angelegt wird.
Na ja, da kann man am einfachsten indoktrinieren.
Ja, und da haben die auch recht. Und wir können ja in Deutschland reflektieren, wir werden das auch gleich machen, beim Bürgergelddiskurs. Wir hatten jetzt in Deutschland einen Bürgergelddiskurs, bei dem nur gelogen wurde, sich um den Faktor 350 verrechnet. Das Gesetz ist jetzt da, da steht drin, es gibt keine Einsparungen, ab nächstes Jahr kostet es Geld. So. Wie laufen die berühmten Weihnachtstischgespräche mit dem Onkel? Da kommt nicht an, dass das alles erlogen und erstunken ist, dass sich verrechnet wurde, was auch immer. So, und das ist nur Fernsehen. Jetzt stellt man sich mal vor, man macht das im Kindesalter in der Grundschule.
Naja, es gab ja immer diese Idee, Wirtschaft als eigenes Fach, FDP hatte da immer das große Thema, wir wissen ja, wie dieser Unterricht ausgesehen hätte.
Also wenn wir Landesverteidigung organisieren wollen, dann als allererstes, wie schützen wir unsere Schulen? Dass die Russen und der Putin und die China irgendwas und so, aber da beginnt, da würde ich zum Beispiel einen Werteskurs beginnen.
Wie meinst du das jetzt?
Na ja, wie schützen wir unsere Schulen vor, dass der Kiesewetter mal wieder so eine Idee mit, ach so, die Soldaten sollten auch mal in die Schule oder was auch immer.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, aber so meinen die das ja nicht, die meinen es ja genau umgekehrt. Die Soldaten kommen in die Schule und den Kindergarten, damit Putin Angst bekommt.
Wenn beim Deutschlandfunk Diversität wäre und da nicht nur Anne Will mit Robin Alexander und Burmair über und so weiter, sondern wir da auch mal Worten mitzureden hätten, wäre das halt ein anderer Diskurs.
Jaja, das ist schon sehr eingeengt. Auch interessant diese Kollektivvorstellung, die da in Russland gepredigt wird.
Viktor Belinsky, Rettungssanitäter, Veteran der russischen Armee, sagte in dem Unterrichtsvideo, Es gibt keinen individuellen Erfolg.
Erfolg ist immer das Ergebnis eines Kollektivs oder der Gesellschaft.
Ja, ich möchte, dass wir dabei bleiben zu sagen, das ist für den Sportunterricht. Das machen wir bitte nicht grundsätzlich.
Aber wir hören dann ja auch Sarah Nanni, die von den Balken als Kollektiv spricht. Und dann fragt man sich, wir können nicht den einen Nationalismus durch den anderen einfach austauschen und dann ist wieder alles gut. Hier ein russischer Bildungsexperte im Exil schildert das mal.
Jetzt sagen sie, wir sind von Feinden umgeben. Und wenn wir nicht zuerst schießen, erschießen die uns. Jetzt sollst du nicht aktiv sein, sondern ein Schräubchen. Es gibt Putin, der entscheidet. Und du musst mit dem Gewehr in der Hand losziehen.
Die Indoktrination der jungen Generation zieht in Russland immer weitere Kreise, nicht nur an den Schulen. In der Jun-Armia, der Jugendorganisation der russischen Armee, werden zurzeit nach offiziellen Angaben 1,75 Millionen Kinder und Jugendliche an Waffen herangeführt.
Russische Verhältnisse haben wir noch nicht, aber wir bekommen zum Beispiel diesen Vorschlag von der CSU. Bayern 24 stellt ihn vor.
Wenn es nach der CSU geht, gehören das Zeugnis und die Hymne bald fest zusammen. Also Einigkeit und Recht und Zeugnis? Am Wochenende war CSU-Parteitag und da waren alle für einen Antrag, in dem Folgendes gefordert wird. Bei gesellschaftlichen Anlässen wie Schul- und Berufsabschlüssen sollen nicht eine, nicht zwei, sondern gleich drei Hymnen gespielt werden. Die deutsche Nationalhymne, die Europahymne und in Bayern auch die Bayern-Hymne. Die Idee? Die Nationalhymne fördert den Zusammenhalt in der Gesellschaft und ja, auch Integration. Außerdem glauben sie bei der CSU, dass man so patriotischer wird und dass sich dann auch mehr Leute freiwillig für die Bundeswehr melden.
Zum Glück sind die Deutschen extrem inkompetent geworden, obwohl sie das mal richtig gut konnten, denn...
Inwiefern?
Drei Hymnen bei einer Veranstaltung, wo es eh schon ewig dauert, bis jeder Einzelne auf der Bühne ist und so weiter. Dann will man eigentlich aufbrechen, die Familie ist auch schon da. Und dann soll man drei Hymnen hören und das auch noch gut finden. Ich bin sehr für diesen Vorschlag, denn wenn man die Melodie zu hassen lernen möchte, ja, dann genau in dem Moment, wo man sie nicht hört.
Ja, ich bin auch erstaunt darüber, dass man jetzt glaubt, so kann es dann gehen. Aber das sind die Methoden, die man sich abguckt. Dann sagt man, die reden auch schon so viel vom Kollektiv und bringen es den Kleinsten schon bei. Dann machen wir das doch auch schon mal. Fangen wir mal mit der Hymne an und dann können wir uns ja noch steigern. Entsprechende Serien werden ja auch am laufenden Band jetzt gerade produziert, auch stark vom öffentlich-rechtlichen Wies, denn eigentlich so bei der Bundeswehr zu sein. Dann gibt es dann immer so Clips, die in den sozialen Medien herumschwirren. Zum Beispiel gibt es die ZDF-Doku beim Bund. Da werden jetzt hier die jungen Rekruten hart rangenommen. Es geht um das Thema Rasur.
Haben Sie sich heute morgen rasiert, Hus? Nein. Warum nicht?
Weil ich so weit keinen Badfußball-Hand festgestellt habe.
Und warum erkenne ich dann da trotzdem noch Badhaare? So klein, wie Sie auch sind, Sie haben den Befehl bekommen, sich jeden Morgen zu rasieren. Wegtretend, nach und nach.
Jawohl.
Haben Sie sich heute morgen rasiert?
Nein.
Warum nicht? Ich habe nur gefragt, warum nicht, wie ich das sie sich anfassen soll. Ja. Korrigieren. Musst du ihnen was sagen oder fällt es ihnen selber auf? Den fällt es selber auf. Wegtreten. Hat hier irgendwer Einblickrasierer dabei? Wir haben hier einen Kamerad, der sie unterstützen kann in Zukunft. Fragen Sie das Ganze ab. Sehen Sie, wie schnell das geht?
So, ich würde sagen, ab IQ 83 erkennt man, dass es hier nicht wirklich um die Rasur geht, sondern um so ein Erniedrigungsritual, wie wir es aus allen Hollywood-Filmen kennen.
Ja.
Dass man hier einfach trainieren muss, nicht zu lächeln, noch den dümmsten Befehl einfach selbst auszusprechen.
Merken Sie es selber? Ja, ja, ich gebe mir selber den Befehl, ich rasiere mich jetzt.
Ja.
Und so. Ich glaube, bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber ich glaube, nach den Einblicken, die ich in die Jugend habe, diese Leute haben ja alle Smartphones. Und die Hälfte von denen, die da stehen, würde die Szene selber gerade gerne filmen, weil das einfach geiler Content ist. Und falls wirklich Leute glauben, gerade bei der Bundeswehr, beim Deutschlandfunk, weil sie mit ihren 55 Jahren denken, das ist eine gute Idee. Ja, ich habe ja schon gesagt, macht die Musterung, holt die Leute in die Kaserne, geiler Content.
Da darf man natürlich selbst nicht filmen, das ist das Problem.
Ja, das wird sich schon, also man kriegt jetzt nicht 10.000 Jugendliche dazu, dass wirklich gar keiner da einen Film macht, vor allem wenn bei den Sachen. Überleg mal, was heute erzählt wird von früher, wie es bei der NVA der Bundeswehr zuging. Stell dir das mal als Social Media Content vor.
Ja, da hast du recht, aber es gibt schon und das merke ich dann ja auch in vielen Beiträgen dieser Art, die ich mir ansehe in den sozialen Medien, einen großen Zuspruch dafür, dass Disziplin herrscht. Und es gibt ja sehr viele autoritäre Charaktere, die also sich gerne unterwerfen und sei die Anweisung auch noch so blöde. Das ist etwas, was sehr weit verbreitet ist, weshalb ich nicht davon ausgehe, dass es nur abschreckend wirkt, sondern endlich sagt hier mir nochmal jemand genau, was sich tun soll. Natürlich würden diese Leute, von denen du da sprichst, die im Deutschlandfunk rum sitzen, würden natürlich niemals irgendeine Anweisung über sich ergehen lassen und immer sagen, nein, ich bin ja ganz individualistisch und ich wähle alles selbst inklusive meines Geschlechts. Aber die werden aber schon Leute rekrutieren können, die dann am Ende blöd genug sind, dem, der den IQ von 83 hat, zu folgen.
Ja, warum war aber Werbpflicht irgendwann kein Erfolgsmodell mehr? Weil man doch weiß, und es ist ja organisatorisch, also sehr super einfach zu verstehen, um für sowas wie EIS, also um ganz Amerika aufzurütteln, so eine Vergrämungspolitik zu machen und so, reicht es, wenn sich 0,03% der Bevölkerung bei EIS bewerben, die werden dann organisiert, ausgerüstet, ausgestattet und fahren dann so rum und das reicht. So, das heißt, die Bundeswehr, wenn sie es wirklich schafft, das über Freiwilligendienst zu schaffen, dann zieht sie ja genau die an, die du beschreibst. Das sind einfach Leute, die fühlen sich endlich mal aufgehoben, die finden Kameradschaft geil, das ist dann auch, lieber tausche ich den vollen Schützengraben mit meinen Kumpels gegen das einsame Kinderzimmer, aus dem ich komme, wie auch immer so. Nur in Deutschland ist ja jetzt Musterung für alle. Was bedeutet, da gehen nicht einfach nur die 3% hin, von denen wir uns in ernsthaft Sorgen machen, sondern da gehen eben auch die 97% der anderen hin. Und da kann man, glaube ich, das Vertrauen in die Jugend haben. Die werden das schon ordentlich.
Naja, aber bei der Musterung passiert ja nicht viel. Also bei der Musterung gibt es ja nur so ein paar Eingriffe und Untersuchungen oder so.
Ja, aber das reicht schon.
Ich bin gespannt, ob du da recht hast. Ich sehe einfach diese jungen, aufgepumpten Typen, von denen es sehr viele gibt und denke so, ja, vielleicht finden die das Militär sogar ein bisschen geil. Ja, die jungen, aufgepumpten Typen.
Geh in eine normale Schule und schau dir an, wie viele aufgepumpte Typen es da gibt. Jetzt sagst du, das sind sehr viele. Ich sag dir, wenn du nicht dahin gehst, wo die aufgepumpten Typen sind, also 20 Uhr abends ins Fitnessstudio, sondern wirklich in die Schule, wo einfach alle sind, die Musterungsbrief bekommen, da werden dir die aufgepumpten Typen kaum auffallen.
Ja, aber zum Beispiel ist ja das Thema Fitness heute schon sehr viel größeres als wir zu den Schulen waren.
In den Medien, ja, ich weiß.
Nein, auch wirklich was die Mitgliederzahlen anbelangt. Als ich Abi gemacht habe, waren bei uns im Abi-Jahrgang zwei Jungs im Fitnessstudio angemeldet. Wenn du heute in einen Abi-Jahrgang gehst, dann werden dort 98 Prozent im Fitnessstudio angemeldet sein.
Das Gegenargument ist so einfach, Wolfgang. Zu meiner Zeit hat einfach jeder Vereinssport gemacht, jeder Einzelne. Ich kannte niemanden, der nicht jeden Tag in der Schwimmbad, Leichtathletik gemacht hat, irgendetwas. Weißt du, wie wir heute noch schwimmen und Leichtathletik gemacht? Niemand. Sport ist heute nur noch Fitnessstudio. Und ja, die Zahlen haben sich verdreifacht. Also statt zwei Prozent der Jugendlichen gehen jetzt, sagen wir mal, 20 Prozent sind angemeldet, zehn Prozent gehen regelmäßig hin. Aber das ist wirklich nicht vergleichbar mit, wie Vereinssport war, bevor die Schule da einfach gesagt hat, wir machen den jetzt in KA aus. So von daher, wir werden die Musterung bekommen. Wir werden das auch einfach abwarten, weil ich, es ist ja nicht nur, dass ich das mit dir diskutiere, sondern grundsätzlich. Die Jugend ist in einem Zustand, der Deutschland erschütternd wird. Und da wird dieses bisschen, aber es gibt auch so viele Leute, die im Fitnessstudio Videos von sich machen und so weiter und so fort. Wir werden diese Aufklärung bekommen. In Amerika nur diejenigen, die freiwillig sich bei Eis melden. Man spricht von der Athletikallergie, die man da diagnostiziert, weil kein Einziger in der Lage ist, mal sieben Klimmzüge zu machen. So, und das sind aber diese kleinen Voraussetzungen. Und das werden wir in Deutschland auch bekommen. Also ich bin sehr froh über diese Musterung. Wir haben nicht nur Musterungen jetzt verpflichtend für Erwachsene, also die sozusagen an der Schwelle des Erwachsenen, sondern wir haben ja grundsätzlich U-Untersuchungen.
Ja, ich will auch nicht sagen, dass alle Leute, die ins Fitnessstudio pumpen gehen, eigentlich potenziell Soldaten werden bzw. irgendwie was in sich tragen, dass sie autoritäre Charaktere sind. Das meine ich jetzt nicht. Ich glaube nur, dass dieses Fitnessdisziplin-Ding, was über die Influencer ja die ganze Zeit so betrieben wurde, und du hast dann auch so Leute wie Karl S oder andere Influencer, die jetzt gerade sagen, Mensch ist doch geil und steht dir das überhaupt durch, seid ihr richtige Männer und so weiter. Dass das schon Ansporn sein kann. Natürlich nicht für die, die eigentlich Kulturwissenschaften studieren wollen und dann Performance-Theater machen. Das sind die Leute, die natürlich später, wenn sie die entsprechende Position haben und die Preise vom Bundespräsidenten bekommen, noch mal sagen, gut, dass wir eine Wehrpflicht haben, aber ich selbst habe verweigert, weil ich ja irgendwie eine Künstler-Säle bin. Aber es geht ja eben um die, die man da erreichen kann. Ich glaube, dass es gar nicht so wenige sind. Vielleicht bekommt man sie mit was anderem aber davon abgehalten. Der Instagram-Kanal Bundeswehr Kompass greift folgendes Thema auf.
Sex bei der Bundeswehr erlaubt. Früher war sexuelle Betätigung innerhalb von militärischen Liegenschaften selbst nach Dienstschluss strikt verboten. Heute ist die Bundeswehr da deutlich rockerer. Solange der Dienstbetrieb nicht gestört wird und alle Beteiligten einverstanden sind, wird das Privatleben respektiert. Aber mal ehrlich, in deiner Grundausbildung hast du da kaum Zeit und vor allem auch wenig Privatsphäre dafür. Mehr Wettstuben, Dauerstress und unangekündigte Kontrollen. Ganz ehrlich, da bleibt nicht viel Raum für Romantik. Also ist Sex beim Bund erlaubt? Ja. Ist es realistisch in der Grundausbildung? Eher nicht. Aber in Zerdequellen haben wir verraten, dass wohl nicht so möglich ist. Aber was sagst du dazu? Sollte Sex in der Kaserne tabu sein oder ist es zu Recht erlaubt? Schreib mir deine Meinung mal dazu in die Kommentare.
Ja, also Sex ist gerade überall tabu.
Nicht nur bei der Bundesebene.
Man wünschte sich ja, dass die Leute mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Sex haben.
Bei der Bundeswehr. Dann spielen uns doch mal das, was du dann noch so so Herrliches hast. Zu dem Bereich Militär und Ukraine.
Genau. Wir hatten ja, also wir hatten so einen Clipsbreitklick von Ulf Bohrmeier. Die können wir aber jetzt, da wir sie nicht punktgenau in der Ukraine, lassen wir sie mal im Jahresrückblick, wo sie gleich hingehören.
Genau, wir spielen sie durch, ja.
Aber wir, ich sage, wir machen jetzt erstmal Bürgergelddiskurs. Okay. Denn es ist ja wirklich die Frage, was ist zu verteidigen? Und der Bürgergelddiskurs läuft ja auch auf einer Ebene, bei der ich sage, hier werden einfach Leute belogen. Hier wird ihnen, so wie ihnen die Ukraine, also Putin ist ganz gefährlich und wir müssen uns auch im Systemkreis gegen China demnächst militärisch werden, so wie ihnen das eingebläut wird, wie man so schön sagt. So wird ihnen ja auch verheimlicht, wie es ihnen eigentlich geht. Manchmal denkt man ja auch, die Politiker freuen sich gerade, dass sie so einen großen Feind haben, weil es da einfach selbstverständlich ist, über den negativ zu reden. Damit hat man schon mal gut Redezeit gefüllt. Also wenn man eine halbe Stunde Slot auf der Bühne hat und man darf 20 Minuten über Putin reden und weil er so böse ist, vielleicht sogar 22, dann bleibt eben nur acht Minuten für den Rest. Und der Rest ist aber eben, was wir in der Bürgergeld-Diskussion sehen. Und ich glaube, die Pointe ist ein bisschen anders als der Linnemann sagt, die Armen und Gebrechlichen sollen jetzt auch mal arbeiten oder die Rentner. Und er suggestiert ja, damit ist dann so ein bisschen der, was weiß ich, wenn man es jetzt pointiert, macht der Kalendereffekt ein bisschen ausgeglichen. Also falls mal wieder ein Tag mit mehr Feiertagen, ein Jahr mit mehr Feiertagen kommt, kann dann der, wie heißt er, der Wirtschaftsweisenrat sagen, aber zum Glück haben wir jetzt mehr Leute aus dem Bürgergeld rausgeholt. Das gleicht sozusagen, dass irgendwelche Feiertage uns rein ins BIP rein können. Der Bürgergeld-Diskurs jedenfalls ist so absurd. Es fallen tolle Pointen an, wie hier zum Beispiel.
Zuerst die offensichtlichste Änderung. Das Bürgergeld soll künftig neue Grundsicherung heißen.
Okay, das ist schon mal eine geile Pointe. Der Name wird geändert. Snickers heißt jetzt Twix. Ansonsten ändert sich nix.
Und die wohl größte Änderung sind die härteren Sanktionen. So hatte sie Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz von der CDU vor rund zwei Monaten nach einem Koalitionsausschuss angekündigt.
Wenn der Leistungsberechtigte einen ersten Termin im Jobcenter versäumt, wird unmittelbar ein zweiter Termin für ihn angesetzt wird.
So, da frage ich mich so ein bisschen auch hier, wie war es vorher? Also der erste Termin wird verpasst. Ich kann bis zwei zählen. Ich weiß, dass danach der zweite kommt. Ist einfach nur das Zauberwort unmittelbar oder?
Wenn ich einen ersten Termin im Jobcenter versäumt, wird unmittelbar ein zweiter Termin für ihn angesetzt wird.
Was wäre, wenn das Wort unmittelbar nicht, also wer einen ersten Termin verpasst, der kriegt dann einen zweiten?
So war es ja vorher auch schon.
Das ist die politische Neuerung jetzt. Auf eins folgt zwei.
Dieser Termin nicht wahrgenommen, dann werden die Leistungen in Höhe von 30 Prozent sofort gekürzt.
So, werden die Leistungen dann gekürzt? Wir hören jetzt mal so ein ganz kleines Nippel.
Und so steht es auch in dem Referentenentwurf, der dem Deutschlandfunk vorliegt. Wer dann zum dritten Mal nicht zum Termin erscheint und dafür keinen wichtigen Grund nennen kann, gilt als nicht erreichbar. Der Person soll dann zuerst der Regelsatz gestrichen werden, die Miete soll direkt an den Vermieter überwiesen werden.
So, die Miete soll ab dann direkt an den Vermieter überwiesen werden. Das halte ich für die ehrlichste Politik überhaupt. Also ich habe ja diese Vororte in der Kinderwüste auch schon gemacht. Warum zahlen wir Familien, die kein Geld haben, Geld, nennen es Wohngeld, damit die es dann den Vermietern bezahlen? Warum ist das nicht eine Sache zwischen Staat und Vermieter? Und lässt halt die Familie außen vor, so wie es halt ist.
Endlich mal Ehrlichkeit.
Das ist doch ein ganz ehrlicher Moment, dass man einfach sagt, ja, also dann ist die Familie außen vor, dann klären wir das einfach zwischen Staat und Vermieter. Dann ist es wirklich Verbietergeld, dann ist es kein Wohngeld mehr.
Wäre eigentlich auch gut, wenn dann der Vermieter mit dem Staat die Mieterhöhung klärt.
Genau, im Grunde ja.
Also es ist ja eine Subventionierung der Vermieter.
Also das finde ich schon mal sehr, sehr gut. Und jetzt Bärbel Bas.
Wenn der Betroffene sich dann immer noch nicht meldet, soll er aus dem System fallen und alle Leistungen werden gestrichen. Da geht es also um die sogenannten Terminverweigerer oder um Terminversäumnisse. Immer wieder betont Bundesarbeitsministerin Bärbel Bas von der SPD in dem Zusammenhang.
Wir wollen nicht die Falschen treffen. Das ist ganz wichtig. Psychisch kranke Menschen oder Menschen, die schwere andere gesundheitliche Hemmnisse haben, werden an der Stelle berücksichtigt und nicht sanktioniert.
So, das finde ich wirklich sehr gut. Diese psychisch diagnostizierten Fälle, die also dem Staat bekannt sein, weil einfach Ärzte oder Mediziner, Psychiater Diagnosen vorlegen. So, jetzt wissen wir aus dieser Forschung zu diesen Krankheitsbildern und ich finde leider diesen Text nicht mehr, weil Christina Huckelenbäuch hat zu meiner Zeit damals eine Glosse in der FAZ dazu geschrieben. Wenn wir Müttern, die aus Gründen der vor allem Zeit, also Überforderung durch Zeitmangel, sie haben alleine sind sie für ein Kind verantwortlich und müssen noch Erwerbsarbeit machen und so weiter und so fort, da geht einiges drunter und drüber. Wenn man denen das Geld, dass sie, wenn sie sich dafür qualifizieren, in Anführungszeichen, für eine Psychotherapie einfach auszahlt, also wenn man ihnen sagt, naja statt wir das jetzt zum Psychologen schicken, der mit dir ein Gespräch führt und dann rechnen wir ihm 100 Euro ab, geben wir einfach dir 100 Euro, so dann geht es diesen Leuten besser. Was hier bedeutet, Bärbel Bas möchte Rücksicht auf Leute nehmen für ein Problem, das sie ja überhaupt erst verursacht durch diese Politik, mit der sie dann Rücksicht nehmen möchte. Und das ist ja eigentlich absurd.
Naja, es gibt ja natürlich auch noch so psychisch kranke Menschen, die jetzt nicht dadurch, dass es irgendwelche Sanktionen gibt, zu einer solchen Krankheit gekommen sind, sondern die haben die einfach und die können dann auch entsprechend berücksichtigt werden.
Stell dir doch im echten Leben die Kaskade vor.
Was ich mich nur frage ist, wenn die sagen, bei den anderen fällt das dann auf Null, also man kann ja nicht Null Geld geben. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass man dann einfach nichts mehr bekommt.
Ja, deswegen widerspricht ja das Gesetz, wie wir es jetzt haben, komplett der CDU-Forderung, weil eben das kleine Eingestellnis gewacht werden musste, dass hier Ewigkeitsklausel 1 Grundgesetz greift und das Bundesverfassungsgericht die Politik zu diesem Felte schon mal darauf verpflichtet hat. Aber worum es mir noch geht, ist typischerweise ist es so, die Hälfte aller Alleinerziehenden in Deutschland, und wir reden hier von 90 Prozent Frauen, sind arm. Also leben einfach in diesen definierten Armutsschwellen, unterhalb dieser Armutsschwellen, wo einfach dieser ganze Kram mit Artikel 1, Existenzminimum und so weiter greift. Der Weg dahin ist ja wie folgt und zwar immer gleich. Diese Kinder werden in Ehen geboren, diese Ehen gehen zu Bruch. Diese Frauen sind nicht richtig abgesichert, vor allem durch deutsche Familienpolitik, die die Familie fördert und den Einzelnen halt nicht. Dann muss man umziehen, findet keine Wohnung. Die Wohnung ist viel zu teuer, also muss man das bezahlen. Also was nehmen alleinerziehende Frauen an als Beruf? Na ja, da sie sich ja tagsüber so ein bisschen um die Kinder kümmern müssen, gehen sie in diesen Raumpflegeberuf. Also ist der meist ergriffene Beruf für alleinerziehende Frauen. Sie müssen also arbeiten, während die Kinder dann aus der Schule kommen, weil du musst dein Kind gut in die Schule schicken. Das würde uns auffallen, wenn es da vorhungert und ohne Sachen ankommt. Aber wie es dem Kind geht, nachdem es aus der Schule kommt, ist ja Deutschland komplett egal. Also da ist ja einfach, keine Ahnung, also gibt es noch Essen in der Schule, darf das auch mal schmecken oder irgendwas. Ach, du musst mit der Bahn nach Hause fahren? Ja, sorry. Das ist ganz schwierig und so. Also ist alles blöd. Diese Frauen haben sich also sehr fröhlich verliebt, haben eine Ehe geführt, die ist zu Bruch gegangen, dann gab es berufliche Turbulenzen, jetzt ist einfach nur noch Armut. Das führt halt in Depression. Und am Ende dieser Entwicklung kommt dein Bärbel Bas und sagt, ja dich verschonen wir jetzt. Dich verschonen wir jetzt. Wir haben zwar alles dafür getan, dass du diese Depression bekommst, die wahrscheinlich auch einfach nur ein Burnout in Überlastung ist. Aber wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, du bist psychisch krank und so. Und jetzt verschonen wir dich aber. Und das ist einfach absurd. Hätte man diesen Frauen einfach dieses Geld gegeben, also würde man einfach jeder alleinerziehenden Frau tausend Euro mehr im Monat geben, hätten wir auch einen tollen nächsten Jahrgang. Ja, aber so ist halt einfach, ja gnädigerweise verschonen wir dich noch mal von den Sanktionen, die wir jetzt, das wirst du dann im Amtsblatt nachlesen können, weil kein Journalist guckt auf die Details. Also wirklich absurd. Wer diagnostiziert jetzt eigentlich?
Psychisch kranke Menschen sollen deshalb eine persönliche Anhörung bekommen, um ihre Situation erklären zu können. Das soll auch für Menschen gelten, die sich schriftlich nicht äußern können.
Also psychisch kranke Personen, die psychisch krank sind, weil sie ärztlich diagnostiziert wurden, wo man sagen könnte, ja, da sind wahrscheinlich schon so einige Gespräche gelaufen, bevor die Diagnose, müssen jetzt ins Amt, um dort noch mal in einem Gespräch zu erklären, dass sie psychisch krank sind.
Klingt für mich nach viel Bürokratie.
Ja, ist nicht vereinbar mit, sagen wir mal so genau. Also das kann man ja grundlegend sagen. Das ist nicht ganz vereinbar mit und so weiter. Okay, sollen Menschen in Arbeit bringen? Diese ganze Politik kennt ja eine große Floskel.
Ein Ziel der Reform soll es sein, Menschen schnell wieder einen Arbeitsplatz zu vermitteln. Deshalb sollen Jobcenter immer zuerst prüfen, ob es eine passende Stelle gibt. Betroffene sollen nur dann eine Weiterbildung machen, wenn sie sinnvoll ist. Aber auch die Sanktionen, so hofft es die Koalition, sollen Menschen dazu bringen, wieder zu arbeiten.
So, was wir ja seit Anbeginn haben, und das ist ja durchaus eine kleine Diskrepanz, sie betrifft ja Menschen, die vielleicht auch gerade gar nicht so an Arbeit denken können. Weil da gibt es erstmal andere Sachen zu regeln. Also arbeiten kann man dann immer noch, wenn man in der Lage ist. Und so, aber manchmal fallen ja Leute, und das sind ja nicht nur einfach, ich hab grad 12 Jahre Schule gemacht, ich mach das erstmal sabbatical oder ein Auslandsjahr oder was auch immer. Sondern das kann man ja auch mitten im Leben erreichen, dass man sagt, nee, das nächste Jahr kann ich jetzt wirklich nicht an Arbeit denken. Hier ist grad Schlimmes passiert oder was auch immer. Und wir haben aber diesen Bürgergelddiskurs, der ganz eng mit Arbeit verknüpft ist. Also das Schicksal der Menschen wird ja gar nicht, sondern es wird ja immer das volkswirtschaftliche Schicksal betont. Wir brauchen diese Leute im Arbeitsmarkt und die verdienen ja dann, also kriegen ja auch zu viel, das Abstandsgebot ist ja gar nicht usw. Und ehrlicherweise, und das halte ich auch für sehr wichtig, Elena Steilhaus geht ja jetzt auch voll auf dieses Argument, der Bürgergelddiskurs ist eine Drohkulisse. Und zwar nicht für diejenigen, die nicht arbeiten, sondern für die, die arbeiten.
Genau, nämlich die bekommen gesagt, pass ja auf, fordere hier nicht zu viel, lass dir nicht zu Schulden kommen, sieh zu, dass du diesen Job behältst. Denn wenn du hier rausfliegst, dann geht es dir richtig dreckig. Deshalb nicht an Streiks oder irgendetwas anderes denken. Das heißt, es geht um eine Disziplinierung derjenigen, die arbeiten. Zudem ist ja auch interessant, dass man hier bei den Bürgergeldempfängern immer nur daran denkt, dass das Einzige, was sie wieder zu wichtigen Bestandteilen der Gesellschaft machte, ist, dass sie sofort wieder arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten, während wir zu gleichen Diskurs haben, auch von denselben Medien vorgetragen, dass wenn sich irgendwie ein Popstar für ein Jahr zurückzieht und sagt, ich mache jetzt mal einen Sabbatical und mache ein Backpacking durch, weiß ich nicht wo, dann sagen alle vollstes Verständnis, toll und ja, hat sie sich verdient, freue mich, wenn du wieder da bist und schreib dir noch ein Buch drüber, ich bin da mal weg, ja, dann können wir dich alle noch mal begrüßen, dass du mal ein ganzes Jahr eine Auszeit genommen hast. Also wir haben einmal so einen Diskurs, der die ganze Zeit nur sagt, ja nimm dir mal die Zeit und zugleich haben wir aber bei den Leuten, die wirklich hart dran sind, den Diskurs, du musst aber ganz schnell wieder in die Arbeit. Und es suggeriert ja die ganze Zeit, so als sei das Totalverweigerer-Problem das dominierende Problem bei der Arbeitslosigkeit. Dabei wissen wir, es sind ein paar Zehntausend Leute, die man zu diesen Totalverweigerern zählen kann, je nach Zählung, aber es sind wirklich nur ein paar Zehntausende. Die anderen, die alle arbeitslos sind, sind es ja nicht, weil sie sich nicht bemühen, sondern es gibt die Arbeitsplätze nicht.
Oder sie sind einfach Kinder.
Es wird so getan, als wäre die ganze Volkswirtschaft und die gesamte Politik darauf ausgerichtet, Vollbeschäftigung zu schaffen. Also hier argumentieren alle, als hätte man den Keynesianismus zu 100 Prozent umgesetzt und wir haben Vollbeschäftigung. Wir wundern uns, warum manche dann noch nicht arbeiten. Das ist aber nicht die Realität. Die Realität ist ja, dass diese Arbeitslosigkeit da ist. Sie wird auch gerne genommen und wenn sie nicht genügend da ist, dann hofft man noch mal auf eine Zinserhöhung der EZB, damit die Nachfrage wieder schwächt, damit wieder neue Arbeitslosigkeit entsteht. Das heißt, das Heer der Arbeitslosen, das es gibt, ist de facto da. Und das liegt nicht an den Leuten, die nicht wollen, sondern es liegt daran, dass diese produziert wird. Wir haben keine Wirtschaftspolitik, die auf Vollbeschäftigung ausgelegt ist und jeder, der was anderes behauptet, lügt.
Also Vollbeschäftigung könnte man einfach organisieren, indem man überall diese Stellen einrichtet und diese Gehälter auszahlt. Das wäre gar kein Problem. Deutschland ist auch vermögend genug. Und ich denke, es gibt auch genug Aufgaben, die man mal einfach definieren könnte, als das läuft jetzt nicht nur Profitinteresse, sondern hier haben wir einfach ein Budget.
Und das würde die Gesellschaft bereichern.
Das würde die Gesellschaft aber so was von bereichern. So, und jetzt haben wir also einen Diskurs, bei dem...
Nur ganz kurz, um das noch zu sagen, warum wird das nicht gemacht? Das werden sich ja manche jetzt fragen. Dagegen ist ja die Privatwirtschaft. Die Privatwirtschaft ist sofort sauer, wenn der Staat jetzt kommen würde und sagt, wir bieten Vollbeschäftigung an, also wir beschäftigen die Leute. Denn dann steht ja plötzlich der Staat in einem Konkurrenzverhältnis zu den privaten Unternehmen. Bedeutet, wenn der Staat also dann ohne weiteres ganz ordentliche Löhne zahlt, kommt ja die Privatwirtschaft unter Druck. Und das will sie ja auf keinen Fall. Deswegen soll der Staat ja möglichst schlank bleiben.
Also ich hätte ja gesagt oder ich hab's ja auch gesagt, förder die Vereine, damit nachmittags für die Kinder was los ist. Das Problem ist nur, würde man da jetzt überall hauptamtliche Stellen schaffen, also irgendwelche Organisationen, die sich um die Kinder kümmern, dann fehlen diese Leute anderswo. Die sollen ja Schrauben für Wirt verteilen. Also gibt es kein Programm für Jugendliche, der nächste Jahrgang fällt so ein bisschen aus. Und jetzt versucht man, das Problem zu lösen, dass hier alle Leute so ein bisschen unmotiviert, unzufrieden mit ihrer Arbeitsstelle sind. Also dieser Bürgergelddiskurs betrifft nicht, sagen wir mal, eine Million Leute, die nicht arbeiten, obwohl sie doch in einem Alter sind, wo sie es könnten und müssten und wie auch immer, sondern der betrifft die anderen 45 Millionen, die arbeiten. Nicht ganz 45 Millionen, ist klar. Es gibt Leute, die, wenn wir, wenn wir es auch im Salon lesen, es gibt diese neue Klasse, die so ein bisschen drüberschwebt, so. Aber ich will noch mal daran erinnern, dieser Herr Peichel vom IFO-Institut, der ja auch mit mir im Balanz war, der schreibt wirklich besonders krasse Texts und hat ja auch vergangenes Jahr diesen einen Text geschrieben. Eine Familie in München lebt vor sich hin, egal, ob sie 2500 oder 4500 brutto verdient oder netto, weiß nicht genau. Also diese, es geht jetzt nur um die Zahlenwerte, zweieinhalb oder viereinhalbtausend Euro. Weil, sobald du in der Arbeitswelt drin bist, sagen wir mal, mit diesem zweieinhalbtausend Euro Haushaltseinkommen, greifen ja dann alle Lohnzuschüsse, Kinder hier, Wohngeld da und so weiter und so fort. Und du bist sofort auf so einem Niveau wie jemand, der 4500 verdient. Das bedeutet, in diesen 2000 Euro bist du in dieser Todeszone, wo du einfach komplett vom Staat abhängst. Wo dir also gesagt wird, ja, wenn du jetzt mit dieser Arbeit aufhörst, ist das alles weg und danach ist sozusagen die nächste Ebene, auf die du dann stürzt, ist ja, Frau Baas nimmt noch mal Rücksicht auf dich, wenn du psychisch krank bist. Aber dazwischen ist nichts. Also freier Fall. Und 4500 Euro ist bei uns am deutschen Lohnniveau. Also da sind schon ein paar Millionen Leute betroffen. Also dieser Bürgerhältniskurs ist so, sag ich mal, für 20, 30 Millionen Menschen relevant, denen einfach gesagt wird, morgen mal pünktlich zur Arbeit gehen.
Ja, sie müssen das noch mal gerade unterstreichen. Also was stattfindet ist, die Löhne sind so niedrig und die Lebenskosten sind so hoch, vor allem die Mietkosten, vor allem in Städten. Dass der Staat also die ganze Zeit diese Niedriglohnpolitik durch diese verschiedenen Maßnahmen subventioniert, bedeutet dann für die Leute, die die zweieinhalbtausend verdienen und die die viereinhalbtausend verdienen in München leben, dass es da eigentlich, was den Lebensstandard anbelangt, gar keinen Unterschied gibt, weil das andere muss eh der Staat unterstützend aufrechterhalten, weil die sonst wegbrechen würden als Arbeitskräfte. Als Arbeitskräfte bekommen sie aber nicht so viel Geld, dass sie als Familie in München leben können. Wir reden hier nicht von Luxus oder irgendwas, sondern einfach nur dort leben können und diese 30 Tage im Monat überleben.
Und deswegen sage ich, großer Moment der Ehrlichkeit, liebe Stadt München, liebe Stadt Frankfurt, überweis doch die Milliarden einfach direkt auf das Vermieterkonto. Warum nennt ihr es Sozialpolitik und zahlt es als Lohnergänzungsmaßnahme, Aufstockerei oder Wohngeld aus? Schafft diese ganze Ministerien ab, Bürokratie weg, einfach die I-Bahn des Vermieters aufschreiben, pro Klingelschild steht halt die I-Bahn drunter, dann geht so ein Polizist rum und guckt mal kurz, alles in Ordnung ist, schreibt die I-Bahns auf, und dann wird halt einfach, ah ja, der hat hier eine Wohnung, 1.000 Euro.
Es gibt auch immer von den FDP-Leuten oder von auch dem Verband für Steuerzahler und so was, diese ganzen Sachen.
Untersteuerzahler.
Cooler Verein.
Heute ist der 7. Juli, das ist der erste Tag, da arbeitest du für dich selbst. Das kann man wunderbar mit Vermietern machen. Man kann dann auch sagen, heute ist der 30. Mai.
Nein, nein, nicht der 30. Mai, heute ist der 24. Dezember, ab jetzt wohnst du für dich.
Ja, man kann das wirklich sagen. Also was da an Miete draufgeht und gerade in den Städten, kann man das wunderbar so ausbuchtabieren.
Ich denke immer, die CO2-Subventionen sind hoch, aber die Wohn- und Arbeitsaufstockersubventionen, wow, wow, wow. Also da sind wir wirklich hunderte Milliardenbereich. Gut, wir haben also beim Bürgergeld-Diskurs nur Gefühlspolitik, die dich einfach zur Arbeit treiben soll. Linneman sagt sogar selber, ja, ja, das ist nur Gefühlspolitik.
Nun liegt der Gesetzentwurf zur Reform des Bürgergeldes vor und macht folgende Rechnung auf. 2026 sollen in Bund, Ländern, Kommunen und bei der Bundesagentur für Arbeit rund 86 Millionen Euro gespart werden. Später soll dann aber die Reform sogar bis zu 11 Millionen Euro kosten.
So, also wir sind jetzt ja in diesem Moment, wo allen in Deutschland gesagt wird, ihr wurdet belogen. Ihr habt den Fernseher eingeschaltet, Leute haben Sachen gesagt, alles war gelogen.
Es war ja immer von Milliarden die Rede.
30 Milliarden, da geht es los.
Wir sind jetzt bei 86 Millionen, aber es wird wohl noch 10 Millionen kosten.
Genau, aber dann kostet es. Also alle, alle wurden hier einfach komplett belogen. Jetzt kommt einfach der nächste Linnemann-Otto.
Also heißt es aus dem Bundesarbeitsministerium, dass die Reform des Bürgergeldes unter dem Strich nicht zu nennenswerten Einsparungen führen würde. Und so kommt es nun für den Generalsekretär der CDU, Carsten Linnemann, nicht mehr aufs Sparen an. Eine Prognose, wie viel tatsächlich entlastet werden könne, sei schwierig, sagte er im Interview mit dem Deutschlandfunk.
Das kann niemand voraussagen, aber ich rechne damit, dass die Menschen, und das ist zunächst einmal das Wichtigste, das Sozialsystem wieder als gerecht empfinden. Das ist ja das Hauptziel, dass die Menschen das Gefühl haben, ich zahle Steuern und zwar vielleicht sogar gerne, wenn ich weiß, dass der Sozialstaat mit dem Geld vernünftig umgeht.
Ziel der Reform ist es, dass mehr Menschen wieder arbeiten.
Der Sozialstaat geht sich so vernünftig damit um, er beweist es jetzt direkt dem Vermieter. Er beginnt bei den Allermsten.
Und die Gerechtigkeit ist ja stattdessen 86 Millionen werden zumindest im ersten Jahr gespart werden. Also man hätte auch sagen können, um Gerechtigkeitsförder müssen alle die Bürgergeldempfang, Clownsschuhe tragen, damit immer die erkennbar sind und sich ein bisschen schämen. Das ist einfach gerechter. Das wäre genauso unsinnig.
Es gibt so zwei Gruppen in Deutschland, die können einfach ihr Einkommen selbst festlegen. Einige sind Bundestagsmitglieder mit einem Bundestagsbeschluss. Sie sagen einfach, ich brauche jetzt einen Hartz-IV-Satz mehr. Ich brauche jetzt 15 Hartz-IV-Sätze pro Monat. 20 wären besser nächstes Jahr dann. Das andere sind die Vermieter. Miete ist einfach teurer. Der Staat zahlt ja. Also das ist wirklich genial. Dieser kleine Snippet, wir haben ihn beim Lifestyle auch schon angesprochen. Wir müssen es einmal im Original anhören. Also die Deutschlandfunk-Tageszusammenfassung vom 17.12. in den ersten Sekunden. Deutschlandfunk, das war der Tag.
Es passiert selten, dass wir hier im Deutschlandfunk unsere eigenen Kolleginnen und Kollegen zitieren. Normalerweise geht es hier um O-Töne von Politikern. Aber das, was meine Kollegin Sandra Schulz heute in den Informationen am Morgen im Interview mit Carsten Linnemann, dem CDU-Generalsekretär gesagt hat, das fasst sehr gut zusammen, wo wir stehen in der Diskussion über die Bürgergeldreform.
Das ist jetzt echt stressig, Herr Linnemann, mit Ihnen auf eine Faktenbasis zu kommen.
Ja, es ist jetzt echt stressig, mit Ihnen auf eine Faktenbasis zu kommen. Das ist einfach absurd. Also was hier abläuft zum Thema ist einfach, man kann es sich nicht ganz vorstellen. So, der Deutschlandfunk dachte sich dann, ach komm, wir holen uns mal einen Experten, Stefan Sell von der Hochschule Koblenz.
Ja.
Also aus deiner Ecke.
Und zwei Aspekte werden dabei...
Kennst du ihn?
Ja, der hat doch bei Twitter immer viel dazu geschrieben zu der Thematik, oder?
Ah ja, ich kann ja nicht.
Und zwei Aspekte werden dabei dann zentral sein. Einmal das Thema Gerechtigkeit, Menschen, die arbeiten können, die sollen das auch tun. Und ein anderes Mal das Thema Geld. Über beide Punkte habe ich vor der Sendung mit Stefan Sell gesprochen. Er ist Sozialwissenschaftler an der Hochschule Koblenz. Guten Abend, Herr Sell.
Guten Abend.
Fangen wir mal an beim Geld. Carsten Lindemann hat heute Morgen bei uns im Deutschlandfunk gesagt, dass niemand so genau weiß, wie viel Geld man jetzt mit der Reform einsparen wird. Deswegen die Frage auch an Sie, wissen Sie das vielleicht?
Ja, das weiß ich ziemlich genau. Also gar nichts.
Gar nichts, weiß ich ziemlich genau. So, ich will jetzt nicht einen zu großen Exkurs machen. Aber wir haben diese KI's, von denen ich ja immer sage, diskutiert doch erst mal mit der KI bevor und so weiter. Diese KI's zeichnen sich vor allem durch eine Kompetenz richtig gut aus. Sie können Code schreiben. Während wir einfach so eine motorische, liebes Google, wie ist denn der Bürgergeldeskurs und so weiter und so fort, diese KI's schreiben das einfach kurz als Code. Dann läuft so ein Programm durch und sucht einfach die Informationen aus dem Internet zusammen. Was bedeutet, jeder Einzelne, der heute in der Lage ist, einen guten Prompt zu schreiben, hat dieselben nämlich unendlich Möglichkeiten wie jeder andere Mensch auch. Also man braucht keine Mega-Organisation mehr, um einfach an eine Information zu kommen, die man halt, da reicht es nicht zu googeln, das muss man aus dem Internet scrapen oder irgend sowas. Das kann doch jeder. Deswegen bin ich sehr dafür, dann macht das bitte einfach mal jeder jetzt. Und genauso wie die KI, die einfach das alles ermöglicht, weil sie die Sprache des Computers spricht, so müssen wir auch an diese Diskurse hier rangehen. Die Sprache der Politik ist nicht Gefühle oder irgendeine Semantik oder so, sondern das ist einfach Verbote und Geld. So, und wenn die Politik es nicht schafft, das mit dem Geld zu organisieren, dann ist sie einfach nichts wert. Ist schön, dass Herr Linnemann noch irgendwas zum Thema Gerechtigkeit und Gefühle. Ich hätte gedacht, okay, das kann man vielleicht sonntags in der Kirche klären oder so. Kommt ja auch mal drauf an, wer hat welches Gefühl zu Gerechtigkeit und so, sondern das mit dem Geld muss halt stimmen. Und wenn ein Experte nach hundert Diskussionen im Bundestag, im Fernsehstudio und so weiter einfach sagt, ja, also jetzt ja, neigt sich dem Ende, wir ziehen jetzt mal Bilanz, null. Dann ist das einfach die komplette Bankrotterklärung dieser demokratischen Versuche, hier was zu regeln.
Nur kommt das ja bei den meisten Menschen eben nicht an, diese Expertenmeinung, da du hast ja eben schon angesprochen, über was wurde da mit dem Onkel unterm Tannenbaum gesprochen, sondern wenn du dir dann die Posts dazu ansiehst, und es gab ja jetzt gerade auch noch von dieser Reality-Tante Claudia Obert, die ja auch sich als Unternehmerin emageriert, so ein Statement, in dem sie sagt, und die sollten gar nichts mehr bekommen, wer nicht zur Arbeit geht, wer faul ist, bla, bla, bla. Und die ist ja auch bei so CDU-Veranstaltungen dann zu Gast. Und du hast dann da ein Publikum, das ihr applaudiert. Dann siehst du einfach, es gibt einen ganz, ganz großen Teil der deutschen Bevölkerung, der sich losgelöst hat von jeglicher Realität. Also wenn wir die ganze Zeit immer über Fake News und Fakten und so ein Kram reden und dann immer ja der Trump, der trollt und der Putin, der kommt hier über irgendwelche windigen Kanäle und manipuliert unsere Wirklichkeit. Nein, die Wirklichkeit der meisten Leute ist bereits vollkommen losgelöst. Alles, was wir dort erleben an Diskurs in den letzten Monaten, ist auf einer reinen Simulationsebene. Also da ist Strackzimmermann fast nur auf dem Boden der Realität dagegen.
So und deswegen werbe ich so dafür zu sagen, wir machen jetzt, also wir zwingen jetzt mithilfe der KI, einfach politisch Bilanz zu ziehen. Also wie heißt die noch mal, die Influencerin, die da einfach Claudia...
Claudia Obert.
Claudia Obert. Also wenn Claudia Obert in einem Gespräch sagt, ja ja, alle faulen müssen jetzt mal ran. So, dann sagt man einfach, und dafür braucht man noch nicht mal, also man kann jetzt simulieren, ich simuliere das, was Gemini sagt auf den Prompt, wenn ich einfach frage, okay, die Politik hat gefordert, alle faulen müssen zur Arbeit, dann hat sie ein Gesetz geschrieben, das dazu führt, dann hat man das Gesetz durchgerechnet. So, das heißt, anhand, liebes Gemini, anhand der Ersparnis wissen wir doch, wie viele Leute wirklich faul waren. Und die Antwort ist einfach null. Also wenn wir kein Geld sparen durch eine Politik, die die Faulheit austreibt, dann war vielleicht niemand faul. Ja. So, das war einfach meine Rechnung eins plus eins ist zwei. Habe ich ohne Gemini hingekriegt. Kann doch noch selber nachdenken. Ja, aber es ist auch nicht sehr kompliziert, was die CDU und Bärbel Bars dabei haben.
Ja, aber du siehst ja, dass es funktioniert.
Es funktioniert wunderbar und es nervt mich so ein bisschen, weil auch in unseren Kommentaren dann immer auch Stefan und die KI und überhaupt und so. Unsere Gesellschaft wäre so viel besser, wenn einfach jeder erst mal kurz mit einer KI klärt, was ihm auf dem Herzen liegt, statt seine Semantik einfach so in so einen Raum reinzubrüllen. Bei einer Abendveranstaltung auf. Das ist ja irre, da sitzen 200 Leute im Raum und jemand steht hinten auf und labert einfach Scheiße. Also wie geht denn das? Also 2026 willst du jetzt nicht mehr erleben. Ja. Okay, ich werde in Erlangen anfangen, den Leuten zu sagen, frag nochmal dein Handy. Du kriegst in 10 Minuten wieder einen Slot, stell die Frage, wie du sie gestellt hast, nochmal in dein Handy und dann nochmal.
Ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, ja.
Weil so geht es nicht mehr. Also das ist einfach, wir sind jetzt an dem Punkt, wo wir ein Jahr Bürgergeld-Diskurs hatten, das darf sich, also das Jahr 2025 darf sich nicht wiederholen. Der Herr Selle ist noch ein bisschen weiter im Gespräch.
Dann noch eine letzte Frage an Sie, Herr Selle, mit der Bitte um eine kurze, knappe Antwort. Welche Effekte hat es denn, dass da, wir haben gerade von der kleinen Gruppe gesprochen, dieser Totalverweigerer, von denen in einer öffentlichen Debatte häufig die Rede ist. Welche Effekte hat das, dass in der öffentlichen Debatte häufig generell Menschen, die Bürgergeld empfangen, quasi in Kollektivhaft genommen werden für die, die Verhaltensweisen dieser Totalverweigerer?
So, er bittet um eine kurze Antwort und labert selber noch 20 Sekunden für seine Frage, die wirklich jeder versteht.
Das ist der wundeste Punkt, den Sie da ansprechen. Es hat einen wirklich ganz destruktiven Effekt auf die vielen, vielen anderen Menschen, die sich im Grundsicherungsbezug befinden und die sich an die Regeln halten, weil die werden tatsächlich in Kollektivhaft genommen. Die werden beschämt in ihrer Hilfesituation, die wirklich auch gegeben ist. Und ich darf mal daran erinnern, wir haben hunderttausende alleinerziehende Mütter, die sehr wohl eine wichtige Arbeit leisten, die aber armutsbedingt in der Grundsicherung sind. Wir haben pflegende Angehörige, wir haben 800.000 Aufstocker, die arbeiten und trotzdem Leistung beziehen müssen.
Ja, ich wünsche mir das 2026 im Diskurs. Also gerade jetzt, ja, alle warten auf den nächsten Jahrgang. Also muss man jetzt über den nächsten Jahrgang reden. Ja. Und zwar so. Das ist eigentlich gar nicht so schwer. Aber man ergibt sich ja ungern mit den Verlierern der Gesellschaft und so. Man will ja mal auf der Siegerseite sein. Deswegen redet man über die ganze Zeit mit Linneman, weil er ja so ein krasser Gewinner ist. Hat es ja voll geschafft, ist Generalsekretär der CDU geworden.
Ja, er hat ja im Prinzip auch nur immer auf Staatsgeld gelebt.
Im Grunde ja.
Jaja.
Linneman, wir rechnen das jetzt mal durch. Sie sehen zwar aus wie 13, aber sie sind 60. Was hat es eigentlich gekostet?
Ja.
Was hat es gekostet, sie so weit zu bringen hier? Und wer hat dafür bezahlt? Presseschau, gut.
Die Lausitzer Rundschau sieht es ähnlich. Wie Ökonomen seit Jahren kritisieren, sind es die strengen Hinzuverdienstgrenzen sowie das Zusammenspiel von geringem Lohn und Sozialleistungen wie Wohngeld und Kinderzuschlag, die eine Aufnahme von Arbeit oder Mehrarbeit unattraktiv machen. Wie man das lösen könnte, ist längst bekannt. Die Taz hingegen warnt vor den Folgen für Kinder. Zwar werden offiziell nur die Regelsätze der Eltern gekürzt, Kinder werden aber indirekt für das Verhalten der Eltern mit bestraft. Die Bundesregierung beweist mit dieser Reform, wie wichtig ihr die Bekämpfung von Kinderarmut ist. Absolut gar nicht.
Also die familienpolitische Bilanz war ja schon unter der Ampel schlecht. Aber die hatten wenigstens die Ambition und einen Zeitplan. Und dann hat Linden erst reingeschossen und dann hat Linden auch noch mal richtig reingeschossen. Aber jetzt gibt es ja gerade gar keine Ambition für irgendetwas. Null.
Aber es gibt ja auch keinerlei Widerstand innerhalb der SPD mehr. Das ist ja auch interessant.
Ja, also es ist wirklich crazy zu sehen, während wir gleichzeitig diesen Wehrpflichtsdiskurs haben, der sich um diese Leute dreht, wie man genau gar nichts für sie macht. Also gar nichts.
Aber schau doch mal diese, diese Jungen bei der SPD, die sind ja auch, weißt du, die dann auch so komische Agenturen machen, um Parteiewahlkämpfe zu organisieren und soetwas. Oder die von der Bundes-Schüler-Konferenz, das sind ja auch so Hainis in der Regel.
Die anderen waren bei den Grünen.
Das sind ja, das sind ja alles Leute, die bei SPD oder Grünen sind. Und die haben das ja auch gar nicht als Thema. Also die reden ja auch inzwischen nur davon, wie können wir uns konstruktiv einbringen in die Wehrpflichtsdebatte. Das heißt, wir wollen Wehrpflicht, aber wollen auch mal irgendwie kurz mitreden. Und von diesen ganzen Agentur-Hainis der SPD kommt auch nur Wehrpflicht. Und wir müssen das Baltikum verteidigen. Aber die reden auch nie über Sozialismus mehr, weil die jetzt auch nun ihr paar Aufträge bekommen haben aus Berlin-Mitte. Und damit ist jetzt gut. Also da kommt, von da kommt nichts mehr. Du hast keine existenten Usos im Prinzip mehr. Also ich weiß überhaupt gar nicht, wer da noch, ach Türmer ist der Vorsitzender, aber kriegt man auch nicht mit. Macht man sich mal ein Instagram-Video zum Thema Reichtum besteuern, wissen wir auch alle, das kommt nie. Also das ist ja völlig aus der Ofen.
Wir müssen eigentlich das ganze Prinzip umdrehen. Vielleicht mein Buchprojekt für dieses nächste Jahr, keine Ahnung. Ich lass das vor mir selber. Ne, dieses kommunalpolitische, es ist ja genau falsch rumgebaut. Deutschland ist genau falsch rumgebaut. Wenn wir von jungen Leuten im Bundestag reden, dann sind das ja, sagen wir mal so 25- bis 35-Jährige, die ja eigentlich mitten im Leben für ihre Peergroup zu Hause was regeln sollten. Stattdessen nimmt man die Engagiertesten und sagt sie, ja, ja, du hast jetzt eine erste Klasse, Bahncard 100, fahr weg, fahr nach Berlin, mach irgendwas und freu dich darüber, wenn du im Fernsehen vorkommst. Und dann arbeitet man drei Wochen darauf hinaus, dass man für zehn Minuten im Fernsehen ist. Und das ist der Erfolg von Politik. Und das ist natürlich genau falsch rum. Also wirklich genau falsch rum.
Ich dachte schon, du wolltest jetzt ein Buch über die jungen Wilden in der Politik schreiben. Nein, also Kommunalpolitik, da wäre ich sehr dafür, dass man da was aufschreibt. Aber wie gesagt, da ist ja überhaupt gar kein Widerstand mehr zu erwarten.
Gar nicht.
Und es ist auch niemand mehr da. Also alles, was vielleicht noch ein bisschen mal diesen Konsens gestört hätte, ist ja nicht behörbar.
Also sehr viel von diesem Kram, Bürgergeld und so, das ist ja alles Bundesangelegenheit.
Ja.
So. Haben wir ja gehört im Salon, die Kommune muss es dann ausbaden, aber darf nicht mitreden, sondern das ist ja alles Bund und Land. So. Das heißt, im Bund machen Leute Politik, die, sagen wir mal, so 50 geworden sind und sich vor allem dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie schon vor 30 Jahren den Kontakt zur Realität verloren haben, weil sie einfach Berliner Bundespolitik gemacht haben. Berliner Bundespolitik hat mit der Realität einfach gar nichts zu tun. Man redet dort nicht ohne Grund vom Raumschiff. Man denkt, man mischt sich jetzt ein, wenn man mit dem Zug durch die Ukraine fährt. Können wir mal mit dem Zug durch eure Heimat fahren? Das wäre vielleicht mal eine Idee.
Das muss ich auch sowieso mal sagen für 2026. Ich will einfach niemanden mehr hören, der sagt, ich war da und dort und habe mit den Menschen gesprochen. Wir sind in Deutschland 83 Millionen Menschen. Es wäre vollkommen irre, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich habe mit den Bayern gesprochen, weil ich mal ganz kurz in München gewesen bin und am Bahnsteig mit jemandem gelabert habe. Wenn irgendjemand mit einer Stiftung, der NGO oder mit der Bundesregierung selbst in die Ukraine, nach Brasilien oder nach China fährt, dann kann man nicht sagen, ich habe mit den Chinesen in den Ukraine gesprochen oder so. Das ist Unsinn. Und man bekommt ja sowieso nur die Leute vorgeführt, die man kennenlernen soll. Ich bekomme das aber auch mit. Also das geht ja bis in die Linkspartei, dass die irgendwo auf zwei Ukrainer vom Militär treffen und danach nach Hause kommen und dann sagen, ja doch, ich habe es jetzt auch eingesehen, wir müssen jetzt aufrüsten. Also das sind solche Begegnungen, die können wir auch rein simulieren und dann könnt ihr euch irgendwas Emotionales daraus mitholen. Es ist völlig idiotisch, auf so eine Argumentation zu gehen. Es ist Welt nicht so erfahrbar, dass ich sage, ich habe mal zwei getroffen und jetzt weiß ich das. Wir haben uns das eigentlich genau abgewöhnt, so nicht drüber zu reden, dass wir nicht sagen, weil wir mal zwei da gesehen haben, sind die jetzt alle so. Das ist eigentlich das, was am naheliegendsten ist, wenn man zum Beispiel Rassismus vermeiden will und all das. Man kann nicht sagen, ich habe zwei getroffen und deswegen sind die Italiener jetzt so. Das heißt, wenn ich noch einmal, das überflippe ich wirklich aus.
Aber der Heiner Grabe aus Dortmund, der viertplatzierte da von der AfD bei der Urhebergemeisterwahl, ist ja der Heimat treu verbunden geblieben, als er dann immer in die Welt reiste.
Ah ja, auch schön.
Da gilt einfach das Silicon Valley Prinzip. Christoph Käser hat das damals in einem Buch sehr gut aufgeschrieben. Silicon Valley gibt es jetzt eine Sache, die kennen wir alle. Mark Zuckerberg schickt seine Kinder auf eine von ihm selbst gegründete Montessori-Schule und niemand hat ein Smartphone. Während die ganze Welt in seine Smartphone-Hölle geschickt wurde. Da könnte man ja schon mal stutzig werden. Das zweite Prinzip ist, das Silicon Valley verbindet immer die ganze Welt. Also wir fahren hier in Frankfurt mit einem Taxi, weil irgendwann Silicon Valley eine Idee hatte. Was haben wir mit dem Silicon Valley zu tun? Die haben uns eine Taxi-App geschickt. Im Silicon Valley gibt es Ideen und Geld und die müssen zusammengebracht werden. Christoph Käse schreibt darüber, wie er sich darüber gewundert hat, aber wie streng dieses Prinzip ist. Der Investor und der von ihm finanzierte Gründer sind maximal eine Fahrrad-Tour voneinander entfernt. Man muss mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren können, nur dann ist die Nähe da, aus der dann was erwächst. Was bedeutet, wenn man sich in Deutschland politisch engagieren möchte, dann bitte dort, wo man mit dem Fahrrad hinfahren kann. Nicht auf Twitter irgendwas über Berlin schreiben. Das ist kein politisches Arker Sprache, sondern im sozialen Nahbereich. Man könnte gucken, ob in der eigenen Nachbarschaft was ist. Wenn man zu langweilig lebt, ist da nichts, aber so mit dem Fahrrad sollte man es schon erreichen können. Und dort engagiert man sich dann. Und zwar nicht, indem man eine Rede ankündigt.
Oder einen Appell.
Einen Appell, sondern im Alltag teilnimmt. Und jetzt gibt es ja einen Verein, der macht das ja stellvertretend für uns, wenn wir sagen, nee, ich hab nur viel Geld, aber nicht viel Zeit. Dann kann man sozusagen, man kann sich das erkaufen. Und zwar bei Helena Steinhaus, Sanktionsfrei-Verein, den sie damit einigen macht. Wir haben also Helena Steinhaus gebeten, bei uns ihren Verein vorzustellen. Wir haben es also hier nicht mit klassischer Werbung zu tun, für die wir bezahlt werden, sondern umgedreht. Ich habe 1000 Euro an Sanktionsfrei geschickt, um Helena zu motivieren, bei uns doch einen Werbeclip zu spielen.
Sehr gut.
So, also hören wir jetzt Helenas Werbung. Das können dann alle für euch ja, also 2026, ich habe nur zwei Möglichkeiten. Entweder ihr fahrt mit dem Fahrrad irgendwo hin, einmal die Woche, wo ihr eine Stunde seid, und dann engagiert ihr euch. Oder ihr überweist pro Monat hunderte oder pro Jahr tausende Euro an Sanktionsfrei, die das dann für...
Es gibt vielleicht noch Leute, die nicht diese enormen Summen mobilisieren können.
Ja, dann müsst ihr euren Onkel überreden, 10.000 Euro zu schicken.
Der Onkel, der Onkel muss es richten.
Der Onkel darf gerne alles sagen, solange er zahlt.
Ja.
Unterm Strich zählt's, ja. Also hier Hellenars Grußwort.
Ich bin Helena Steinhaus, Gründerin des Vereins Sanktionsfrei. Wir setzen uns für eine menschenwürdige und sanktionsfreie Grundsicherung ein. Und das tun wir auf verschiedenen Ebenen. Einerseits indem wir juristisch und finanziell unterstützen, wenn Menschen Probleme mit dem Jobcenter haben.
So juristisch und finanziell, das sind die beiden Sachen, um die es geht. Helena hat nicht gerade angekündigt, dass wir das Geld nehmen und dann eine Rede halten.
Aber auch indem wir ganz viel Öffentlichkeitsarbeit zum Thema Erwerbslosigkeit und Armut und dem ganzen Stigma drumherum machen.
Das ist für euren Onkel?
Die neue Grundsicherung soll das Bürgergeld ersetzen. Und damit einher werden sehr drastische Verschärfungen gehen, bis hin zu totalen Kürzungen des Regelsatzes, wenn man nur eine einzige Arbeit einmal ablehnt. Auch die Miete soll komplett entzogen werden können. Das heißt, auf unsere Arbeit wird einiges zukommen. Wir haben jetzt schon extrem viele Anfragen in unserem Support. Aber die verschärften Sanktionen werden die Situation noch mal verschärfen. Und alle, die mitmachen wollen, die unseren Solidartopf füllen wollen, damit wir Menschen im Bürgergeld unterstützen können, in existenziellen Notlagen, die sind herzlich dazu eingeladen, Heartbreaker zu werden. So nennen wir unsere DauerspenderInnen, dank denen wir unsere Arbeit machen können. Ihr findet alle Infos auf sanktionsfrei.de/supportoderauch in den sozialen Medien könnt ihr uns folgen unter at sanktionsfrei oder at steinhaushelena.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Ja, so ist es.
Wir weisen an dieser Stelle mal auf den Salon hin. Es gibt ja viel zu hören, jetzt gerade noch den Live-Salon vom Dezember. Da haben wir ja auch über Alex Kaab und die emotionalen Faktoren gesprochen. Wie kann der Mensch Energie für die Maschinen liefern? Haben uns ja hinein in die Laber-Podcasts begeben, die von Funk finanziert werden und haben aber auch über Kommunalpolitik gesprochen, wie da mit neuen Herausforderungen zu kämpfen ist. Wir werden im nächsten Salon ein Buch besprechen, auf das wir aufmerksam geworden sind durch unsere Pranko Milanovic Lektüre. Das war ja auch der Salon, der uns doch sehr lange beschäftigt hat. Ich glaube, einer der längsten Salons. Wir haben zumindest sehr lange über Pranko Milanovic gesprochen, weil es so ein herausragendes Buch ist.
Er einfach Politik in Geld übersetzt. Und da kann man halt um die Argumente nicht drum rum. Anders als Herr Lindemann. Das ist aber stressig, jetzt ihn zuzuhören.
The Great Global Transformation, darüber haben wir gesprochen. Und in diesem Buch erwähnte er eine neue Klasse, die entsteht. Nämlich Homo Plutia nennt er die. Das sind Menschen, die haben Vermögen. Meistens haben sie es geerbt. Aber die arbeiten trotzdem. Sie sind nicht einfach eine Rentierklasse wie im 19. Jahrhundert. Das heißt, Homo Plutia, sie sind reich an Vermögen und reich an Arbeits Einkommen. Und da entsteht eine neue Klasse, die sich auch sehr gut imprägnieren kann. Deshalb, weil sie sagt, na ja, ich bin doch fleißig, ich leiste doch was, ich habe hier eine 80-Stunden-Woche. Da ist also dieser meritokratische Gedanke, plötzlich dazu da, um sich abzudichten gegen jede Umverteilungsidee. Franco Milanovic verwies da auf das Buch The Meritocracy Trap von Daniel Markowitz. Und dann sagte ich, das wäre doch eine Idee, das mal zu lesen. Und gleich als ich es dann bestellte, sah ich ein Quot von Michael Sandel, über den wir ja auch schon gesprochen haben. Dieses wunderbare Buch Ende des Gemeinwohls, haben wir lange im Salon diskutiert, der gleich hier zitiert wird mit A Bold Brave Kritik. Das heißt, wir werden uns also mit der Frage der Leistungsgesellschaft und ihrer Ideologie beschäftigen, werden das aus einer anderen Komponente jetzt einmal tun. Wir haben also jetzt auch einen juristischen Blick darauf und werden uns fragen, ob wir uns wirklich von dieser Idee der Leistungsgesellschaft immer mehr verabschieden sollten und was da eigentlich für ideologische Implikationen drin liegen. Das alles kann man hören, wenn man den Salon abonniert. Und das ist möglich über Patreon, Apple und was wir besonders empfehlen Steady. Man kann auch für ein Jahr Steady verschenken. Wer das machen möchte, also ist nicht nur zu Weihnachtszeit möglich, sondern für ein Jahr kann man Steady verschenken. Und am besten geht man da, um das alles zu finden, auf die neu designte Homepage.
Ja, auf die neue Zwanziger-Seite, in der man nächstes Jahr ein bisschen viel noch Neues findet. Jetzt schon hat man das ganze Salonarchiv. Also man kann vorher noch mal jeden einzelnen Text, jede Kapitelmark ist aufgeführt mit einem Link zu dem Originaltext. Und dann kann man unsere Besprechung dazu hören, wenn man Salonmitglied ist. Also man folgt dem goldenen Button, meldet sich bei Steady an. Und ich will es jetzt ausdrücklich sagen. Wenn ihr euch bei Steady ein Abonnement holt, könnt ihr das in jedem Podcast-Player eurer Wahl hören, auch bei Apple Podcasts. Das ändert aber nichts daran, dass bei Apple Podcasts euch der Salon, wenn wir ihn bei Apple vertreiben, trotzdem als, das ist eine, aber ihr habt ja schon bezahlt bei Steady und es taucht auch schon in eurem Podcast-Player auf. Also das Steady-Abo erlöst euch nicht davon zu sehen, dass wir den auch bei Apple anbieten. Aber ihr könnt es trotzdem bei Apple einfach hören. Ihr müsst ihn halt nur manuell hinzufügen.
Ihr müsst ihn nicht doppelt dann buchen.
Genau, nicht doppelt buchen, sondern ihr geht einfach in der Apple Podcast-App oben auf das kleine Plus, wo man per URL ein Feed hinzufügt, und dann nehmt ihr einfach den Steady Feed, tragt den da ein und ab dann kriegt ihr den Podcast, sobald der veröffentlicht ist, kriegt ihr einen Hinweis, ihr neuer Podcast, ihr kriegt die Kapitelmarken, ihr kriegt die Links, ihr kriegt die Covers, ihr kriegt alles, das ganze Archiv.
Und wir bedanken uns bei all denen, die das tun und freuen uns, wenn viele weitere dazu kommen.
So ist es. Wolfgang hat nun heute schon alle seine Clips gespielt.
Nein, nein.
Und zwei sind noch offen.
Nein.
Sind noch mehr offen?
Ja.
Aber ich will nur sagen, wir haben jetzt erst Halbzeit. Und ich glaube, also zumindest von meiner Seite nur noch Amüsantes.
Okay. Ja, ich hab nicht nur Amüsantes. Ich hab noch was Ernstes. Wir können das auch gleich spielen, wenn du erst danach dann nur noch Amüsantes.
Es begeben sich neue Sachen im Podcastland, die hoch interessant sind. Robin Alexander ist jetzt unabhängig.
Ja.
Ich reklamiere das ein bisschen auch auf meine, wie soll ich sagen, Propaganda, die ich gemacht habe. Ich war ja mit ihm bei Hard Aber Fair vor einer Weile schon und da gibt es ja ein Nachgespräch, das ist schon immer so rum und so. Und da habe ich ihn gefragt, Alexander, Ihr Podcast läuft ja richtig gut. Und er so, ja und irgendwie. Und ich bin jetzt nicht indiskret. Und ich habe dann so gesagt, wieso machen sie nicht mehr? Wieso machen sie? Also er so, ja, wir haben ja immer wenig Zeit. Dagmar und ich haben ja noch vieles anderes zu tun. Und da habe ich ihm gesagt, also ich habe noch nie ein Text von ihm gelesen. Ich kenne sie nur aus ihrem Podcast. Und ich kenne auch nur Leute, die nur ihren Podcast hören, aber die nie was lesen. Und ich glaube, das hat gefruchtet bei ihm. Denn diese Ausrede, ich habe ja so viel zu tun, ich muss ja noch eine Glosse schreiben, noch einen Aufmachen, noch irgendwas und so in der Welt. Nee, setz dich hin, bereite deinen Podcast vor, mach einen Podcast. Und jetzt ist es tatsächlich dazu gekommen.
Ja, wir müssen das ein bisschen erklären, was jetzt da passiert ist. Also die beiden, Dagmar Rosenfeld und Robin Alexander, die diesen Machtwechsel-Podcast, heißt er, schon seit Langem erfolgreich gestalten, die haben sich jetzt losgemacht. Das heißt, dieser Podcast ist jetzt unabhängig vom Springer Imperium. Aber sie bleiben beide als Hausautoren oder auch Gäste in diesen Sendungen zu bleiben. Sie erhalten, das heißt, sie sind weiterhin auch mit Springer verbunden. Das wird sicherlich ein großer Deal sein. Man hätte gerne mal die Interna, denn das wird nicht billig sein, sich da rauszukaufen, das mitzunehmen, unzugleich noch so freundschaftlich verbandet zu sein, dass man also jetzt weitermacht wirklich eine Meisterleistung der Anwälte vermutlich, dass das alles so hingekommen ist. Also ich stelle es mir nicht leicht vor, da ja Springer erstmal das größte Interesse wohl daran hätte, dass man einen solchen Podcast behält und dass man die nicht einfach losmacht, dass man aber dann vielleicht noch ein Deal füllen, dass man sagt, ihr seid mit dem Haus weiterhin auch verbunden, aber ihr könnt auch da nochmal ein eigenes Business machen, denn die Sache ist ja die und das ist ja ein Problem, dass im Prinzip alle Medienhäuser haben, das ist ja jetzt nicht ein Springerproblem, sondern das gilt ja auch für kleinere Medienhäuser, auch für die, die eher so als unabhängig aufgetreten sind. Man hat also Protagonisten, die dann aufgrund ihrer Auftritte, ihrer Inhalte, aber auch ihrer Social-Media-Präsenz eine solche Relevanz bekommen, dass man eigentlich sagt, warum macht ihr das dann nicht selbstständig und wie schafft man es eigentlich noch, diese Leute dann bei sich zu behalten, wenn es für die sicherlich lukrativer wäre, den Podcast alleine zu machen und dann mit entsprechenden Werbeeinnahmen und so mehr zu verdienen, als der beste Redakteur im Springer-Kosmos verdienen kann. Und da gibt es, glaube ich, jetzt immer mehr, das beobachten wir jetzt ja auch in den USA, wird es immer mehr solche Deals geben. Also entweder gehen Leute ganz raus und machen so wie zum Beispiel Taylor Lawrence und sagen, ich bin versierte Tech-Journalistin, aber ich habe keine Lust mehr, mich an die Washington Post oder so zu binden. Ich bin jetzt da ganz frei und mache da mein eigenes Geschäft raus. Oder es wird dann Leute geben, die ein bisschen in die Unabhängigkeit zum Teil hineingehen. Also Paul Ronsheim hat ja auch Management, hat auch jetzt seinen YouTube-Kanal, der ist noch mit der Bild-Zeitung verbunden. Aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es jetzt häufiger zu solchen Konstellationen kommt, dass man nicht also ganz rausgeht, dass man sich da auch nicht verkracht unbedingt, aber dass man sieht, ich kann ja so nochmal angenehmer Geld verdienen. Im Prinzip kann man sagen, ist das dann so ein bisschen, wie wir das beim Fernsehen ja auch schon haben, wo sehr viele externe Produktionsfirmen dann aber dauerhaft mit RTL zusammenarbeiten. Und dann ist der Moderator auch nochmal mit einem Exklusivvertrag da drin, zum Beispiel wie bei Werder Millionär. Das heißt, das ist etwas, was glaube ich jetzt einfach so eine, ja, Transformation der Medienlandschaft ist, die wir da nochmal besonders für die Podcastlandschaft beobachten können.
Also ich spekuliere jetzt nur, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich würde sagen, hier waren gar keine Anwälte mit befasst. Und das, was wir jetzt hören mit, ja, er bleibt noch als Chrononist verbunden und so, das sind halt so, das sagt man halt so.
Nee, ich glaube schon, dass es Regeln geben muss. Also ich glaube schon, dass...
Welche Regeln denn?
Na ja, Springer hat ja ein großes Interesse daran, dass jemand wie Robin Alexander mit der Zeitung verbunden ist.
Genau.
Und er wird ja nicht, und Springer wird ja nicht sagen, ach so, du willst jetzt selbst den Podcast weitermachen, wir schenken dir den RSS-Feed, mach das. Also ich kann nicht darüber sprechen, wer das ist, aber ich kenne aus einem Bereich jemanden, der einen Podcast betrieben hat und der war nicht unerfolgreich, aber der war viel, viel kleiner als all das, über das wir jetzt gerade reden, ja.
Und dieser Mensch wollte den auch lösen aus diesem Medienhaus heraus und sollte eine Unsumme dafür zahlen, so dass er sich sagte, das kann er schon nicht machen.
Ja, und jetzt hast du mir schon gesagt, der war ja viel, viel kleiner. Jetzt sage ich Folgendes, Robin Alexander ist ja nicht klein, klein, klein. Der ist ja groß, groß, groß. Also das ist wahrscheinlich der wichtigste Politikpodcast, was die Reichweite angeht, auf den auch alle warten.
Ja.
Und was zu folgendem Szenario führt, hätte Robin Alexander gesagt, ich trenne mich von Springer im Streit und Die Neue UL, das Podcast lauderteilt Machtwechsel 2.de, Sendung 1 hätte sofort alle Hörer. Also diese Nachrichtenwelle, die durch Deutschland gegangen wäre, die hätte sofort dazu geführt, dass wir diesen alle jetzt schon abonnieren, obwohl es noch bis Januar dauert und die erste Folge kommt. Robin Alexander ist in dieses Büro gegangen, deswegen die hauseigene Springer-Kommunikation ist, wie du es jetzt beschrieben hast. Die Süddeutsche schreibt es wie folgt, am Mittwoch meldet die Welt noch stolz das Ergebnis einer Branchenumfrage, Zitat Robin Alexander ist der einflussreichste politische Journalist Deutschlands. Zitat Ende. Nur einen Tag später muss der Axel-Springer-Verlag einräumen, dass ausgerechnet dieser Robin Alexander, stellvertretender Chefredakteur der Welt, die Zeitung zum Jahresende verlässt. Also Robin Alexander muss hier auf gar nichts Rücksicht nehmen und das ist ja das Tolle. Er kann einfach sagen, ich verlasse die Welt. Das alleine hätte schon ein Beben in der deutschen Politiklandschaft verursacht. Und dann noch zu sagen, mein Podcast geht weiter, hätte er gesagt, der Podcast hat eine neue URL.
Ja, also diese Infrastruktur, die man da hat, die zu nutzen, das ist schon sehr teuer.
Das ist doch neue Infrastruktur.
Naja, es ist ein RSS-Vide.
Ja.
Aber der ist schon relevant für die Leute. Also es sind ja nicht alle, so wie du, Medien interessiert und sagen sofort, okay, in euer Podcast abonnier ich. Das heißt, das ist eine sehr zähe Angelegenheit.
Nee, in dem Falle keine zähe Angelegenheit.
Und es ist auch für, also wir sind jetzt keine Fans des Springerhauses, aber ich glaube für die Reputation und auch was dann so medial, also man ist in die Talkshows auch eingeladen als Robin Alexander, weil man zu Springer gehört. Also ich glaube, man darf das jetzt nicht völlig ausschließen, dass das auch eine Rolle spielt für Robin Alexander, was man aber sagen kann. Und ich glaube auch, dass es inhaltliche Gründe hat. Ich meine, dass Robin Alexander und Ulf Poschert wahrscheinlich nicht allzu viele Gemeinsamkeiten haben, das dürfte uns klar sein. Ja, also Robin Alexander ist zwar ein konservativer Autor, aber der hat ja mit einem Ulf Poschert doch wenig gemein. Und es gibt ja wohl auch damals, als dann Döpfner und andere wohl darauf gedrängt haben, dass Elon Musk da seinen obskuren Gastbeitrag veröffentlicht kann, indem er sagt, nur noch die AfD kann Deutschland retten. Dass da wohl aus dem Robin Alexander Lager, so hört man zumindest, Widerstand kam, beziehungsweise gab es da sehr großen Unmut. Und das kann natürlich sein, darüber kann man nur spekulieren, dass das dafür gesorgt hat. Was ich aber glaube, ist, dass diese großen Medienhäuser noch mal in einer ganz anderen Dominanz natürlich eine Präsenz verschaffen können für diese Podcasts. Denn ja, natürlich haben diese so prominenten Gesichter die Möglichkeit, sich auch unabhängig zu machen. Und ja, der würde jetzt nicht ein Sozialfall werden. Das glaube ich jetzt sicherlich auch. Aber man darf, glaube ich, nicht unterschätzen, wenn er einfach in der Bildzeitung noch mal eine große Anzeige für den Ron Simon oder Robin Alexander Podcast ist. Wenn man diese Infrastruktur hat, einfach um das Publikum, wie man in Marketing sagt, zu penetrieren, dann ist das noch mal eine andere Möglichkeit für die Reichweite. Also wenn unser Podcast Neue Zwanziger jetzt ein Monat von Springer hofiert würde und überall abgedruckt und beworben wäre, dann würde das hier auch explodieren. Da müssten wir nichts am Inhalt ändern. Das würde einfach bei Marketing gehen. Ich glaube, deshalb spielt es auch eine Rolle.
Okay, habe ich gut verstanden. Ich sage jetzt trotzdem noch mal den Gegenentwurf, um dann überzuleiten auf die nächsten Clips. Denn ich glaube, und ich sage auch so, ich weiß es ja nicht, ich vermute nur. Ich, also was ich aus diesem süddeutschen Ding, dass er einen Tag nachdem noch die große Feierstunde bei Springer stattfindet, geht, bedeutet für mich, die haben sich im Streit getrennt. Und als es in der Vorstandsetage hieß bei Poschardt, der Robin Alexander hätte gerne einen Termin mit dir, waren auch allen klar, was als nächstes kommt, nämlich, dass er jetzt wirklich geht. Weil typischerweise man das in diesen Häusern immer so unter der Hand und hier nochmal und dann ach komm, zum Glück haben wir es diesen Text verhindert, das geht ja alles gar nicht. Robin Alexander ist ja dann am Ende doch noch ein Typ von so ein bisschen Anstand und Integrität.
Ja, ja.
Er passt eigentlich nicht zu Springer.
Genau.
Und ich glaube, er wollte im großen Streit gehen und dann hat Springer von sich aus gesagt, wir spielen den Ball mal flach. Also behalte einfach den Machtwechsel-Podcast. Also den RSS-Feed, wie du jetzt sagst, der ist so wichtig. Ich glaube, das ist da nicht so wichtig. Das ist in dem Falle wirklich so krass Personal Branding. Also es ist ja nicht der Machtwechsel-Podcast, sondern Robin Alexander hat einen Podcast. So. Und wenn da eine Transition stattfindet, dann findet die einfach statt. Also das ist dann schon auf Niveau. Wir sind ja nicht in der Kommunalpolitik, sag ich mal, wo man immerhin dringend auch gibt es noch eine Lokalzeit, wo man eine Anzeige machen könnte.
Also was wir ja beobachten können, ist, dass bei Springer jetzt gerade medial sehr vorbereitet wird, dass es eine Koalition geben kann, die schwarz-blau ist.
Da kommen wir gleich drauf.
Da können wir nachher noch ansprechen.
Lass uns das mal entserren. Also wir sind jetzt bei meiner Hinleitung zu machen.
Ich will nur sagen, zu diesem Lager gehört Robin Alexander definitiv nicht.
Nee, genau nicht. Deswegen hat er jetzt wirklich gesagt, sorry, aber das ist jetzt zu viel. Ich habe jetzt Bilanz gezogen, der Tropfen und so weiter. In meiner Vorstellung, und ich sage, das ist meine Vorstellung, ich weiß es ja nicht, ist Robin Alexander auch in das Gespräch gegangen und hat gesagt, Leute, ich mache den Machtwechsel-Podcast selber, egal wie ihr das organisiert. Ich gebe mich geschlagen, je nachdem, wenn ihr sagt, nee, wir besetzen den Machtwechsel-Podcast jetzt neu. Und da ist ja die Frage, mit wem eigentlich? Und dann wäre im Haus die Idee gekommen, ja, der Gordon Rapinski, der gibt sich doch auch immer ganz viel Mühe, Politik-Podcasts zu machen. Wir nehmen den einfach. Und dann hat Robin Alexander so gesagt, ja, viel Spaß. Das ist ja ein sehr guter Podcast. So, und wir machen das jetzt mal. Wir gehen das Szenario mal durch. Was hätte denn Springe noch hinterher, um den Machtwechsel-Podcast zu bespielen, wenn man sich wirklich im Streit getrennt hätte und gesagt hätte, ja, der Machtwechsel-Podcast hat jetzt einen neuen Host, Gordon Rypinski. Gordon Rypinskis Beiträge in der politischen Landschaft sind so schlecht, wir müssen uns darüber lustig machen. Er hat jetzt zum Jahresabschluss am 1.12. ein Podcast über die SPD gemacht. Und ich will das kurz einrahmen. Ronsheimer ist ein Podcast, der sich dadurch auszeichnet, dass er immer so Fragen stellt. Ja, da will ich jetzt mal richtig reingehen. Das interessiert mich jetzt sehr. Lieber Gesprächspartner, jetzt liefer mal. So, damit kommt man nicht sehr weit, weil das immer so dieses, ja, Ronsheimer höre ich nur, wenn der Gast gut ist. Ja, so in die Richtung geht das dann. Das ist ja bei Robin Alexander ganz anders. Man will ja hören, was Robin Alexander denkt. Jaja. So, das heißt, Ronsheimer könnte diesen Podcast auf gar keinen Fall machen, weil Ronsheimer keine Analyse kennt. Das kennen wir ganz viel in Deutschland, dass Leute zwar unendlich viele Gesprächspodcasts haben, aber eigentlich nicht richtig ein eigenes Thema, nie für einen Vortrag gebucht. Es hängt halt so in der Luft. Man ist dann so als Moderation gebucht und dann ist halt irgendwann die Zeit vorbei und dann kommt die nächste Generation und dann ist man so aussortiert. So, Gordon Rapinski ist irgendwo dazwischen. Er versucht den inhaltlichen Ich-bin-s. Ich habe eine Meinung da draußen, das beschäftigt euch doch auch, die SPD und so. Wir hören mal diesen Ton in Gordon Rapinski einfach denkt, dass Deutschland jetzt politisch bespielt werden muss.
Ein bisschen Rockstar sein. Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht nur etwas, was sich Klingball manchmal vorstellt, wenn er in der Dienstlimousine nach 16 Std. Tagen nach Hause fährt, sondern es ist irgendwie auch noch das, was er in seinem Image jetzt gerade bräuchte, jetzt wo er sich so sucht. Die Tragik des Duos ist auch ein Symptom der Zeit, in der es in der Politik natürlich schwer ist. Es braucht Begeisterung, dafür braucht es Vision, es braucht Feuer, es braucht Führung, aber auch eine klare Idee. Und die sieht man bei Bas und bei Klingball im Moment nicht. Und so ist die Frage, wer von beiden jetzt der Spitzenkandidat, der Kanzlerkandidat für 2029 werden sollte, die ist so wahnsinnig weit weg. Weil keiner von beiden sich wirklich aufdrängt im Moment. Beide versuchen irgendwie klarzukommen in dem, was sie tun und verwalten damit irgendwie auch das Erbe ihrer Partei. Vielleicht ist in der Koalition mit der Union für die SPD-Moment nicht mehr drin. Aber Bas und oder Klingball müssen den Hebel irgendwann umlegen.
Sonst redet über sie.
Weißt du, was er da macht? Weißt du, was er versucht, zu kopieren? Esra Klein. Esra Klein hat doch manchmal diese Monologe, wenn er dann beispielsweise Kamala Harris krönt oder sagt, Trump ist so merkwürdig geworden. Und dann hat er immer genau diesen Ton. Look, but something is different. Und dann redet er so, sich da so rein. Dann wiederholt er das wieder. Und es ist wirklich dieser Versuch, ja, aber irgendwas ist mit der SPD noch nicht. Noch nicht so, wie es eigentlich sein sollte. Da muss, glaube ich, noch ein Hebel umgelegt werden. Aber es ist dann doch bei Esra Klein, bei aller Kritik, die ich immer an ihm habe, ein bisschen interessanter.
Was heißt das eigentlich, dass ich das nicht erkannt habe, aber es mir jetzt wie Schucken von den Ohren fällt, dass das natürlich die Esra Klein-Modus sein soll. Also wirklich, es ist so grandios schlecht. Esra Klein hat ja einen Gesprächspartner, so auch hier Sebastian Roloff, also jemanden aus der SPD, Vize, Vorsitz, irgendeinen Ausschuss, ich weiß nicht genau, wo der herkommt. Und jetzt können wir natürlich alles mal weiter, und da ist das wie bei Esra Klein.
Frau Baas hat gesagt, nach dem Arbeitgebertag wusste sie, gegen wen man jetzt kämpft.
Da meinte sie aber mit Sicherheit nicht in den Arbeitgebertag. Ich kenne allerdings auch nur Ausschnitte der Rede von Frau Baas und nicht die ganze.
Das ist schon mal nicht so wie bei Esra Klein. Dass einfach keiner weiß, wovon hier was und überhaupt. Also das ist meine Partei, keine Ahnung.
Sie meint eben genau diese Kräfte, die die SPD verdrängen wollen, weil sie noch mehr Turbokapitalismus, noch weniger Beteiligung und noch weniger Sozialstaat wollen.
Also Herr Rohloff, da hat Frau Baas gesagt, sie hat in diese Reihen geguckt, hat diese Maßanzüge gesehen und diese Herren. Und deswegen wüsste man jetzt, gegen wen man kämpft. Ich meine, da ruft doch die Arbeitsministerin und Parteichefin in einer Koalition zum Klassenkampf auf. So kann das doch nichts werden, oder?
Ja, Springer, wir kennen das Anliegen, aber in der Form zündet es nicht. Und dann kommt wieder der nächste Appell.
Die Frage, die ich mir immer stelle bei der Betrachtung der SPD ist, bekommst du diese Partei mit dieser Geschichte dafür begeistert, nochmal dafür begeistert nach der Agenda 2010, solche Schritte zu tun, wo ja immerhin viele Jahre danach bis heute alle sagen, das waren die größten und schwerwiegendsten und erfolgreichsten Reformen, die dieses Land in diesem Jahrtausend gesehen hat. Und kriegst du die SPD nochmal zu diesem Punkt, dass nochmal machen zu müssen? Weil es ist an der Zeit. Ich meine, wir sind, manchmal frage ich mich auch jetzt an so einem Freitag, wir gucken alle da so auf diese Rentenabstimmung und so. Dieses Land hat so krasse Herausforderungen vor sich. Wir sind in einer solchen Wirtschaftskrise, auch Potenzialkrise. Wir sind in einer solchen geopolitischen Krise, die das dann alles nochmal verschärft.
Zum Glück hat er es verstanden. Also zum Glück hat er es auf der einen Seite.
Dass ich mich wirklich frage, ob es ein Realitätsbewusstsein außerhalb von der namentlichen Abstimmung, die da heute stattfindet, in der Regierung gibt. Und eben auch und besonders in der SPD.
Ja, das, was der da abliefert, kann wirklich jeder Onkel unterm Tannenbaum auch leisten.
Das ist definitiv so. Ich habe hier so einen Clip, da sehe ich gerade erst eine Minute 52, Repinski jetzt über die Jusos. Mal gucken, wie lange wir das durchhalten.
Wir sind jetzt schon bei ein Viertel des Haushalts.
Er hat dann Journalisten, Kolleginnen, mit denen er nochmal das kluge Tischgespräch führt oder was auch immer....
investieren nur in den Konsum oder auch mehr in Forschung, weil andere haben uns schon längst überholt, KI...
Auch in die Forschung, weil andere haben uns schon längst überholt, KI......Grüner Stahl und so weiter.
Du hast absolut recht und es ist im Grunde genommen super schön ausgeführt, was ich damit meine mit die Begeisterung der Sozialdemokratie dafür wecken, was eigentlich jetzt ansteht und das, was ansteht an Aufgaben zu sozialdemokratischen Themen zu machen. Nur das Problem ist, aus meiner Sicht, dass die Sozialdemokratie...
Jetzt kommt auf meine Analyse, was das Problem ist...
.einer demografischen Zange gefangen ist zwischen einer völlig verkopften, alten Ortsvereins Sozialdemokratie und einer genauso verkopften und noch tragischer verkopften Juso-Jungenorganisation, die einfach glaubt, das, was in den 70ern richtig war, das ist jetzt immer noch richtig.
Ja, was in den 70ern richtig war, ist heute noch richtig. Nämlich, dass man z.B. volkswirtschaftliches, produktives Vermögen in den Löhnen verrechnet, in dem Moment, wo es erwirtschaftet wird.
Und das finde ich ist eine solche intellektuelle Enttäuschung auch. Also ich finde, ich bin ja...
Eine intellektuelle Enttäuschung?
Dauerenttäuscht grundsätzlich von dem meisten, was Jugendorganisationen in den Parteien machen. Aber bei der SPD finde ich es wirklich besonders dramatisch, dass es einfach niemanden gibt bei den Jusos, der auf die Idee kommt, naja, es könnte ja vielleicht auch so sein, dass man länger arbeiten muss oder so etwas. Was natürlich daran liegt, dass du sofort in der Logik dieser jungen Partei oder Parteijugend abgestraft wirst. Und das finde ich ist einfach in der Politik insgesamt eine Enttäuschung. Also wenn du immer nur... Das ist übrigens in den Medien, sieht man das auch. Wenn du immer nur entlang deines Klischees Politik machst oder wenn du immer nur entlang des Klischees deines Mediums kommentierst oder wie gesagt bei den Jusos Politik machst, dann kann nicht etwas rauskommen, was intellektuell den Veränderungen der Zeit angemessen ist.
Lieber Gordon Rakinski, Sie argumentieren nur entlang des Klischees Ihres Mediums, nämlich dass man die Arbeitnehmer mehr gängeln muss, damit es den Arbeitgebern besser geht. Und ich sehe ja auch nie, dass andersrum diskutiert wird. Man könnte ja auch mal die Diskussion aufmachen, warum ist eigentlich die Union immer so arbeitgeberfreundlich? Kann die sich nicht davon mal lösen? Also man würde nie in so einem Podcast hören, dass man der CDU Sozialdemokratie empfiehlt. Aber der Sozialdemokratie empfiehlt man die ganze Zeit, dass sie doch bitte auf diese verzichten solle und lieber das Unionsprogramm eins zu eins umsetzt. Dass sie ja überhaupt noch Restbestände von Sozialdemokratie bei der aktuellen SPD findet, finde ich ja schon erstaunlich an sich. Aber dass er wirklich glaubt, dass das einfach das Rezept ist, würde die SPD loswerden, dann wäre alles super. Dann könnte man auch sagen, dann kann die SPD sich auch ganz eingemeinden in die CDU. Dann hat man eine einzige Partei noch.
Das ist ja im Grunde was sie sich wünschen im Systemstreit gegen China, dass alle so zusammenhalten wie die kommunistische Partei.
Ja.
Dass es nur noch Bindifferenzen gibt, die man dann mal so nebenbei klären. Gut, also dieser Jahresrückblick, den der Deutschlandfunk gemacht hat, zum zweiten Mal, denn es war offenbar ein Erfolgsrezept.
Wer war jetzt dabei bei dieser Ausgabe?
Genau, also die Runde wird ja immer so gestaltet jetzt, dass man so eine Art Roundtable, wie man sich es bei der Zeit abgeguckt hat, veranstaltet. Und dort, also Ulf Bohrmeier war glaube ich letztes Jahr schon dabei, Bettina Schmidt-Matern aus der Redaktion, Nadine Lindner, Katharina Hamburger glaube ich, vielleicht gleich Anne Will, Robin Alexander und Ulf Bohrmeier als Externe. Das klingt so nach einer tollen Runde. Genau, wir werden mal divers, wir holen mal noch andere Meinungen rein. Und es ist wirklich sehr amüsant geworden, muss ich sagen. Das ist schon der Beginn. Man überschlägt sich natürlich wie irre und verrückt. Wir versuchen jetzt diese Bilanz einfach nachzuvollziehen, denn vielleicht wird übertrieben. Ich habe den Verdacht, dass es vielleicht in Berlin doch eine andere Großwetterlage gibt, als bei mir zum Beispiel. Also Anne Will legt mal los.
Du hast den Titel ja schön gewählt, die bröckelnden Gewissheiten des Drittes.
Also die bröckelnden Gewissheiten, ja? Das ist der Titel dieses Deutschlandfunk Politik Podcasts.
Die bröckelnden Gewissheiten des zurückliegenden Jahres sind. Und ich würde es dann auf die Formel bringen, dass ich sage, dass wir in einem Epochenbruch leben.
Also bröckelnde Gewissheiten, sagt der Deutschlandfunk, ist das Thema. Jeder soll eine These mitbringen. Sie redet von diesen Gewissheiten, die jetzt der Epochenbruch und so.
Epochenbruch leben, dass wir wirklich eine grundstürzende...
Grundstürzend...
Veränderung unseres politischen Systems erleben. Das ist glaube ich in diesem Jahr durch eine Menge Ereignisse, die wir ja bestimmt noch anschauen werden, jedem und auch jeder Einzelnen wirklich überdeutlich klar geworden.
Ja, also soweit ich weiß, geht morgens die Sonne noch auf, abends unter. Keiner schießt auf der Straße rum. Die Leute fahren zum Tanken und es kommt tatsächlich Benzin raus und im Supermarkt gibt es auch immer noch Sachen, die sind nur wahnsinnig teuer. Ja. Wenn ich jetzt überlege, was hat mein Leben beeinflusst, also ich könnte Geschichten von KI erzählen, es ist ja wirklich sensationell mittlerweile, was man so tut. Ja, sowas wird ja einfach gar nicht besprochen, sondern man ist ja im Politikmodus, weißt du, man redet ja nur über die großen Themen, bei denen alle Leute zu doof sind, eine eigene Meinung zu haben. Also erzählt mir hier das große Märchen des subalativen, überdeutlichen Epochenbruchs, der nun wirklich jedem klar geworden ist. Dann fragt man sie so, kannst du sie jetzt mal runterbrechen?
Jetzt sind die Dinge einfach anders, als sie vorher waren. Es gab ja diesen Begriff der Zeitenwende, der ganz oft fiel, Epochenbruch ist meiner Ansicht nach jetzt der nächste größere Begriff, der kommt durch Friedrich Merz, auch in der Regierungserklärung jetzt in der letzten Parlamentswoche genannt.
Nehme an, das hat er von mir, der hatte diese These gelesen, weißt du, und dann hat er gesagt, ah klar, Epochenbruch, ja.
Aber wo würdest du den Finger draufhalten, wo du es richtig gemerkt hast, jetzt ist was anderes?
Finde ich gut, dass du es so fragst, weil ich wirklich dachte, ich habe es gefühlt, also nicht nur gelesen, wahrgenommen, sondern gefühlt am Abend des 28. Februars, ist das, glaube ich, als Volodymyr Zelensky im Oval Office ist und da in einer Weise gedemütigt wird, die ich schlimm fand.
Das war jetzt der Epochenbruch, oder was?
Das war der Epochenbruch, wo ich mir denke, naja.
Also dass Trump vor der Öffentlichkeit das gemacht hat, was amerikanische Präsidenten sonst auch immer mit den regierenden anderen Länder getan haben.
Oder es noch labelt mit Grey Television.
Ja.
Also das ist jetzt der große Epochenbruch.
Das ist die große Veränderung.
Danach hat sie gemerkt, ich kann jetzt meine Milch nicht mehr so kaufen wie bisher.
Was glaubt sie denn, wie Biden Zelensky klar gemacht hat, dass nicht die entsprechenden Waffen geliefert werden, die die Ukraine fordert? Sicherlich nicht in der Öffentlichkeit. Davon haben wir nichts gesehen.
Das war dann nicht Grey Television.
Intern können wir uns vorstellen, wird das nicht angenehm gewesen sein, mit beiden da zu sitzen. Vermutlich hat das Beide noch nicht mal selbst gesagt, sondern irgendein Berater neben ihm.
Genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen, weil so wie wir jetzt auch immer Trump und so.
Ja.
Nee, man wird zu Schnecke gemacht im Weißen Haus. Das ist typischerweise so.
Wenn man überhaupt einen Termin kriegt, das ist ja auch noch mal so eine Sache. Also in der Ansicht, okay, das ist natürlich, also dass Leute aus dem Fernsehen sagen, dass das, was sie im Fernsehen gesehen haben, sie jetzt wirklich beeindruckt, weil sie jetzt plötzlich anderes Fernsehen machen müssen, um den Leuten zu sagen, wie krass das jetzt alles ist. Also abgekoppelt, da geht es gar nicht, finde ich.
Also Epochenbruch meint einfach, Sehgewohnheiten sind andere Noten.
Genau, die Sehgewohnheiten sind jetzt ein bisschen gebrochen, aber gut. Robin Alexander, er hat hier mal eine These, der will, also ich werde hier gleich komplett widersprechen.
Selbst wenn es wieder einen demokratischen Präsidenten gibt in ein paar Jahren, bis die Leute in der Welt, in den Demokratien wieder glauben, dass die Amerikaner auf jeden Fall da sind, das wird mindestens eine Generation dauern. Also viel ist kaputt gegangen, das ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel, was nicht nächstes Jahr schnell heilen kann.
Also ein Gavin Newsom, der eine Europareise macht und eine Rede, egal in welchem Europäischen Parlament hält, hat das alles geheilt.
Ja klar. Das ist ja in gewisser Weise auch das tragische an der Sache, denn wir wissen ja noch ganz genau, Trump wird nicht wiedergewählt, Biden wird es und wir haben Macron, Scholz, von der Leyen, alle reden da und sagen America is back.
Dann werden wir wieder im Podcast sagen, also angenommen, es ist jetzt im Januar, in drei Jahren kommt ein neuer demokratischer Präsident, der hält dann im März in einem europäischen Parlament als Antrittsbesuch in Europa stellvertretend, für Europa, man erkennt Europa wieder an, in Antrittsräte. Dann haben wir das restliche Jahr, neun Monate Zeit, um zu sagen, sorry, ihr habt euch verarschen lassen, strukturell hat sich gar nichts verändert, das war nur eine Rede. Dann werden wir im Jahresrückblick des Deutschlandfunk hören, das war der Moment, als mir klar war, es ist alles wieder gut.
Die transatlantische Partnerschaft besteht.
Genau, da ist sie wieder. Wir haben zweimal Trump überstanden, wie gut kann das eigentlich sein, das ist ja wirklich erstaunlich und so. Und das finde ich wirklich sehr tragisch, dass wir das hier so serviert bekommen einfach. Aber gut, wir gehen Robin Alexander noch ein bisschen weiter nach. Er wurde natürlich auch entsprechend angeteasert.
Robin Alexander sitzt mir direkt gegenüber, Journalist bei der Welt seit 2019, dort stellvertretender Chefredakteur, Buchautor und Podcaster seit 2021, moderierte mit Dagmar Rosenfeld den Podcast Machtwechsel. Und Robin, bei dir werden sich Dinge durchaus verändern im neuen Jahr.
Ja, und das hat mit dem Podcast zu tun, weil Dagmar Rosenfeld und ich machen uns mit unserem Podcast Machtwechsel selbstständig. Wir werden das also zum Schwerpunkt unserer Arbeit machen.
Also mehr Machtwechsel, weniger Welt in Zukunft für dich.
Ja.
Ja, also da ist er ganz zurückhaltend. Jetzt denkt man, okay, Stefan hat gerade gesagt, das ist bedeutsam und mal gucken, wie die nächsten Podcasts zu sind. Also Pinsky können wir aussortieren. Aber es wird schon interessant, die ersten Machtwechsel zu hören, einfach um so Shifts in Tenor zu hören. Allerdings könnte es auch einfach weitergehen wie bisher. Denn Robin Alexander.
Also ich glaube, es gibt politisch keinen großen Richtungswechsel, sondern es ist nicht besonders amüsant mit Ulf Poschert und den seinen dort ständig unter einem Dach sitzen zu müssen. Wenn man sich die Auftritte von Poschert ansieht, dann hat man doch den Eindruck, das wird immer wirrer. Und dann meine ich jetzt gar nicht, dass ich die politische Position nicht heile, sondern es ist einfach unangenehm und wirr. Es ist nicht so, dass man sagt, na ja, aber da hat er noch einen Punkt und darüber könnte man mal sich austauschen mit ihm, sondern es ist nur wirr.
Genau.
Und deshalb kann ich sehr gut verstehen, dass man da nicht arbeiten will. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass jetzt Robin Alexander eigentlich sozialdemokrat ist oder so.
Und das wird hier auch deutlich, denn Robin Alexander schaut auf das Jahr zurück und zieht dann so Konsequenzen im Denken.
Und beim Bürgergeld, es hilft doch nichts. Das Wahlergebnis, wenn man guckt, was war das Wahlergebnis, die Leute wollten das mit dem Bürgergeld nicht mehr haben. Jetzt kann man sagen, die Leute sind doof oder böse oder kaltherzig.
Ja, also es widerspricht genau unsere Analyse. Während wir sagen, ne bitte greift zu eurem Handy und fragt einfach irgendeine KI-Kotz, wie das mit der politischen Bilanzierung, wenn ich habe im Radio gehört, 0 Euro ersparen ist. Was bedeutet das? Er so, ne es geht ja gar nicht ums Geld in der Politik. Es geht um das Gefühl. Der Lindemann hat da schon recht und die Wähler haben halt gesagt, ihm ist das wichtig und so. Also wenn das der Thema von Machtwechsel ist, dann gut.
Aber das hat gegen das Gerechtigkeitsempfinden der Leute verstoßen. Das sagt die Union offen und die SPD sagt das, wenn es nicht gerade der eigene Partei da ist, auch. Und jetzt versuchen die, das zu operieren und das gleiche an den offenen Grenzen. Also ich meine, warum hat denn Joe Biden verloren?
Dieses Gefühl, das Gerechtigkeitsgefühl bei den Grenzen wie beim Bürgergeld, das ist auch einfach so da. Das ist unveränderbar.
Unveränderbar.
Komischerweise ja nicht, weil 2015 haben sich ja Leute zu Willkommensgrüßen hinreißen lassen, wo man überrascht war beispielsweise, dass die so sehr sich freuen, dass Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland kommen. Und dann ist das irgendwann wieder weg, weil sich dann die Großwetterlage ändert medial. Das heißt, das ist ja ein Thema, bei dem man ja nochmal ganz klar sagen kann, gerade beim Bürgergeld, die Menschen haben ja überhaupt gar keine Ahnung von irgendwelchen Bezügen, die Bürgergeldempfänger bekommen. Wenn Linneman denen sagt, wir werden viele Milliarden sparen, dann hören die Milliarden denken, naja, gut, sparen. Das jetzt am Ende ist nur 86 Millionen und auch nur im ersten Jahr sind. Das weiß schon fast keiner mehr. Das heißt, das Gerechtigkeitsempfinden könnte man ja nur auf eine rationale Grundlage stellen, wenn diese Leute, die dieses Empfinden haben, wüssten, über was sie da reden, dass sie sagen, ja, wenn wir den Bürgergeldempfänger 30 Euro wegnehmen, dann ist mein Gerechtigkeitsempfinden wiederhergestellt. Es ist aber nicht. Es ist eine reine Simulation, wie wir ja auch gesagt haben. Eine gefühlsvolle Politik, wie Lindemann es auch selbst sagt. Deswegen ist das hier wirklich ein Offenbarungseid, dass die, die medial die ganze Zeit diese Empfindungen schaffen, jetzt sagen, naja, das waren die Empfindungen. Und darauf hätte die SPD aber auch mal steunigst reagieren müssen.
Da beißt sich die Empfindungskatze in den Schwanz. Man weiß nicht genau, was war zuerst da, die Empfindungen oder die Politik. Aber es ist halt wie es ist. Und so eben auch bei diesen offenen Grenzen. Du hast ja diesen Clip gespielt. Deutschland 100 irgendwas, ARD. Flüchtlinge sind ja einfach nur Betten, die in der Thronhalle stehen. Was bedeutet? Eine gute Flüchtlingspolitik bedeutet niedrige Flüchtlingszahlen. Und wenn die Deutschen sagen, sie sind unzufrieden mit der Migrationspolitik, dann denken die bei der ARD gar nicht lange darüber nach. Dann heißt es einfach, ah ja, weil die Zahlen so hoch sind.
Klar. Ja. So, Punkt.
Sonst ist es kein Gestaltungsspielraum.
Die Zahlen sind so hoch, deswegen sind die Leute unzufrieden. Wenn die Zahlen niedrig sind, sind die Leute wieder zufrieden mit der Migrationspolitik. Und so denkt auch, also das ist, Es gibt immer nur so einen Hebel, den man nach da oder dort ziehen kann. Hahn auf, Hahn zu.
Ja, wir kennen das, wir haben das ja heute schon mal als Beispiel genannt. Wir kennen das ja noch genauso aus der Corona-Politik. Wir gucken, wie viele Fälle. Okay, alle wieder Maske an, drin bleiben. Jetzt wieder niedrig. Wunderbar, könnte wieder rausgehen.
Genau, man versucht so ein gutes Niveau zu halten, wo alle zufrieden sind. Und bei Corona waren wir alle super zufrieden. Also, Robin Alexander, das ist so seine Schöpfungshöhe, was diesen Gedanken angeht.
Auch. Und jetzt versuchen die, das zu operieren. Und das Gleiche an den offenen Grenzen. Also, ich meine, warum hat denn Joe Biden verloren gegen Donald Trump? Und warum ist der Brexit passiert? Offene Gesellschaften mit offenen Grenzen funktionieren nicht. Das hat sich herumgesprochen. Das hat sich herumgesprochen.
Ich bin mal sehr gespannt, wie wir Bilanz ziehen in zwei, drei Jahren, wie ZU-Grenzen und Amerika so funktionieren. Wenn wir schon die 10 Billionen vorgerechnet bekommen von der Zentralbank in Dallas und so. Mal sehen, wie die Bilanz da rauskommt.
Vor allem wird ja auch immer so getan, als sei offene Grenzen, also sei das wie der Binnenraum, dass jetzt einfach immer alle zu jeder Zeit kommen konnten und jetzt erst schließt man Grenzen. Nein, es gab ja schon einen Grenzregime. Europa war offen. Und man muss Asylanträge stellen und dergleichen.
Das hast du falsch gesehen. Europa war offen. Ja. Und Merkel hat auch die Grenze geöffnet. Also wir hören das hier mal weiter, das Argument, er entfaltet jetzt ganz klug.
Zwei Gruppen, die Rechten sagen, die offene Gesellschaft kann das Problem nicht lösen. Und die Leute ganz links sagen, sie darf es nicht lösen. Und die offenen Gesellschaften in der Mitte versuchen es zu lösen im Rahmen ihres Rechtsstaats. Und da ist etwas, finde ich auch, wo man sagen muss, weil wir so darüber hinweggegangen sind, die Zahlen in den Erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen sind 50 Prozent runter. 50 Prozent.
Das ist doch nichts mit Nationalmaßnahmen zu tun hat.
Und wofür? Aber was war ein Theater für die Zurückweisung an der Grenze? Unter anderem vor allem ja bei uns im Podcast hier. Und jetzt sagt man, ist alles völlig egal. Man kann ja dagegen sein, ist ja okay. Aber zu sagen, es hat keinen Unterschied gemacht, ob Nancy Faeser oder Alexander Dobrindt regiert, das finde ich eine starke Baugt.
Na ja, es ist ja Nancy Faeser, Olaf Scholz, gemeinsame Asylpolitik, die die Zahlen runtergebracht hat. Wir können ja nicht sagen, Neemertz ist schon auf allen Ebenen gescheitert so bislang. Also alle sind total enttäuscht, nichts funktionieren. Außer die Migrationspolitik? Nee, da sind natürlich auch andere Sachen, die da funktionieren. Also, deren sich schon bescheuert. Und ich will es nur anmerken, wir haben jetzt kein großes Thema dazu, aber es ist schon erwähnenswert, dass wir also mit deutschem Siegel unterschriebene Aufnahmebefehle an die Verwaltung sozusagen, den Menschen ausgehandigt haben in Afghanistan, auf Rechtswegen eingeklagt, einfach per Federstrich sagen, ihr dürft jetzt doch nicht kommen. Wenn es stimmt, was Robin Alexander sagt, nämlich dass die Deutschen so Fernsehen schauen und da wird ein Gefühl erzeugt und das ist dann halt so. Wenn Leute Fernsehen schauen und sehen, dass Deutschland so mit seinen Leuten umgeht, die in Afghanistan geholfen haben und so weiter, das bedeutet ja dann offensichtlich auch irgendwas in der Welt. Und dann wieder in Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz zu machen, wo man so sieht, der globale Süden, da kommt schon gar nicht mehr. Da ist da wirklich eins plus eins im Zweiten.
Als wenn ich der globale Süden wäre, würde ich auch noch nicht nach München kommen.
Ja, vor allem, weil die Grenzen hier zu sind.
Also mit Häuskeln war das dann auch anders, aber jetzt ist da ja nur wirklich von den Leuten gar keiner mehr interessiert.
Jetzt bietet man nur noch eine Bühne für JD Vans. Was sagt der denn diesmal an sich?
Ich frage mich aber auch, wenn man das doch eh alles genau so sieht, dass das mit den Zurückweisungen jetzt toll ist und Dobrindt so toll ist und dass man sich auch gar nicht mehr darum schert, dass man selbst den Leuten aus Afghanistan, denen man zugesagt hat, dass sie kommen dürfen, plötzlich mitteilt, wir halten uns doch nicht daran, aber dann kann man doch auch gleich für die AfD plädieren. Also warum muss man dann immer noch sagen, ich will aber nicht AfD, nur weil jetzt...
Also wenn die AfD mit allem Recht hat, dann hat sie halt mit allem Recht. Und wenn man das vor allem im Radio auch so sagt die ganze Zeit.
Also dann weiß ich nicht mehr, wo ist deren Problem mit Alice Weidel. Also ich weiß dann nicht, wo der Unterschied ist, was würde denn Alice Weidel an der Situation verschlimmern? Beziehungsweise in ihren Sinne oder in Robin Aleksanders Sinne würde sie ja die Situation höchstens noch verbessern.
Noch allerdings regiert die CDU mit der SPD. Allerdings, die SPD hat eine hohe Lernkurve.
Es gibt bei der SPD doch eine hohe Lernkurve. Also das die SPD...
In welche Richtung führt diese Kurve?
Die SPD, die Migrationspolitik, über die wir schon gesprochen haben, miträcht. Also die SPD trächt jetzt die Migrationspolitik mit, die Angela Merkel aus Seehofer nie durchgehen ließ. Das ist eine hohe Lernkurve. Und dass Bärbel Bas das Bürgergeld abwickelt, ist auch eine hohe Lernkurve.
Mit Dagmar Schmitt auch noch, oder?
Mit Dagmar, ja.
Wer ist Dagmar Schmitt für alle, die jetzt nicht ganz tief drüben?
Die Sprecherin für Arbeit und Soziales in der SPD und kommt wirklich vom ganz linken Flügel und ist auch wirklich eine derjenigen, die einigt, dass damalige Bürgergeld...
Also dass das verstanden wurde, muss man ausdrücklich anerkennen.
Die haben sich jetzt einfach an die Herrschaftsinteressen angelehnt und werden nicht mehr in irgendeiner Weise gebraucht. Also die SPD hat sich gänzlich überflüssig gemacht. Punkt.
Vor allem, welches Bild haben die denn hier, dass man als Staatssekretär völlig frei seinem Gewissen verpflichtet, da irgendwelche Politik macht? Nein, man bleibt dort hängen, weil man seine Grundüberzeugung aussortiert hat. Ja. Nur deswegen, das ist der einzige Erfolgsmechanismus, um in Berlin Rolle zu spielen. Und jetzt kann man sich über zwei Sachen dann freuen. Also entweder, oh, jemand hat es bis zum Staatssekretär geschafft oder jemand ist sich treu geblieben. Aber das geht halt nicht überein. So. Und dass die sich dann immer wieder überrascht zeigen, dass sich jemand dann doch für die gewissen Annehmlichkeiten entscheidet, ist halt auch...
Ja, ja. Also das wird ja nie so beschrieben. Also eigentlich ist das ja nur die Frage, wollten sie ihren Job behalten? Ja oder nein? Ja, ich wollte den behalten und dann hätte ich ja was Richtiges machen müssen. Das wollte ich nicht, also bin ich hier geblieben.
Man sagt halt so in der CDU-Linken, SPD-Linken, ja wir hätten hier einen Posten für dich, aber du weißt ja, wir regieren hier mit der CDU und du bist auch nicht Minister, sondern halt ausführende Verwaltungsfrau.
Ja und wir werden jetzt hier alles, kurz und klein, schlank für was du stehst, machst du mit.
Genau.
Es gibt 10.000 Euro im Monat, überlegst dir.
Von daher, so, zum Ende dieser Sendung, wir kommen aber gleich ausführlich auf Ulf Burmeier zu sprechen, zum Ende dieser Sendung, ich will es nur jetzt schon mal spielen. Barbara Schmidt-Matern stellt so fest, es geht ja ganz turbulent im Fernsehen zu. Während ich so denke, ja, wir haben die ganze Zeit nur über Fernsehinhalte gesprochen. Anne Will hat mit ihrem Grundstürzen, denn sie hat was im Fernsehen gesehen. Robin Alexander so, die Wahrheit kommt im Fernsehen, die Gefühlszahlen, die Migrationszahlen, wie auch immer. Jetzt Barbara Schmidt-Matern.
Wo hat die eigentlich hier?
Wo sie hier ein bisschen gelacht werden, dass Robin Alexander ja keine Haare hat, in der er sich raufen kann.
Also du möchtest keine zahlen.
Ich bin nicht in der Position, über Haare öffentlich zu sein.
Nein, aber es ist gut, mit Friedrich Merz zu sagen, welche Frisur.
Können wir das Thema wechseln?
Tina, wie sieht es bei dir aus? Wie viele Momente hattest du, wo du zweifelst an dem, was du siehst?
Ja, also ich hab das gar nicht so oft mit dem Haare raufen, aber ich stelle mir oft die Frage, haben wir das eigentlich schon verstanden? Also wir müssen ja, das finde ich, wir erleben die Sachen ja auch, wir sind ja auch irgendwie, müssen sie gleichzeitig ja immer einordnen. Und das finde ich, ist wirklich eine Herausforderung gewesen in diesem Jahr, dass man sie quasi während die Dinge passieren, muss man sie auch schon verstanden haben und auch bewerten können. Und da habe ich in diesem Jahr oft gedacht, haben wir das eigentlich schon richtig verstanden?
Und das war früher anders oder was?
Na ja, das hat sie oft gedacht. Aber hat sie mal danach gehandelt, den Leuten zu sagen, guten Abend, ich bin Barbara Schmitt-Matern, ich mache heute die Deutschlandfunk-Tages-Sammfassung. Ich sage es ihnen jetzt nicht, aber ich tue mal so als ob. Ich erkläre ihnen jetzt Sachen. So und das ist dieses große Phänomen des Trump-Washings. Trump kommuniziert einfach öffentlich, er hält eine halbe Stunde eine Rede, ein Rumgewife, also dieses Abschweifen, hier nochmal ein Exkurs, da nochmal und so weiter und fort. So, dann setzen sich Journalisten hin und versuchen da im Schweise ihres Angesichts irgendeinen roten Faden reinzuweben und den verkaufen sie dann ihren Zuschauern, weil es wäre ja blöd, wenn die Zuschauer nicht verstehen, was Trump gesagt hat. Ja. Aber diese Frage, ja, hat Trump was gesagt, was es zu verstehen ist, kann man ja auch mal mit Nein beantworten.
Ich würde ja gerade sagen, ja, aufgrund dieser Diagnose, dass man da eigentlich überfordert mit ist, ist ja etwas passiert. Man muss also Kompetenz vortäuschen und das tut man besonders dann, wenn man ja in so einer misslichen Lage ist, dass es eigentlich so auf einen einprasselt, dass man es gar nicht kann. Das hat ja dann zur Folge, dass wir eigentlich so eine Inflation von Kompetenz-Performance erleben, das sieht dann so aus, dass laufend erzählt wird, das ist das Trump-Playbook.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das ist die große Strategie. Und dann bekommt man aber alle drei Tage wieder eine völlig neue Strategie und ein völlig neues Playbook präsentiert. Naja, man tut so, als könnte man das alles mal gerade nach einer ganz großen Agenda durchforsten und sagen, nun da geht das hin und 2035 wollen die da rauskommen. In Wahrheit aber weiß Trump heute das und morgen das und übermorgen macht er vielleicht wieder eine Kehrtwende und man kann genau dieses Playbook nicht durchspielen. Aber es wird die ganze Zeit so getan, als würde eigentlich alles nach einem großen Masterplan verlaufen, was ja eigentlich so eine Verschwörungstheorie der Mitte jetzt wird. Also wir haben eigentlich die ganze Zeit immer Verschwörungstheorien bekämpft, bei denen immer gesagt wird, es gibt den einen großen Plan und damit soll das System gestürzt werden und so etwas. Während man jetzt die ganze Zeit aus der Mitte heraus sagt, ja das ist jetzt dieser eine Plan, mit dem will Trump dies und das machen. Und dann merkt man drei Tage später, ach das hält schon nicht mehr, weil er gerade den Minister, mit dem er diesen Masterplan umsetzen wollte, schon wieder rausgeworfen hat wegen irgendetwas.
Genau, es gibt in der Soziologie, das kann, wer Interesse hat, selber googeln, diese Fragestellung, gibt es überhaupt Kompetenz? Also kann man überhaupt die Welt bewältigen? Oder wäre nicht so was wie Trump, also so ein Trial and Error zu machen und dann so mit dem Vibe zu gehen, nicht eigentlich das Richtige? Und der Grundbegriff dazu heißt Kompetenz-Darstellungskompetenz. Also wenn es überhaupt eine Kompetenz gibt, dann vorzutäuschen, man hätte Kompetenz und es klingt jetzt ein bisschen komisch, aber es ist tatsächlich für einen der relevanteren Grundbegriffe, gerade für so eine pragmatische Soziologie, wo man auch mal zu einem Argument kommt, Kompetenz-Darstellungskompetenz. Also wer das googelt, findet sofort Dutzende Texte. So, jetzt Ulf Burmeier. Es ist wirklich grandios, denn hier haben wir auch dieses Phänomen, so wie wir auch, unendlich viel geredet. Aber was wir jetzt vor einem halben Jahr gesagt haben, wissen wir nicht mehr so ganz genau. Und jetzt liegen halt Themen auf dem Tisch, wir sagen irgendwas. Dann kommt irgendwer bei einer Live-Veranstaltung und sagt, ja, ihr hattet es ja damals so gesagt und jetzt so, wie ist denn das zu erklären? Und dann sage ich gar nicht, sorry, du hast offenbar ein Höherlebnis gehabt, das sich mit meinem Sprecherlebnis nicht deckt. Weiß ich jedenfalls nicht. In meinem Arbeitsgedächtnis liegt es nicht mehr. In meinem richtigen Speicher kann ich gerade nicht nachgucken, wie auch immer. Also das musst du schon selber mit dir erklären. Wir versuchen jetzt aber trotzdem aus Ulf Burmeier einen roten Faden rauszuleiern. Es ist mir nämlich völlig unklar, was hier passiert. Also, Ulf Burmeier, wir hören ihn in zwei Clips aus seinem eigenen Podcast Lage der Nation vom 27.11. Er erklärt uns die Sache mit Putin, der Ukraine, dem deutschen Engagement. Wie wir das jetzt alles machen müssen. Das Ziel des Krieges ist ja offen. Wir wissen nicht genau. Jemand, der hat jemals außer halt Zero Putin oder so. Regime Change, keine Ahnung. Oder soll die Ukraine jetzt in Russland angreifen oder was auch immer. Jetzt wird uns hier mal ein Ziel des Krieges genannt.
Und das ist glaube ich das große Problem, das was die Europäer einfach überhaupt nicht verstehen. Es geht für...
So, was die Europäer überhaupt nicht verstehen, was offenbar also Ulf Burmeier versteht und uns jetzt mitteilen möchte.
Einfach überhaupt nicht verstehen. Es geht für Putin nicht darum, irgendwelche Fragen mit der Ukraine zu klären. Es geht darum, seinem neokolonialen Spirit hinterher zu laufen. Er möchte einfach das russische Weltreich wieder auferstehen lassen und er braucht den Krieg auch innenpolitisch einfach, weil er seine Macht festigt, weil er sich ein...
Das höre ich aber jetzt seit drei Jahren von all diesen Leuten.
Nur Ulf Burmeier versteht das.
Dass der neokolonial ist und der all das gerne wieder so hätte wie früher.
Die Ukraine ist auch nur... Es hat halt die Ukraine getroffen, aber eigentlich würde er gerne die ganze Welt anzünden.
Einfach dann wesentlich besser im Sattel halten kann, wenn er irgendwelche externen Konflikte provoziert. Und deswegen wird eben die Sicherheit Europas in der Ukraine verteidigt. Solange Putin da beschäftigt ist, so lange kann Europa in relativer Sicherheit leben. Und ehrlich gesagt, diese relative Sicherheit brauchen wir auch, denn wir sind ja eben militärisch noch nicht wirklich abwehrbereit. Und ich glaube, das sind diese ganzen Zusammenhänge, die in der Breite der Bevölkerung einfach noch nicht verstanden wurden, die aber auch ehrlich gesagt viel zu wenig kommuniziert wurden.
Wir haben ja eben gehört von diesem Korrespondenten der Welt, Christoph Wanner, der sagte, dass monatlich die Zahlen, genau weiß er nicht, so etwa 10.000 Menschen tot oder schwer verletzt sind in der Ukraine an der Front an Soldaten, die dann nicht mehr kämpfen können. Und jetzt sagt Ulf Burmeier, wir lassen den mal da beschäftigt, bedeutet also jeden Monat 10.000 weitere dazu, weil wir ja dann Zeit gewinnen, um aufzurüsten, um Putins neokoloniale Anliegen zu torpedieren. Das ist jetzt die Theorie. Also da können wir noch ein paar 100.000 Ukranier sterben lassen.
Ich habe hier auch gehört, das brauchen wir auch, dass Putin da beschäftigt ist in der Ukraine. Ja. Für alle, die sich jetzt fragen, hat der Burmeier das so gemeint oder wie auch immer, also hier kommt ein zweiter Clip.
Es wird immer sehr mit, also auch von der aktuellen Bundesregierung, sehr mit abstrakten Zielen argumentiert, Völkerrecht, Freiheit der Ukraine, Selbstbestimmung. Das ist auch alles richtig und wahr. Was aber viel zu wenig gesagt wird, ist, dass eben tatsächlich die Sicherheitsinteressen Deutschlands und der NATO massiv davon abhängen, dass Putin in der Ukraine zunächst mal beschäftigt ist. Und dann, wenn da irgendwann...
Wir haben doch die ganze Zeit verboten bekommen, von einem Abnutzungskrieg und all dem zu sprechen. Da hat man immer gesagt, nein, nein, das sei kein Stellvertreterkrieg.
Nein, nein, ist nicht.
Es geht nur um das Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Ukraine. Jetzt sagt er die ganze Zeit, ja. Nein, nein, wir müssen sehen, Putin ist da beschäftigt.
Der Ukraine-Krieg hat nur mit Deutschland zu tun, mit unserer Sicherheit. Und vielen Dank, liebe Ukrainer, dass ihr Putin da beschäftigt.
Und der NATO massiv davon abhängen, dass Putin in der Ukraine zunächst mal beschäftigt ist und dann, wenn da irgendwann mal Frieden herrschen sollte, die Lektionen gelernt hat, dass sich militärisch also nicht nur Putin besiegen, sondern auch eine Lektion erteilt. Abenteuer nicht lohnen. Das letzte, was man will, aus der Perspektive der europäischen Sicherheit ist, dass Putin aus diesem ganzen Ukraine-Thema rausgeht mit der Erkenntnis, ja, okay, ist nicht Bombe gelaufen, aber unter dem Strich ein Superprojekt, sondern er muss das bereuen. Wenn er das nicht bereut, dann ist die große Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es einfach sehr bald das nächste militärische Abenteuer von Vladimir Putin gibt, dass er einfach mutwillig vom Zaun bricht, so wie er den Ukraine konfliktiert, auch mutwillig vom Zaun gebrochen hat, und zwar planmäßig seit etwa 15 Jahren. Und das ist, glaube ich, das ist die zentrale Erkenntnis. Es hilft niemandem, wenn da irgendwie so ein bisschen Waffenstillstand in der Ukraine ist. Putin muss lernen, so geht es nicht.
So, jetzt verstehe ich allerdings, warum der Ukraine-Krieg schon so lange läuft. Und warum das auch politisch gewollt wird von den europäischen Kräften. Denn ich glaube, anders als Uwe Bohrmeier mir sagt, dass die Europäer das nicht verstehen, ich glaube, das verstehen die ziemlich gut. Und das ist genau die Taktik, die gerade läuft.
Ja, nur war das ja genau die Aussage immer von jenen Kritikern dieser Politik, die dann sich anhören mussten, ihr seid aber Putin-Trolle oder sonst was. Und jetzt wird hier sogar aus dieser Riege so argumentiert, dass man sagt, ja wir sollen, wir kämpfen bis zum letzten Ukrainer, damit wir uns weiter sicher fühlen. Und reden wir jetzt mal nicht über selbstbestimmungsreich, völkerreich, alles gut und schön, stimmt auch, aber eigentlich geht es um was anderes. Also hier wird es ja in aller Klarheit ausgesprochen, dass man die Ukrainer als Kanonenfutter verwendet.
Und ich finde es auch betrüblich traurig und dramatisch, dass wir hier quasi drei Jahre lang eine Argumentation laufen haben, mit, ne, wir können nicht einfach den Ukrainern sagen, wir schicken euch mal Helme, gut Gewehre, vielleicht mal ein Panzer, wie auch immer. Lass es köcheln, nutzt euch für uns ab. So, dieser Krieg wird leider kein Ende haben, denn der ist nicht gewollt. Und dann kriegt man drei Jahre Liga Kritik. Nein, also die Europäer tun doch alles dafür, aber der Putin lässt ja nicht mit sich reden. Und die Strakts immer mal voll super engagiert. Und dann von diesen handvoll Note-1-Juristen, von denen wir jetzt in der LGBT-Zeit alle auch wissen, was das bedeutet, nämlich gut Glück, man gibt so Noten, Texte ab und dann der eine bewertet so, der andere bewertet so, dass er dann plötzlich mit seinem juristischen Sing-Sang, das ist ja alles schön und gut mit dem Völkerrecht und so, aber was ja eigentlich Sache ist, ist, der muss seine Lektion lernen. Und wer nicht hören will, muss fühlen. Und wir wollen ja auch nicht richtig fühlen, aber zum Glück sind die Ukrainer da, die so ein bisschen für uns fühlen und so, wie ein Krieg ist. Das ist doch wirklich absurd einfach, ja?
Zehntausend Tote, Bruderlich, aber so ist es halt, wir teilen eine Lektion. Und das ist ja genau die Position. Das muss man noch mal hier klar herausstellen. Die Habermas in seinem großen Aufsatz in der Süddeutschen Zeitung, damals kritisierte auf diesen zwei Seiten, schrieb er ja, das Problem ist, dass die Europäer in der Zuschauerloge sitzen und sagen, jetzt macht mal. Und dann wird sich moralisch immer weiter gesteigert und überschlagen mit dem, was man da angeblich will. Und jetzt aber plötzlich, wo es dann doch einmal zu Verhandlungen kommen könnte, lässt man die Katze aus dem Sack und sagt, na ja, darum ging es jetzt uns gerade nie, sondern wir wollen jetzt eigentlich Putin beschäftigt halten. Die sollen ja nicht sehen, dass sie jetzt einen Friedensschluss hinbekommen, sondern lasst ihn mal lieber dort beschäftigt sein. Wir haben noch nicht genügend aufgerüstet, etc.
Ja, und mit dem...
Also unter welchem, also man stelle sich vor, man hätte zu Beginn des Krieges den Ukrainern gesagt, also ja, ihr wollt euch da so selbst finden und selbstbestimmen oder so, aber darum geht es jetzt gar nicht. Denkt jetzt einfach daran, an uns, wir rüsten irgendwie so langsam auf und macht jetzt erst mal, haltet uns mal die Bahn frei. Dann hätte ja jeder Ukrainer gesagt, ja, ich bin ja nicht verrückt, ja.
Im Grunde ist das so dieses, ja, da richtet man dann eine Pufferzone ein. Also die NATO-Grenze beginnt erst vorher. Es ist nicht direkt an Russland dran so, es ist eine Pufferzone. Nur, ja, was heißt denn Pufferzone? Ja, dass es da halt auch mal vor sich hin brodeln kann. Und das passiert jetzt gerade. Also man macht so das Versprechen des, nee, nee, wir organisieren euch da so eine Grenze, das wird wie mit Westdeutschland und der DDR blühende Landschaften auf beiden Seiten, damit sich die Blöcke zeigen, wie toll es läuft und so. Nö, nicht, sondern wir lassen es einfach so ein bisschen brodeln.
Aber ich hab heute schon diesen Begriff gehabt, große Gewöhnung, die jetzt so stattfindet. Und das ist wirklich das, was wir erleben können, dass man sagt, wir gewöhnen uns daran, dass wir im Mittelmeer die Leute ertrinken lassen. Da haben wir auch so ein paar Unternehmen, die sich darum kümmern, so halbstaatlich machen wir das, ja, und der Rest wird irgendeine libysche Miliz überlassen. Und die Ukrainer, die lassen wir da sterben. Die machen das auch für was. Und ach ja, dann haben wir noch unsere Vergangenheit mit der Staatsräson. Gut, das müssen die Palästinenser mal ausbaten. Da wollen wir uns jetzt auch nicht mal so reinhängen. Und wir gewöhnen uns einfach mal so daran.
Im Bangladesch arbeiten für alle von uns 50 Sklaven.
Ja, das ist wirklich neben uns die Sintflut oder um uns herum die Sintflut. Aber wir werden weiterhin in großen moralischen Appellen nochmal deutlich machen, wie wichtig hier unsere Werte sind.
Ja, aber der Wohlstand ist jetzt bedroht. Zum Glück Kalendereffekt nächstes Jahr. So, mit so einer Argumentation kommt man natürlich jetzt nach oben. Man wird aus der freien Podcast-Szene in die große Deutschlandfunkriege aufgenommen. Also ich finde Deutschlandfunk wirklich ein sehr nationelles Programm. Aber manchmal gibt es halt echt so Momente, wo ich mir denke, hätte man lieber nicht machen sollen, kein Programm wäre besser gewesen, hätte man hier Diana Dammraus Weihnachtsmusik gespielt. Deutschland wäre es gut gegangen. Stattdessen machen sie einen Politikpodcast. Also Ulf Bohrmeier erklärt uns jetzt Migrations- und Sozialpolitik. Er hat eine These, ich weiß nicht, ob er sie gegen Robin Alexander stellen wollte, der ja vorhin mit offene Grenzen sind ja gescheitert und beim Bürgergeld wollten die Leute halt und so, ihr Gefühl bedient haben. Ulf Bohrmeier versucht es mit diesem Argument.
Du hattest mich ja gefragt nach meiner These. Und meine These für diese Sendung ist eben wie gesagt innenpolitisch gewesen. Ich habe es mir etwas zugespitzt. Ich AG is over. Und ich glaube, dass wir einfach merken, dass eine Politik der Entsolidarisierung, der Zuspitzung, auch der Ausgrenzung der Polarisierung an ihre Grenzen stößt. Wir haben jetzt ein halbes Jahr innenpolitisch große Zuspitzungen erlebt. Denken wir an die Diskussion mehr Härte gegen Menschen im Bezug von Bürgergeld. Denken wir an die Diskussion maximale Härte gegenüber geflüchteten Menschen. Was wir sehen, ist das zentrale Ziel dieser Politik einer neuen Härte ist nicht erreicht worden. Die AfD ist nicht geschwächt worden. Es gibt natürlich auch keinen Wirtschaftsaufschwung. Das war wahrscheinlich auch nie wirklich ernsthaft erwartet worden, dass das irgendwie zusammenhängt. Aber ich glaube, das muss man einfach konstatieren. Diese Politik der Kälte gegenüber Geflüchteten, gegenüber ärmeren Menschen, die ist jedenfalls Stand heute gescheitert. Sie hat jetzt sie nicht erreicht. Und die spannende Frage ist, ob diese Botschaft auch im Kanzleramt angekommen ist, ob sie im Willy-Brandt-Haus angekommen ist.
Ja, diese Botschaft ist jetzt angekommen, Ulf. Und deswegen beginnt jetzt ein sozialdemokratisches Jahrzehnt. Also, über was genau reden die da und wie? Ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Ja, es ist, glaube ich, dass sie doch...
Die Politik der sozialen Kälte ist gescheitert.
Ja, nicht für die, die da aus...
Aber was soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Naja, ich glaube, so was passiert nur, wenn man eigentlich glaubt, dass man Podcasts und Nachrichtensendungen macht für die Mächtigen. Also sie haben halt nicht die Möglichkeit, mit Friedrich Merz oder mit der Bärbel Baas direkt zu telefonieren. Also müssen sie den Umweg über den Podcast nehmen und sprechen aber zu denen, ja. Das ist, glaube ich, diese Idee. Und deshalb sagen sie jetzt, guck mal, das hat doch gar nicht funktioniert, aber für die funktioniert's ja.
Ja. Ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen, dass er sagt, man hatte Migrations- und sozialpolitische Ambitionen und zwar Grenzen irgendwie zu. Man fliegt da Bundespolizisten an die Grenze für teuer Geld und damit wert man Flüchtlinge ab und man macht diesen sozialpolitischen Diskurs zum Bürgergeld, wie wir ihn hatten. Und jetzt sieht man aber, ah, es sind gar keine Einsparungen da beim Bürgergeld und die Flüchtlinge sind halt immer noch da. Keine Ahnung, wie auch immer, wie man das dann verrechnet. Nur, also glaubt er jetzt, ah ja, jetzt setzen sich die Politiker hin und ziehen Strich drunter und sehen, ah ja, wir haben ja gar keine Ersparnisse beim Bürgergeld und die Flüchtlingszahlen sind wir jetzt auf niedrigem Niveau, aber durch Scholz-Europapolitik und nicht durch Merz-Innenpolitik. Und es zieht auch niemand Bilanz wegen Zahlen.
Nein.
Sondern die Politik ist halt, wie die Politik ist.
Ja, ja, aber das ist so der Glaube, man rechnet es nochmal vor und dann wird die Hausaufgabe nochmal korrigiert.
Aber warum stellt er hier so eine Zäsur in den Raum? Mit der Unterstellung, na ja, und jetzt, weil die Politiker ja klug sind, ziehen sie Bilanz und sagen, ne, das Pendel muss zurückschwingen. Wir haben uns hier verrannt, wir machen jetzt Sozialpolitik, wie Willy Brandt sie vorhatte.
Ja, das Gegenteil findet ja auch statt.
Also das ist einfach dieses ganze Denkgebäude so.
Da ist Christina Schröder mit ihrem komischen Think Tank, die nochmal sagt, wo könnte man eigentlich bei Menschen mit Behinderung sparen. Wir haben ja nur weitere Vorschläge, die in die entsprechende Richtung gehen.
Vor allem, wir haben ja auch diesen Wendepunktverein da jetzt, der quasi Turning Point Germany ist. Also es geht doch jetzt erst los mit dieser, was er gerade als gescheitert erklärt. Wir werden doch dran gewöhnt, dass das Scheitern ist, weitergehen.
Man sollte denen das doch auch nicht glauben. Linneman wusste doch, dass keine riesen Einsparungen damit zu machen sind. Der hat das da mal gesagt, wenn er irgendwo in der Runde saß, da werden wir Milliarden sparen, damit alle mal kurz Ruhe geben. Aber er selbst ist ja nicht zu blöd, um die Zahlen zu kennen. Also das ist ja nicht so, dass die das jetzt nochmal für sich durchrechnen und sagen, Mensch, ich habe bei der Einkommensteuer einen Fehler gemacht, sondern die wissen das ja. Sie machen die Politik ja wissentlich.
Das ist vielleicht ein ganz wichtiger Punkt für die Journalisten, die ja wie Bettina Schmitt-Materney meinte, vielleicht verstehen sie es nicht immer. Vielleicht macht die Politik gar keine Irrtümer, sondern sie lügt von Anfang an.
Ja.
Vielleicht wussten die in der CDU einfach, dass sie sich gerade um Faktor 350 verrechnen, machen das aber ganz bewusst.
Könnte man dann auch in der Erklärung einpreisen, die man als Journalist...
Es gab jetzt zum Beispiel mal einen Bundeskanzler, der gesagt hat, dass die Schuldenbremse eingehalten wird und dass es kein Sondervermögen noch mal geben darf. Und dann wurde der gewählt und dann hat er noch einen Tag später noch gefordert, das mit dem alten Bundestag. Und das hat man echt auch noch gemacht. Ja, wer denkt denn dann so was noch?
Es war ein guter Trick, einfach die Öffentlichkeit damit zu beschäftigen, ob das denn der alte Bundestag noch darf. Das ist ein bisschen wie bei Kindern, dass man sie fragt, also nicht möchtest du dich jetzt bettfertig machen, sondern möchtest du zuerst Zähne putzen oder zuerst den Schlaubertzug anziehen. Alternative A oder B. Aber Alternative C ist damit weg. Also so geht das dann. So in dieser Denke, dass hier gerade Politiker und Journalisten einsehen, dass die Migrations- und Sozialpolitik gescheitert ist und deswegen jetzt das hoffnungsvolle Land vor uns liegt. Mit diesem Denkgebäude im Hinterkopf versucht Ulf Bohrmeier uns jetzt noch mal zu verdeutlichen, wie man im Deutschlandfunk über die Wehrdienstdiskussion reden sollte.
Ich würde es gerne noch mal kurz unterschreiben, was du gesagt hast. Wir hatten in der Lage der Nation jetzt vor kurzem eine ausführliche Diskussion über die Wehrpflicht, über die Verteidigungsfähigkeit, über die Frage, würdest du kämpfen, wenn Deutschland angegriffen würde? Oder würdest du dich vom Acker machen, wie es ja eben auch manche Menschen sehr öffentlichkeitswirksam fordern? Und in dieser Diskussion haben wir bei uns gerade im Lageforum, also quasi in unserem Diskussionsforum, immer wieder gehört, warum soll ich für dieses Land kämpfen, wenn es diese Regierung nicht schafft, zum Beispiel einen Beitrag zu leisten für den Klimaschutz, wenn dieses Land es nicht schafft, die Renten zukunftsfest aufzustellen. Also ich glaube, das ist was, was im politischen Berlin nicht hinreichend einfach auf dem Zettel ist.
Glaubt er?
Auf dem Schirm ist, wie sehr Menschen, die jetzt gerade anfangen, sich politisch zu sozialisieren, wie sehr die eigentlich frustriert sind.
Genau, aber die Entscheidung für eine Wehrpflicht, das ist ja eine Entscheidung für die junge Generation. Denn das ist ja ein Beitrag in unsere Sicherheit. Also ich finde, da springt man zu kurz, wenn man sagt, jetzt müssen die Jungen ran. Erstens waren die Alten, die waren schon dran. Die haben das ja, also es gab eine kleine Generation dazwischen, die hat keinen Wehrdienst gemacht. Die Älteren haben das gemacht. Und das ist ja genau das. Das ist ja eine Investition, nicht eine materielle, aber ein Engagement in die eigene Zukunft. Also das finde ich, kann man nicht als Belastung, es ist nicht angenehm, aber das kann man nicht als eine ungewöhnliche Belastung der jüngeren Generation werten.
Ich habe das nur dargestellt, wie das bei uns im Forum anklang, das ist jetzt nicht meine Idee.
Ich habe das ja nur dargestellt. Und wie du das gerade gesagt hast, ist natürlich auch mir voll einleuchtend. Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, glauben die, da hört jemand zu? Und was glauben die, wie ist der drauf? Also wenn jetzt ein 17-Jähriger durch Zufall zuhört, ne? Und er hört jetzt von der Schmittmatern? Ne, also ein Wehrdienst ist ja eine Investition in die eigene Zukunft. Weil damit garantiert man ja, dass Deutschland noch da ist, nachdem Putin angreift. Und das ist doch völlig klar. Da denke ich so, nein, der Typ fragt sich grad, wie er sein Date heute Abend plant. Und zwar völlig zu Recht, weil darum geht es im Leben. Und der ist nicht offen für bescheuerte Argumentation. Also bietet ihm einfach meine Kluge.
Und für was wäre Wettgespiele? Putin scheitert an der Ukraine laufen, aber wird bald in Berlin sein. Und deshalb muss ich jetzt sagen, Freundin geht nicht, Sex auch nicht, wie wir gehört haben in diesem Bundeswehr-Spot. Jetzt geht es an die Front bzw. jetzt geht es erstmal zum Wehrdienst, damit ich der Pflicht nachkomme. Und wenn es aber mich danach hart treffen sollte, also ich verliere z.B. einen Job danach, dann werde ich, wenn ich den ersten und den zweiten Termin versäume, sanktioniert noch und nöcher.
Dann musst du schon eine Psydiagnose vorlegen, die du nie wieder aus deiner Biografie gestrichen kriegst.
Im Übrigen würde ich das sowieso jetzt empfehlen, auch mal den Eltern, die jetzt Kinder haben, Jungs haben, 16, 17, jetzt schon mal Arzt aufsuchen und so Atteste einsammeln, da gibt es viele Möglichkeiten, diese ganzen Allergien und da müsste man doch auch mal dieses ganze ADHS so richtig in Anschlag bringen können, oder?
Also ich würde die Heugabel nehmen und mit zum Musterungstermin gehen.
Nee, aber ich würde sagen, da kann man doch jetzt bestimmt richtig viel auf der Ebene an Attesten einsammeln.
Ja, das macht aber auch alles wieder Arbeit. Und weißt du, was Familien nicht mögen? Sinnlose Arbeit für die Politik.
Ich will es ja nur raten, dass man da schon mal entsprechend vorsorgt.
Ich finde, wir sollten jetzt alle mal Briefe an den Deutschlandfunk schreiben, indem wir die Zitate der Sätze, die wir gerade gehört haben, in den Brief aufnehmen und dann einfach drunterschreiben, ich habe das nicht verstanden, können Sie mir es nochmal erklären?
Ja.
Weil das ist nicht zu verstehen, was hier ist. Man hört so ein bisschen, das ist deutsche Sprache, aber die Worte, so irgendwie ergibt es keinen Sinn. Robin Alexander macht hier einen Spruch.
Also sollte die These stimmen, dass die junge Generation nicht bereit ist, Deutschland zu verteidigen, wegen mangelndem Klimaschutz, dann wünsche ich viel Erfolg mit klimapolitischen Maßnahmen unter russischer Besatzung. Also dieser Standpunkt, wenn ihn so viele teilen, die Wahlergebnisse bei den Erstwiedern sprechen ja krass dagegen, der wäre doch ein wenig unplausibel, oder?
Das ist wie Mark Rutte, der als NATO-Chef in irgendeinem Podium sitzt und sagt, wenn wir uns nicht verteidigen, müssen wir hier alle russisch reden. Ja. Das verstehen normale Menschen in diesem Land nicht, weil es dann nichts zu verstehen gibt, liebe Journalisten.
Das ist einfach ein Unsinn.
Oder kann Putin alles? Bringt der Russisch-Lehrer mit, die uns dann russisch beibringen?
Ja, ja. Da kommen Millionen, weil die Russen haben ja so viele Leute, wie wir wissen. Die haben ja gar kein demografisches Problem. Die kommen alle hier hin und werden dann uns hier alle russisch beibringen. Das wird schon 2029 so weit sein.
Nadine Lindner versucht es mal mit einer Erklärung.
Was ich ja ziemlich interessant finde, das ist, wenn man es quasi noch mal eine Ebene höher zieht, dass der Schaden oder dass sozusagen der Einsatz im Persönlichen gesehen wird und dass der Nutzen ja eher abstrakter ist. Also das heißt, es ist ja was, was ich persönlich tun soll, indem ich in eine Kaserne gehe, indem ich lerne.
Ja klar, ich bin nicht nur eine Statistik. Wenn ich tot bin, an der Front gestorben bin, dann kann ich ja nicht mir nacheinander sagen, ja, war so im Ganzen, so das Abstrakte war es doch gut.
Wir hören das nochmal. Also sie stellt gerade fest, dass der einzelne, trotz aller gegenteiligen, gegen lauten Werbemaßnahmen, ja gar nicht Deutschland ist, sondern dass Deutschland etwas abstraktes ist. Oder die Zukunft, oder was auch immer.
Haben wir nicht eben aus dem Deutschlandfunk dieses Feature gespielt zur russischen Propaganda an Schulen, wo gesagt wird, du bist nicht der Einzelne, sondern du bist das Rädchen, du bist die Heimat, du bist Russland.
Da wundern sie sich ja so ein bisschen, dass der Einzelne gar nicht versteht, ach so, aber der ist doch Deutschland.
Also Leute, die ja nur individualistisch leben. Also das sind ja alles Leute, die können ja schalten und walten, wie sie wollen. Also die sind ja auch in einer sehr glücklichen Situation, ähnlich jetzt unserer zusammen. Wir nehmen Podcasts auf, wir machen Auftritte, wir schreiben Bücher. Also das ist ja die komfortabelste Situation, die man erstmal hat.
Das ist im Grunde die Freiheit, die es zu erreichen ist und zu verteidigen. Aber nee, du musst Deutschland sein. Nur Podcasten geht nicht, du musst Deutschland sein.
Also was ich ja ziemlich interessant finde, das ist, wenn man es quasi nochmal eine Ebene höher zieht, dass der Schaden oder dass sozusagen der Einsatz im Persönlichen gesehen wird und dass der Nutzen ja eher abstrakter ist. Also das heißt, es ist ja was, was ich persönlich...
Ja, also wenn du kämpfst und bei diesem Kampf stirbst, war der Einsatz halt persönlich. Und du hast dann halt nichts, gar nichts davon, ja.
Oder du machst oder du musst dann halt einen richtigen Kult aufbauen, dass man dann sagt, starb für Volk und Führer oder so. Dann musst du sagen, dann hat der Einzelne, ist eingegangen in die große Volksgemeinschaft und wird jetzt nach Walhall überführt.
Woanders haben wir denn diesen Gemeinsinn, den sie ja gerade einfordert, mal drin? Bei einer Zeugnisvergabe nicht, bei der Führerscheinvergabe nicht, bei den Lohnverhandlungen nicht, bei der Studienwahl nicht, bei Prüfungsleistungen nicht, nirgendwo.
Wird alles kompetitiv angelegt.
Genau.
Und soll auch so sein, damit wir stark sind und innovativ sind.
Gemeinsinn, das hat man mal, wenn man 15-jährig alleine für zwei Wochen dankenswerderweise ins Ausland, in den Urlaub fährt mit der Peer Group und die Eltern mal nicht dabei sind. Dann hat man das mal. Ich würde ja sagen, ich habe ja schon das Pädoyer für die Alten gemacht, Urlaubs bis ans Lebensende. Also, dass man das einfach kultiviert und zum Lifestyle macht. Und zwar für alle überall. Von daher, liebe Leute, wenn ihr wollt, dass eure Leute länger bei euch arbeiten, auch übers Rentenalter hinaus, dann bietet ihnen doch einfach eine Arbeitsstelle, wo es schön ist.
Ja, diese Gemeinsamssache, dass man sagt, gut, mein persönliches ist mir jetzt nicht so wichtig. Also, kennt irgendjemand wen, der schon mal gesagt hat, ich zahle in diesem Jahr 10.000 Euro Steuern mehr für den Gemeinsinn? Nein, jeder wird natürlich versuchen, nur die Steuern zu zahlen, die er zahlen muss. Das ist ja völlig natürlich, das so zu tun. Aber nein, nach diesen Gemeinsamspredigern würden wir uns ja alle am liebsten nur dem Kollektiv hingeben.
Und das findet sie jetzt wahnsinnig interessant, ja? Sie fühlt das hier noch ein bisschen aus.
Das heißt, es ist ja was, was ich persönlich tun soll, indem ich in eine Kaserne gehe, indem ich lerne, mit einer Waffe zu schießen, was ja auch...
Ja, mit einer Waffe schießen heißt auf der anderen Seite, stirbt jemand, weil da übt auch jemand, mit der Waffe zu schießen und zwar auf dich. Weiß nicht genau, warum das immer nur so halb zu Ende gedacht wird. Man will es nicht so richtig aussprechen. Da übt man mit einer Waffe zu schießen.
Okay.
Für viele Menschen einfach eine sehr beunruhigende Vorstellung ist.
Ja, das ist für viele Menschen sehr beunruhigend.
Ja, also deswegen habe ich mich auch jetzt privat nicht bewaffnet.
Wir haben Schusswaffen aus dem zivilen Leben in Deutschland verbannt. Wir gucken amerikanisches Fernsehen, wundern uns darüber, was da vor sich geht. Und jetzt wundert sie sich darüber, dass es einige Menschen befremdlich finden, mit einer Waffe zu schießen, nicht mehr zu Hause zu wohnen, sondern in der Kaserne und so. Warum wundern die sich so?
Ich meine, die würden noch... Stell dir mal vor, ich würde sagen, ich gehe gleich noch in die Stadt, nach Frankfurt rein und habe einen Revolver dabei. Weil man weiß ja nicht, kann ja sein, dass ich jemanden abknallen muss, der mir zu nahe tritt.
Dann ist doch gut, wenn du es vorhin in der Kaserne geübt hast.
Menschen einfach eine sehr beunruhigende Vorstellung ist, indem ich möglicherweise dann halt auch näher an einen militärischen Einsatz rücke, etc.,
etc. Also tot, unversehen, etc., etc.
Natürlich immer unter der Möglichkeit, dass auch verweigert werden kann, dass man auch im Zivilen natürlich diesen Dienst leisten kann. Aber ich glaube, das ist dann erst mal ein persönlicher Einsatz, ein persönlicher Kosten, den man sieht. Und ich glaube, dass viel noch zu abstrakt ist, wofür es eigentlich sein soll. Und ich sehe durchaus...
Jetzt kommt die große, das Rätsel ist jetzt auf dem Tisch. Jetzt kommt die Aufklärung.
Eine Parallele zwischen dem, was wir im Klimaschutz natürlich halt auch immer wieder diskutieren, dass es dann darum geht, was für...
Das finde ich sehr gut, das liegt ja auf der Hand. Beim Klima haben wir ja auch schon ein größeres Thema. Die Frage ist jetzt ein bisschen, versteht sie gleich selber, während sie darüber redet, wer sich beim Klima verweigert und wer dort das Engagement gezeigt hat? Vielleicht passt es doch nicht so, wer Dienst und Klima auf einen Nenner bringen zu wollen.
Zwischen dem, was wir im Klimaschutz natürlich auch immer wieder diskutieren, dass es dann darum geht, was für eine Heizung soll ich haben, was für ein Auto soll ich fahren, wie soll ich meine Mobilität, meinen Konsum gestalten? mich selber einschränken für ein Ziel, was ich gar nicht selber so richtig greifen kann. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass es hier Parallelen gibt.
Ja, ich habe da auch ein Gefühl, dass es da Parallelen gibt, nämlich... Und das wünsche ich mir dann auch nächstes Jahr. Wenn Ü40er wollen, dass junge Leute zur Bundeswehr gehen, dann möchte ich, dass sie das kundtun, indem sie sich mit Kleber auf die Straße kleben und ein Schild hochhalten mit... Du fährst jetzt nicht in die Schule, du fährst jetzt in die Kaserne. Ja. So. Und für den Fall, dass die jungen Leute dann nicht aus dem Auto steigen und die einfach verprügeln, weil die... Man will ja in die Schule. So. Würde ich sagen, okay, dann ist der Diskurs jetzt eröffnet. So. Aber wieso wundern die sich?
Ich verstehe das einfach. Wir wissen ja, die 17-Jährigen, die denken ja über die Heizung nach, die wollen ihre Ölheizung behalten, die wollen das Auto fahren und den übermäßigen Konsum.
Genau.
Sind das nicht andere?
Ja, also ich muss mich, ich also.
Aber ich meine, wir haben jetzt hier ja schon in mehreren Folgen, sagen wir, Elitendiskurse dargestellt. Und ich habe da von Elitendämmerung gesprochen, jetzt auch angesichts von Ferdinand von Schirach. Sondern das scheint ja flächendeckend so zu sein, dass die Leute nicht mehr in der Lage sind, über ja Dinge klar nachzudenken und dann nur noch mit solchen ideologischen Argumentationen kommen.
Ich würde das, was du jetzt über Dinge klar nachzudenken, ich würde sagen, das Leben führen diese Leute da in Berlin, die immer morgens zum Radio fahren und dann immer erzählen, wie übernächtig sie sind, weil mal wieder irgendeinen Koalitionsausschuss tagte, führen die wirklich gar kein echtes Leben mehr. Ich habe mich das bei Journalisten immer gewundert. Sie haben morgens den Stress mit der Familie, sie müssen wieder hier in der Reise da, keine Ahnung, was auch immer. Sie kommen in der Redaktion an und es ist wie in Severance. Drei Sekunden im Fahrstuhl hat die einfach komplett ausgenockt. Sie haben alles vergessen, dass das Kind sich ja morgen nicht anziehen wollte, dass die Kita anrief und sagte, können Sie das Kind schon 15 Uhr abholen und so. Das wird alles vergessen für die Zeit, in der man in der Redaktion sitzt, weil jetzt macht man ja die wichtigen Themen. Und dann versucht man so den Weltgeist nachzuspüren, das abstrakte Deutschland, was heißt das eigentlich und so. Und ich denke mir so, Leute.
Also man zieht doch nicht morgens ein Kind an und sagt, in zwölf Jahren kannst du auch an die Front.
Ja genau, lieber Deutschlandfunk, nächstes Jahr ladet doch Wolfgang und mich ein für euren Jahresrückblick. Und dann reden wir über die ernsthaften Themen. Welchen Sport haben wir gemacht? Was haben wir gegessen? Was haben wir in der Oper gesehen? Was war im Leben los so? Wie hat uns die KI dieses Jahr wieder weitergeholfen? Haben wir irgendwelche blöden Erfahrungen mit irgendwelchen Leuten gemacht, die uns über den Tisch ziehen wollten? Das sind doch die Themen. Und nicht das abstrakte, ja, da muss ich mich auch wundern. Also hier, die wissen offenbar gar nicht, warum es sich zu kämpfen lohnt. Können wir nicht erstmal darüber reden, warum es sich zu leben lohnt und so. Es ist alles ganz schräg, was hier abläuft. Jetzt kommt natürlich der Experten-Diskurs zum Thema. Denn die Themen, die noch offen sind, sind, sind wir jetzt Aufmarschgebiet oder Frontstaat?
Ach so, so hab ich es mir noch gar nicht vergegenwärtigt.
Natürlich wieder mit unserem Podcast-Superstar Ulf Burmeier. Wir sind so froh, dass aus unserer Podcast-Riegel jemand beim großen Deutschlandfunk vertreten ist, um einfach diese wichtige, mich auch quälende Frage zu klären, ob ich jetzt hier gerade das Aufmarschgebiet aufbereiten muss oder vielleicht doch selber an die Front.
Würde da einmal ein Fragezeichen dran machen, ob wir kein Frontstaat wären?
Ja, ich würde da einmal kurz ein Fragezeichen dran machen.
Wenn ich mir anschaue, wie die Angriffe auf die Ukraine gerade ablaufen, wie sehr der Infrastruktur ins Visier genommen wird, wäre sicherlich auch deutsche Infrastruktur betroffen, wenn es tatsächlich im Osten knallt. Aber ich wollte eigentlich die Diskussion noch so ein bisschen differenzieren.
Ich glaube, das ist natürlich jetzt ein gutes Angebot. Vielleicht sollte man die Diskussion mal differenzieren.
Wir sind uns hier am Tisch relativ einig, dass...
Oh, man ist sich am Tisch relativ einig bei einem Thema.
Das ist aber ein Wunder.
Das ist natürlich eine große Erkenntnis.
Wir sind uns hier am Tisch relativ einig, dass tatsächlich Verteidigungsfähigkeit, manche nennen es Kriegsbereitschaft, erforderlich ist, einfach zwingend geboten ist. Letztlich vor allem deswegen, weil wir ja alle wollen, dass es keinen Krieg gibt. Freinach dem alten Motto, wenn du Krieg vermeiden willst, bereite dich auf den Krieg vor.
Ich hätte gerne ein Land, in dem es für jeden völlig selbstverständlich ist zu sagen, da kommt gerade einer, will ihr was kaputt machen, sorry, ich stell mich dagegen. Nur wenn es einem eh egal ist, weil man in einem ostdeutschen Dorf lebt, wo ach so, der würde uns jetzt die Dorf-Schenke nehmen, die hat uns schon vor 30 Jahren der Kapitalismus genommen. Das ist doch, wenn es nichts Öffentliches zu verteidigen gibt, wenn es heißt, draußen auf dem Acker ist eine Bombe eingeschlagen. Man lebt seit 30 Jahren neben diesem Acker und fragt sich, wem gehört der eigentlich? Also mein Acker ist das nicht. Ach so, der gehört zum australischen Hedgefonds. Da wundern die sich so ein bisschen. In Frankfurt am Main wurden jetzt ganze Straßenzüge zerstört. Da haben Leute gewohnt, das ist sehr dramatisch. Wem gehören die eigentlich? Irgendso einem Typ in Düsseldorf.
Es ist vor allen Dingen auch ein Wahn, dass man jetzt irgendwie glaubt, dass Deutschland jetzt platt gemacht wird.
So und jetzt kommt aber der Kicker, ja. Wolf Bohrmeier mit seinem, wie ich finde, für dieses Jahr das finale Argument, er versteht nicht, warum die Linken nicht verstehen.
Ich möchte aber doch noch einmal das Augenmerk darauf lenken, wie groß die Skepsis in dieser jungen Generation ist, ob dieser Staat es wert ist, verteidigt zu werden. Ich möchte diese These ausdrücklich nicht teilen. Entschuldigung.
Ich muss doch auch noch mal hier darauf hinweisen, wir haben doch da aus der Lage schon den Clip gespielt, ich habe ihn ja heute schon einmal erwähnt, dass man zur Not dann die Huttis in die Steinzeit zurückbomben muss. Es geht doch offenbar nicht nur um diese Art der Verteidigung, die hier ausgemalt wird permanent. Also wie kommt man denn die ganze Zeit, dass man da nur in diese Richtung schielt? Also wir haben doch gehört, was mal gesagt wurde, ich habe da, vergesst das doch nicht.
Ja, wir können ja noch mal hören, wie Ostbrunnen war jetzt. Es ist halt, wenn man beim Deutschlandfunk zum Jahresrückblick eingeladen ist, muss man jetzt nicht alles aufgreifen, was man in diesem Jahr so verzapft hat.
Ich möchte aber doch noch einmal das Augenmerk darauf lenken, wie groß die Skepsis in dieser jungen Generation ist, ob dieser Staat es wert ist, verteidigt zu werden. Ich möchte diese These ausdrücklich nicht teilen. Ich finde es aber für eine Demokratie außerordentlich besorgniserregend, wenn es doch eben breite Kreise gibt, die sich diese Frage stellen. Auf der Rechten erleben wir das seit Jahren. Also die AfD ist ja die Partei, aus meiner Sicht der Entsolidarisierung, das ist eine Art parteigewordener Egotrip. Aber gerade auf der linken Seite des politischen Spektrums, es wird ja eigentlich Solidarität hochgehalten. Und ich finde das einfach interessant, dass gerade Menschen, die in ihrem persönlichen Leben, bei ihren Freunden oder meinetwegen auch gegenüber zum Beispiel sozial schlechtergestellten, viel Wert auf Solidarität legen, dass die trotzdem sagen, die sind staatverteidigend? Nein. Also das kann man natürlich teilweise damit begründen, dass man sagt, ich für diese Regierung nicht, Anne, das hast du ja gerade schon zitiert. Aber jedenfalls in den Diskussionen, die bei uns im Forum geführt wurden, ging das vielmehr in die Breite. Und ich finde, das ist auch eine Chance. So eine Distanzierung von Staat und Gesellschaft ist ja auch eine Chance, sich die Frage zu stellen, was können wir denn vielleicht besser machen? Oder was machen wir denn vielleicht gerade nicht so gut?
Ja, das versteht er jetzt gar nicht.
Man solidarisiert sich mit Freunden und Familie und man solidarisiert sich, wenn man egalitär eingestellt ist, auch mit den Schwächeren. Aber man solidarisiert sich nicht mit einem abstrakten Staatsgebilde.
Aber das verstehe ich nicht, Wolfgang. Solidarität ist doch Solidarität.
Das ist eine für Opfern. Und keinem würde man jetzt zum Beispiel es krump nehmen, wenn er sagt, ich verlege meinen Lebensmittelpunkt, verlagere den nach Rom. Da wird ja keiner sagen, oh, du bist aber ein Vaterlandsloser Geselle. Warum bleibst du nicht in Deutschland? Verteidige doch Frankfurt oder so. Das ist doch einfach keine Denkweise. Und wenn jetzt so getan wird, dann sei das jetzt so eine eigentlich schon fast so die Entsolidarisierung der Linken. Und bei der AfD haben wir eh schon so eine lange Entsolidarisierung. Entschuldigung, Ali Zweidel und ein Großteil der AfD ist für eine Wehrpflicht, ist für 5% NATO-Ziel. Da ist nur dieses Höckellager, das sagt für diesen Staat nicht, weil der ist denen zu vogue.
Nee, der ist denen nicht deutsch genug.
Der ist denen nicht deutsch genug, ja.
Der ist zu grün.
Deswegen können wir nicht, die können natürlich dann nicht unter einer grünen Außenministerin oder so das Land verteidigen. Aber sonst ist das doch längst die neue Querfront, die geht doch von Alice Weidel bis tief in die Sozialdemokratie hinein, dass alle sagen, jetzt müssen wir aber mal.
Ja, ich finde es einfach sehr gut, dass man die Linken festnagelt auf, na die sind doch vor Solidarität. Warum sind die denn jetzt nicht solidarisch? Das ist einfach genial, finde ich.
Wir haben ja eben die Clips gespielt. Einmal von Burmeier selbst, der sagt, wir lassen die Ukraine bitte noch weiter kämpfen. Paraphrasiert jetzt, ja. Also die Ukraine nutzen gerade Russland für uns ab. Das ist also ein völlig unsolidarisches Verhalten, das wir an den Tag legen, weil wir machtpolitische Interessen haben, sagen wir, dann sterben die da. Und wir wissen zugleich von dem WeltTV-Korrespondenten Christoph Wander heute auch gespielt, wie die Ukrainer dort eingesammelt werden, um an die Front geschickt zu werden und wie viele desertieren. Da kann man doch nicht hier jetzt sitzen und sagen, ja wer für Solidarität ist, der muss doch auch für eine Wehrpflicht und all das sein.
Ja, das sind viele offene Fragen, die uns der Deutschlandfonds nicht und so weiter. Es ist, wir müssen jetzt zum nächsten Thema kommen.
Thema Meinungsfreiheit. Keine Sorge, es geht diesmal nicht um Big Tech.
Sind wir jetzt zurück bei einem ernsten Thema oder?
Ja, wir sind jetzt bei einem ernsten Thema. Es geht jetzt nicht um Big Tech, insofern als wir wieder uns die Frage stellen, wie regulieren wir was um Kinder zu schützen oder so. Diese Debatte machen wir heute nicht auf, sondern wir sehen uns jetzt Fälle an aus diesem Monat. Man fragt sich, cancelt jetzt einfach jeder jeden. WeltTV noch einmal hier.
Wieso immer WeltTV? Hast du Springer nochmal zum Abschied noch Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt?
Na ja, manchmal wird da ja auch einfach was berichtet. Oder wenn wir jetzt gleich den Korrespondenten da hören, den man irgendwo in Berlin hingestellt hat zu der Thematik, dann merken wir natürlich auch welche Tendenz da noch drin liegt. Deswegen habe ich es auch ausgewählt.
Ich finde nur witzig, WeltTV ist für mich so dieses typische NTV. Es ist diese Aufbruchszeit 90er Jahre irgendwie. Alle freuen sich, dass sie Karten für Westernhagen haben. Und im Fernsehen, es hängen also immer überall Fernsehen rum. Also die Fernseher sind so billiger geworden im öffentlichen Raum. Und dann läuft immer ohne Ton, wie man das aus den Filmen kennt, in denen so CNN im Hintergrund läuft. Und dann sitzen immer links eine Frau und rechts ein Mann und beide haben so die Hände auf dem Tisch. Und einer redet immer und der andere guckt ganz ernst. Dann redet der andere. Und ich denke mir immer so ein bisschen, wenn ich das sehe, das ist wieder diese 90er Jahre. Also gerade Springer mit WeltTV, die so den Aufbruch in die Zukunft bringen uns noch, weil diese 90er Jahre gefühlswert sind.
Man fragt sich fast, was ist eigentlich aus den Telekom Aktien geworden.
Ja genau, man muss es mit der Volksaktie.
Jetzt also Thema Cancel Culture auf allen Ebenen. Wir gehen wirklich alles durch. Und zwar fangen wir an mit der Antifa Ost.
Linksradikale und Linksextreme sind seit sehr langer Zeit ein großes Dorn für den US-Präsidenten. Wir können uns ja zum Beispiel auch daran erinnern, dass er erst vor wenigen Wochen angekündigt hatte, die National Guard nach Portland zu schicken, nach Oregon dort in den Bundesstaaten, weil er Zitat davon gesprochen hat, dass diese Stadt von der Antifa regelrecht belagert wird. Sehr interessant ist übrigens auch, ich hatte ganz kurz die Möglichkeit heute...
Was ist also geschehen? Antifa Ost ist jetzt auch auf der, ist jetzt auch als Terrororganisation eingestuft. Das heißt also, die USA warten jetzt gar nicht, wie Deutschland dazu steht, sondern sagen jetzt einfach Antifa, Antifa Ost, okay, die sind jetzt auch Terrorinhaber, nur Ungarn sind sie es ja auch schon, deswegen machen wir das jetzt auch. Wir gehen jetzt nicht rein in, was diese Organisationen einzeln tun und so. Es ist jetzt nur interessant festzustellen, was jetzt da passiert und auch, wie das eingeordnet wird von dem Korrespondenten von WeltTV.
Auch mit einigen Polizeikontakten zu unterhalten heute unter anderem hier auch in Berlin und wenn wir uns mit Polizisten hier in der Hauptstadt unterhalten, aber auch vor allem in anderen Teilen Ostdeutschlands, denn da ist die Antifa für die Polizei immer wieder auch zum Problem geworden. Da wird doch davon gesprochen, dass man das lobt, wie der US-Präsident da jetzt durchgreift und dass man sich ja ähnliche Taten beziehungsweise ähnliche Handlungen, so heißt es richtig, auch von der deutschen Bundesregierung wünschen würde. Es gibt aber ein Problem und da ist auch der US-Präsident in der Vergangenheit schon kritisiert worden und zwar, dass die Antifa in gewisser Weise eher als lose Bewegung zählt.
Also, es ist ja nicht ein Club, in dem man einfach eintritt, so wie man sagt, ich bin jetzt SPD-Mitglied.
Ja.
Bedeutet also, alles kann dann auch Antifa werden.
Es ist wie mit Links Media oder wie die da heißen, Indy Media.
Indy Media, ja.
Die hat man auch nachträglich zum Verein erklärt, damit man sie dann wie den Verein behandeln kann. Also da gehört sozusagen die Erfindung überhaupt zum Urteil dazu. Es war ja schon so ein kurzer Moment, wo sich sehr viele Leute online auch lustig gemacht haben. Ich fand eins sehr witzig. Da hat einfach so ein Typ so ein Video von sich gemacht, meinte, ich bin der Präsident von Antifa. Ich fordere hiermit alle Gliederungen auf, sofort auflösen. Wir sind jetzt verboten. Und es war irgendwie amüsant, nur dadurch, dass Antifa so diffus ist, aber die Politik sich nicht scheut. Eine virtuelle Politik zu machen, bei der irgendetwas erfunden wird, ist gefährlich.
Das hat ja auch Folgen. Oder so könnte man es zumindest einschätzen. Wenn man auf solchen Sanktionslisten ist, dann kann man nicht in die USA einreisen. Gelder, die man in den USA hat, werden gesperrt. Allerdings wird das jetzt für die Antifa Ost kein großes Problem sein. Ich vermute jetzt nicht, dass die Millionen da liegen haben und dass die dann nicht in die USA einreisen können. Nun gut. Aber das bedeutet natürlich auch, was hierzulande. Ich zitiere aus einem Taz-Artikel. Da geht es um die rote Hilfe, die sich also um linke Gefangene einsetzt. Auch die werden ja immer wieder kritisiert, für wen sie sich da so alles einsetzen. Die werden auch vom Verfassungsschutz beobachtet, sind auch da schon eingestuft worden mal als linksextremistisch usw. Interessant ist nun aber, dass diese rote Hilfe ihr Bankkonto verloren hat. Und nicht nur bei der roten Hilfe ist das so, die vermutet nämlich auch, dass Trump der Auslöser ist, sondern auch bei Antifa Ost. Da heißt es, denn die hatte Mitte November die deutsche Antifa Ost bzw. Hammerbande als ausländische Terrorvereinigung eingestuft. Mit dem Namen wird eine Gruppe Antifaschistinnen bezeichnet, denen schwerer Angriff auf Rechtsextreme in Ostdeutschland und Budapest vorgeworfen wird. Mit der Einstufung setzt Trump seine Kampagne gegen die Antifa fort. Auch international, obwohl es US-Verbindungen der Antifa Ost gar nicht gibt. Welche Personen, die zur Antifa Ost zählen und sanktionieren, ist bis heute unklar, aber die US-Regierung erklärte bei der Terror-Einstufung explizit, dass damit ein Ausschluss vom US-Finanzsystem verbunden ist. Und sie setzte die Gruppe auf eine Sanktionsliste, die auch Banken zu beachten haben. Das bedeutet dann, dass Konten in Deutschland denen gekündigt werden, weil die dann auch sich an diese Sanktionen halten, weil diese Banken wiederum verflochten sind mit der USA. Hier in dem Tatsartikel heißt es auch, die deutsche kommunistische Partei DKP machte gerade erst publik, dass ihr Parteikonto bei der GLS zum Jahresende gekündigt wurde. Auch hier mit Verweis auf die allgemeinen Geschäftsbedingungen und ohne weitere Angabe von Gründen. Die Partei vermutet als Grund ihre Spendenaktion für Kuba.
Also die GLS-Bank kenne ich überhaupt nur, weil sehr viele in der Podcastlandschaft, ich auch, auf höherer Druck als es immer hieß. Nee, du hast bei der Commerzbank, das ist doch ganz böse, du musst zu dieser ganz guten Bank gehen, GLS. Dann haben sich alle das angeschaut, das kostet 60 Euro im Jahr, warum eigentlich? Ja, weil das voll gut ist und dann ist das hier und überhaupt.
Transparenz und ökologisch und investieren nicht in Rüstungsdinger. Das wird so sein.
Von daher, ich bin wirklich richtig wütend auf solche scheiß Organisationen wie diese GLS-Bank.
Das passiert nämlich jetzt. Wir kommen auf GLS gleich nochmal zu sprechen. Das ist übrigens nicht nur GLS, sondern es sind eben dann auch zum Teil Sparkassen dabei. Wir bleiben jetzt, wir werden nicht nur von links jetzt da drauf bringen. Wir gucken uns jetzt das gesamte Spektrum an. Also diese Thematik alle canceln. Alle will ich auch wirklich vorführen, was das bedeutet. Wir bleiben erst nochmal bei den USA. Hate Aid, das ist diese Organisation, die Hass im Netz juristisch zum Teil verfolgt. Ich bin zugegebenermaßen nicht Riesenfan dieses Vereins, weil ich ja immer mit dieser Pranger-Sache mein Problem habe, weil das auch in meinen Augen Tür und Tor öffnet für die, die jetzt Geld verdienen wollen, damit dass sie irgendwie von Hass im Netz sich, wir haben das bei den Politikern ja schon durchdekliniert haben, dass dann die laufend jetzt Leute abmahnen, die beleidigen.
Aber wir haben es hier nicht mit einem Abmahnmaschenverein zu tun, der Politiker aktiv anspricht, und sich nicht mal gegen diese und jene Beleidigungen vorbeigeholt.
Gibt's ja auch. Also dazu würde ich jetzt Hate-Aid nicht zählen, aber ich bin generell glaube ich, dass das auch nicht fördernd für die Meinungsfreiheit ist. Ich sehe da durchaus Probleme, was manche Angriffe anbelangt, aber würde selbst nicht darauf zurückgreifen wollen. Aber trotzdem skandalös ist, was man mit Hate-Aid jetzt tut, nämlich auch wieder von Seiten der USA.
Normalerweise verhängt Washington Einreiseverbote gegen Diktatoren oder Kriminelle. Diesmal trifft es zwei deutsche Aktivistinnen, die sich gegen Hass im Netz einsetzen. Der Vorwurf, sie seien Teil eines Netzwerks, das versucht, amerikanische Plattformen zu zensieren. Gemeint ist der Digital Service Act ein EU-Gesetz, das illegale Inhalte im Netz verpflichtend löschen lässt. Die deutsche NGO Hate Aid unterstützt die Umsetzung. Für die USA ist das ein Dorn im Auge, denn jegliche Regulierung wird als Eingriff in die Meinungsfreiheit verstanden. Der Außenminister Marco Rubio schreibt online, Viel zu lange haben Ideologen in Europa organisierte Bemühungen unternommen, um amerikanische Plattformen dazu zu zwingen, amerikanische Standpunkte zu bestrafen, die ihnen nicht gefallen. Die Trump-Regierung wird diese ungeheuerlichen Akte extraterritorialer Zensur nicht länger tolerieren. Hate Aid reagiert empört und spricht von politischer Repression. Außenminister Johann Wadepfuhl weist die Sanktionen zurück. Auf X schreibt er, die durch die USA verhängten Einreiseverbote, darunter gegen die Vorsitzenden von Hate Aid, sind nicht akzeptabel. Der Digital Service Edge stellt sicher, dass alles, was offline illegal ist, auch online illegal ist. Auch Justizministerin Hubech stellt klar, Hate Aid schütze Persönlichkeitsrechte. Wer das als Zensur darstellt, verkennt die Grundlagen des Rechtsstaats.
Ja, dass jetzt einfach alle ihre Appelle kurz machen, dann noch bei X, ist ja wirklich total bescheuert.
Was wir hieran aber merken, ist, es geht gar nicht um diesen Verein konkret, sondern man ist gegen die EU und ihren Digital Service Act versucht jetzt erst mal über diese Schiene, indem man diese Vereine, die da so lose dranhängen, mehr ist das ja nicht, zu sanktionieren, was dann wiederum dazu führen soll, dass die EU sich künftig zurückhält mit irgendwelchen Regulierungen, die die Macht des Silicon Valley in irgendeiner Weise begrenzen könnte. Das ist eigentlich der große politische Skandal noch mal darin. Nicht nur, dass man jetzt dort einzelne Akteurinnen von dem Verein nicht mehr einreisen lässt oder so, sondern es geht ja auch eine ganz andere Art von Macht ausübung.
Ich finde ja, das ist ein Angriff auf Europa und unsere Werte und Lebensweisen. Und ich fordere eigentlich eine Wehrpflicht. Also ich finde, unsere Politiker haben jetzt die Pflicht, Deutschland zu verteidigen.
Tja, passiert relativ wenig. Werden wir jetzt auch gleich noch sehen. Aber springen wir mal auf die andere Seite des politischen Spektrums. Flavio von Witzleben, das ist auch so ein YouTuber, der unter anderem dieses Gespräch führte mit Höcke und Girol, das wir hier mal gespielt hatten. Der jetzt bei der Jungen Freiheit, also der Rechten Zeitung, zu Gast ist. Und auch der hat ein Canceln erlebt, beziehungsweise die Banking spielt auch da eine Rolle.
Warum hat die Sparkasse Karlsruhe ihnen das Konto gekündigt?
Wenn ich das wüsste, das Ganze geschah ohne Angabe von Gründen. Ich hatte dort schon sehr lange mein Konto. Schon als junger Mann habe ich dort mein Konto eröffnet und das wurde dann irgendwann umgewandelt in ein Geschäftskonto. Und ja, jetzt kam Ende Oktober, kam dann die Kündigung bei mir ins Haus. Und dann bin ich da zunächst dagegen vorgegangen mit meinem Anwalt. Die Sparkasse hat die Kündigung aber weiterhin aufrechterhalten. Und somit gehen wir jetzt direkt über ins Hauptsacheverfahren, haben die Sparkasse verklagt und werden jetzt mal sehen, wie sich das Ganze weiterentwickelt.
Ist es nicht so, dass Sparkassen eigentlich nicht direkt unmittelbar einfach kündigen dürfen, sondern eher nur die Privatbanken?
Ja, genau.
Ich kann das ja nicht beurteilen, was da in einzelnen Fällen ist. Man hört ja auch von den Statements aus.
Es ist ja gut, dass es jetzt mal prozessiert wird.
Die Sache ist natürlich jetzt, er hat offenbar die Möglichkeiten, da zu prozessieren. Das ist natürlich anderen gar nicht so einfach möglich.
Das unterstellt man denen immer so, dass irgendwelche Leute immer so mega, ne, das wird auch für ihn eine heikle Sache sein.
Ja, das wird für ihn eine heikle Sache sein. Nur kann er überhaupt was machen. Ich glaube, dass für so kleinere Vereine, denen das passiert, wo gar kein Kapital im Hintergrund ist, noch mal schwieriger ist, dagegen vorzugehen.
Naja, in dem Falle hat man wirklich am besten Öffentlichkeit, Solidartöpfe und so.
Wenn man sie herstellen kann, die Öffentlichkeit. Wir werden gleich ein Beispiel bringen, wo ich sage, die haben jetzt keine Öffentlichkeit. Die werden jetzt wahrscheinlich, also ich kannte die auch vorher nicht, die werden jetzt hier einmal von einem größeren Publikum überhaupt gehört, dass es die gibt. Und da gibt es eben sehr viele Fälle, die man auch jetzt abbilden könnte. Was ich nur sehe ist hier, irgendwas politisches wird ja im Allgemeinen drin stecken. Bei dem Einzelfall wissen wir das jetzt nicht. Keine Ahnung, warum die Sparkasse, wo war das jetzt? Ich glaube Karlsruhe oder was sich so entschieden hat. Das können wir auch von hier nicht bewerten. Wir wollen ja auch nicht spekulieren, mutmaßen. Nur, was wir ja offenbar sehen in den letzten Wochen, Monaten ist, dass dieses Debanking passiert und dass dabei häufig Rechte oder Linke vorkommen, die davon betroffen sind. Also es werden in der Regel nicht Leute aus der Mitte sanktioniert. Und ich habe ein bisschen den Verdacht, dass wir jetzt so unter dem Slogan der wehrhaften Demokratie gerade so eine Verengung des Meinungskorridors haben im Sinne von, naja ich kann dich auch anders zensieren, indem ich dir einfach die Kanäle, die du benötigst, entziehe. Und das sehe ich als eine ganz große Gefahr an. Also da bin ich auch gespannt, ob da mal vom Chaos Computer Club was in diese Richtung kommt. Ich hörte jetzt, dass die sich wohl bei so einigen Linken-Gruppierungen, die ihr GLS-Konto oder ein anderes Konto gesperrt bekommen haben, dass sie wohl sich dazu auch noch mit einem Statement äußern wollen. Aber das ist eine Gemengelage, in die wir uns jetzt, glaub ich, immer mehr einfinden werden, dass man jetzt sieht, was wir auf einer internationalen Ebene schon länger gemacht haben, dass man jetzt sagt, brauchen wir eigentlich dieses Swift-Verfahren als einen neutralen Akteur oder sollte man das nicht auch politisieren und sagen, die nicht mehr drin und die nicht mehr und die nicht mehr, dass das jetzt auch so flächendeckend stattfinden kann, was eigentlich den Status noch prekärer macht für alle im Prinzip, weil alle jederzeit betroffen werden könnten. Also ich sehe da keine Verbesserung drin und deswegen würde ich auch hier als mein Appell mal sagen, man sollte sich von links nicht so sehr freuen, wenn da von rechts irgendwas verboten wird, wenn da was passiert, wenn da De-Banking stattfindet. Das hat man nämlich auch immer wieder dann gelesen, ja ja, den geschieht es aber auch ganz recht, weil das immer auch umschlagen kann, dann in die andere Seite und irgendwann sagt man dann ja, dann bitte nur noch die Mitte und das und das und das nicht mehr. Deswegen müsste man ja sich nicht solidarisch erklären, das meine ich jetzt nicht, aber dass man es als ein gemeinsames Thema ansieht, dass das eine ganz, ganz große Herausforderung wird, weil dann werden ja viele Dinge nicht mehr möglich sein, wenn das weiter Einzug hält. Hier ein Beispiel vom Verein Anarchist Black Cross Dresden, also die eine anarchistische Gruppierung sind. Die waren beim Freien Radio Dreieckland zu Gast. Da ist eine Sprecherin Nina von diesem Verein und die berichtet auch von Die Banking.
Was ist Mitte November konkret passiert, als das Konto gekündigt wurde?
Wir haben sozusagen als Gruppe kein eigenes Konto mit diesem Namen. Also es gibt kein ABC-Konto, sondern wie du schon richtig gesagt hast, arbeiten wir mit einem Verein seit Jahren eng zusammen, über dessen konnten gemeinsam Spenden gesammelt werden. Und eben genau dieses Konto wurde gekündigt. Und die haben erzählt, es war einfach so, dass sie sozusagen dann versucht, sich ganz normal einzulocken beim Online-Banking. Und es ging dann nicht. Und dann haben sie bei der Hotline angerufen und dann wurde mitgeteilt, dass es sich quasi ein technisches Problem handelt und mit der Fachabteilung gesprochen werden müsste, beziehungsweise die Fachabteilung würde zurückrufen. Das ist dann nicht passiert. Und dann haben sie quasi ein paar Tage später dann noch mal angerufen und ein bisschen mehr Nachdruck erzeugt. Und dann wurde so ein dringender Rückruf eingestellt. Und dann hat tatsächlich wer von dieser Fachabteilung angerufen. Und die haben dann behauptet, dass eben diese Beziehung noch mal evaluiert werden wäre und dass es nicht mehr tragbar sei, mit dem Verein zusammenzuarbeiten. Und das war dann eigentlich auch alles. Also es wurde fristlos gekündigt. Es gab auch keine Zeit, das Geld noch mal zu überweisen. Oder irgendwie, genau. Also das war dann das.
Enteignet wurde man auch noch, oder was?
Ja, er fragt jetzt auch nach.
Ganz lebenspraktisch, was ist mit dem Geld?
Genau, das liegt da noch.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Also ich packte heute noch mein ganzes Geld in Bitcoin.
Ja, also ich meine, ich meine, das ist ja die logische Konsequenz davon. Das ist ja das Schlimme.
Ich mach Gold.
Das ist ja das Schlimme. Wenn das jetzt immer weiter einzukällt und man das so politisiert und sie beißt auch jetzt auf die politischen Bedingungen da mal hin. Wir sind da in Sachsen, was da noch so kommen könnte. Man könnte sich ja auch vorstellen, wenn da noch andere Kräfte wirken, aber schon jetzt funktioniert das so. Ich würde auch sagen, wenn man diese Politisierung der Banken jetzt vornimmt, dann haben wir ständig irgendwelche Fälle, wo eine eher linke Regierung, links-siberale Regierung sagt, jetzt verbietet man denen den Rechten da. Der hat aber das und das in seinem YouTube-Kanal gesagt und die anderen kommen dann aus Sachsen, sagen, er verbietet mal die, die haben das und das gemacht. Die sind nämlich viel zu links, die sind ja linksextrem. Dann geht das nur so.
Aber könnte die Wahl natürlich ein bisschen vitalisieren, wenn man vom Wahlergebnis ablesen kann, ob man morgen noch ein Konto hat. Jaja, das muss man sich vorstellen.
Das ist wirklich dramatisch in meinen Augen.
Sagt ihr in eurem Statement auf eurer Webseite, dass das kein Einzelfall sei und wenn man euren Fall ja mit anderen zusammendenkt, etwa dem der Kontokündung, Kündigung der DKP, welches Muster wird da aus eurer Sicht erkennbar?
Na, das sind jetzt sozusagen ja die aktuellen Fälle, wie wir sie gerade genannt haben, aber es gibt auch noch mehr und es gab auch in der Kriminalisierung sozusagen schon vorher Fälle. Ich denke, daran erkennt man mehrere Muster. Zunächst einmal haben wir natürlich hier in Sachsen so einen sehr klaren Kriminalisierungsversuch durch die CDU-Regierung gegenüber linken, antifaschistischen, anarchistischen Strukturen. Also hier in Sachsen passiert das eigentlich seit Jahren, vor allem auch nochmal verstärkt in den letzten Jahren. Bei unserer Gruppe begann das so vor drei Jahren mit der großen Solidaritätskampagne für die Ukraine oder mittlerweile vier Jahren. In dem Zusammenhang wurden wir als linksextrem eingestuft, weil wir versuchen, Anarchismus in der Ukraine zu etablieren, laut dem VS. Und bei anderen Gruppen begann das eben schon früher teilweise mit dieser Einstufung als linksextrem oder vor allem verstärkt in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, das ist sehr gut. Während im Deutschlandfunk darüber gesprochen wurde, dass Friedrich Merz mal Taurus versprochen hat und dann leider doch nicht lief, das muss man jetzt sich erstmal erklären und so, hat die CDU Sachsen schon alle Ukraine-Unterstützung weggekanzelt.
Ja, die Anarchistische, das darf es natürlich nicht geben. Deswegen sollen die das dann nicht mehr weiter haben. Kennst du Jacques Beau?
Nein.
Ich kannte ihn auch nicht. Ist jemand, der sehr viel in der Weltwoche vorkommt, also auch rechte Schweiz sagen wir mal.
Ich habe ja mit der Schweiz nicht so viel zu tun als Deutscher. Das ist ja mehr so ein kleines Land, wo man mal zum Urlaub hin fährt. Jetzt sagst du wieder, wir haben Schweizer Zuhörer.
Ja, kreiert sie miteinander. Jacques Beau ist jemand, der auch bei West End Bücher schreibt. Und was der jetzt gerade erledigt, fand ich...
Also der gehört aus dieser Weltwochen-Ecke?
Nein, der ist eigentlich Diplomat. Wir hören jetzt gleich, was er schon alles gemacht hat. Also ist ein 1000-Sasser. Und der erlebt jetzt gerade Sanktionen durch die EU. Und ich war total verblüfft. Wir hören jetzt aber keinen Beitrag aus der Weltwoche, sondern vom Schweizer Fernsehen SRF.
Der Krieg von Russland gegen die Ukraine zeigt sich auch in Form von Cyberangriffen, Propaganda und Desinformation im restlichen Europa und in der Schweiz. In diesem Zusammenhang hat die EU vor einer Woche den pensionierten Schweizer Oberst Jacques Bo auf eine Sanktionsliste gesetzt. Sie wirft ihm unter anderem vor, pro-russische Propaganda zu verbreiten. Für den Sanktionierten hat das gravierende Konsequenzen. Daniel Klaus und Georg Halter berichten.
Jacques Bo, früher Oberst der Schweizer Armee, ehemaliger Mitarbeiter des Schweizer Nachrichtendienstes und später tätig für UNO und NATO. Heute ist er Buchautor und rechtfertigt wiederholt den Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine. Zum Beispiel sagt er, Russland habe im Februar 2022 den Angriff gestartet, weil die Ukraine habe angreifen wollen.
Seit März 2021 hat sich Ukraine vorbereitet, um militärisch die Krim und Donbass wieder durch Kampf, durch Krieg zu nehmen.
Um das ganz kurz zu sagen, das ist nicht meine Auffassung, aber ich sehe nicht, warum das nicht gesagt werden darf. Also da muss ich einfach sagen, in dem kann man ja widersprechen, aber...
Wir haben nicht lange gesagt, als würde die Ukraine auch für ihr eigenes Gebiet angreifen.
Naja, die würden da was zurückerobern. Also er sagt, die haben das provoziert oder so. Das ist ja nicht eine Haltung, die man teilen muss, und die teile ich auch gar nicht. Aber ich verstehe nicht, warum man dann solche Sanktionen da hat.
Vor einer Woche setzt die EU Jacques Beau auf eine Sanktionsliste und begründet, er fungiert als Sprachrohr für prorussische Propaganda und verbreitet Verschwörungstheorien, indem er beispielsweise die Ukraine beschuldigt, ihre eigene Invasion inszeniert zu haben, um der NATO beitreten zu können. Für Beau bedeutet die Sanktionierung, er darf in der EU nicht mehr reisen und sein Vermögen ist blockiert. SVP-Außenpolitiker Franz Grüther zeigt sich schockiert.
Das ist ein undemokratisches Vorgehen und was mich am meisten stört, ist, dass diese betroffenen Personen nicht mal rechtliches Gehör bekommen. Das heisst, sie können sich eigentlich gar nicht wehren gegen diese willkürlichen Sanktionen.
Beau kündigt heute gegenüber der Agentur Keystone-SDA an, er werde die Sanktionierung anfechten und sei enttäuscht von der Unterstützung der offiziellen Schweiz.
Das EDA hat Herrn Beau kontaktiert und ihm Unterstützung im Rahmen des möglichen Angebots. Zudem haben wir heute bei den zuständigen EU-Behörden mehr Informationen über die Hintergründe und die Konsequenzen ihres Entscheides verlangt.
Der Fall Beau wirft die Frage auf, wo das Grundrecht der Meinungsfreiheit aufhört, wann eine Einschränkung legitim ist.
Aus Sicht der Meinungsfreiheit dürfen Behörden Meinungen nicht einfach deshalb einschränken, weil sie ihnen nicht passen oder weil sie ihnen zutiefst zuwider sind, sondern erforderlich ist, dass eine Meinungsäußerung Dritte zu Handlungen aufruft, die dann ganz konkret sich in schwerwiegenden Verletzungen hochwertiger Rechtsgüter niederschlagen, wie beispielsweise Leib und Leben.
Ob diese hohe Voraussetzung im Fall Beau tatsächlich erfüllt ist, eine Antwort werden die Gerichte geben müssen.
Die EU braucht 19 Sanktionspakete, um immer noch nicht die Öllieferung darunter. Und die Oligarchen verdienen weiter prächtig und so. Und in der Schweiz wird so jemand, der eine Meinung hat, gekanzelt. Also das ist ja irgendwie...
Ich finde es absurd. Also wenn man ihm glauben darf, ich habe da noch das eine oder andere Interview mir durchgelesen, dann sagt er auch, dass er auch nie in russischen Medien aufgetreten ist jetzt während des Krieges. Sondern es kann sein, dass die schon mal Interviewmaterial, das irgendwo im Netz steht, verwendet haben. Ich kann das nicht nachprüfen, ob das alles so ist. Was ich aber doch sagen kann, ist, dass das, was hier vorgetragen wird, zu kritisieren ist, aber ja nicht in irgendeiner Weise sanktioniert werden muss. Wo man einfach sagen kann, nee, diese Meinung muss ja möglich sein. Beziehungsweise, was macht man eigentlich mit denen, die beispielsweise steif und fest behauptet haben, dass Nord Stream 2 von Russland gesprengt wurde. Also das war auch falsch. So sanktioniert man die jetzt auch in diese Richtung wieder anders. Also ich halte das für wirklich fatal. Was ich aber glaube, was hier sehr drin steckt, und das sollte wirklich die Schweizer auch ein bisschen irritieren, auch wenn sie politisch wo ganz anders sind, auch nicht mit der SVP sozialisiert werden wollen und nicht mit der Weltwoche assoziiert werden wollen, dass hier die EU eigentlich der Schweiz sagt, also mit eurer Neutralität, wie ihr da so glaubt, ihr könnt hier was eigenes machen, das werden wir euch schon noch austreiben. Wir geben hier den Ton an. Also ich finde, das ist ein Machtgebaren auch der EU gegenüber der Schweiz, die sich da unterwerfen soll. Ich halte das für...
Sowieso, diese Vertragsverhandlungen über die Assoziation Europa und der Schweiz gehen ja regelmäßig schief.
Ja.
Peter Altmaier hat sie gequält bis...
Ja, und ich glaube, das ist wirklich ein Druckmittel, das man jetzt gerade wieder hier hat, dass man da Unruhe stiftet. Ich finde das wirklich besorgniserregend, auch wenn wir die Einzelfälle nicht durchschauen können jetzt. Das ist aber auch in der Struktur so angelegt. Also wenn die natürlich nur nebulös verkünden, verbreitet pro russische Narrative, naja, das ist ja auch so alles und nichts, wie wir ja wissen. Das kann vieles sein. Kommen wir aber jetzt noch zum krassesten Fall. Also wir bilden wirklich das Gesamtspektrum heute ab. Der Fall Nikola Giyu, Giyu. Giyu ist Richter am internationalen Strafgerichtshof und der erlebt eine Vollsanktionierung in einem Maße, wie die Tagesschau uns das hier mal kurz versucht zu vermitteln.
Er hier kann sich online quasi nichts mehr kaufen oder bestellen, weil er von den USA bestraft wird. Das ist Nikola Giyu. Er ist Richter am internationalen Strafgerichtshof und hat da was mitentschieden, was die Regierung von US-Präsident Trump ziemlich sauer gemacht hat. Die hat Giyu und mehrere seiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen auf eine Sanktionsliste gesetzt. Auf der landen eigentlich Menschen wie Terroristen oder autoritäre Staats- und Regierungschefs. Okay, aber warum sind Giyu und seine Kolleginnen und Kollegen da jetzt auch drauf? Weil sie Haftbefehle gegen den israelischen Premierminister Netanyahu und den ehemaligen Verteidigungsminister Galant erlassen haben. Die Anklage wirft den beiden Kriegsverbrechen und Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit vor, wegen ihres Vorgehens im Gaza-Krieg mit zehntausenden Toten. Die USA verurteilen die Entscheidung des Gerichts und reagieren mit den Sanktionen. Die Folgen, für Richter GU und seine Kolleginnen und Kollegen, sämtliche Konten, z.B. bei Amazon, Airbnb und PayPal, wurden geschlossen, sagt er. Und auch Kreditkarten von US-Unternehmen funktionieren nicht mehr. Selbst Banken außerhalb der USA schließen Konten von Sanktionierten wie GU vorsichtshalber. Dadurch wird er faktisch von großen Teilen des weltweiten Bankensystems ausgeschlossen.
Naja, die Banken machen es ja nicht vorsichtshalber, sondern die Banken müssen es halt machen, auch wenn sie keine amerikanischen Banken sind, um ihr Amerika-Geschäft zu behalten, das nun mal jede Bank hat. Von daher, das ist so dramatisch. Das ist im Grunde die Negativseite von 60 Jahren Globalisierung. Wir werden alle davon profitieren, dass wir eine Welt sind. Die Welt ist ein Dorf.
Der lebt jetzt in den 80er Jahren. Also der kann nichts bei Amazon bestellen, der kann keine Kreditkarte benutzen, der kann nicht mit dem Uber fahren. Da geht nichts mehr. Es geht einfach nichts mehr. Kein Paypal, nichts.
Aber seine Kollegen sind es auch, das betrifft ja nicht nur ihn.
Es gibt einen sehr guten Artikel dazu beim Verfassungsblock von Kai Ambos. Der schreibt hier auch nochmal ganz klar, es geht der USA ausschließlich um den Schutz eigener und befreundeter, in Klammern israelischer Staatsangehöriger, nicht um die Verfahren oder die Tatvorwürfe an sich, solange diese sich gegen Gegner und Feinde der USA, in Klammern Taliban oder Israels, in Klammern Hamas, richten, hat die US-Regierung kein Problem mit dem angeblichen Overreach des Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs. Wenn aber gegen die USA oder deren Freunde das Recht durchgesetzt werden soll, wird der Gerichtshof selbst zum Feind. Diese Doppelstandards sind nicht neu, sie lassen sich aktuell auch im sogenannten Drogenkrieg beobachten, während die Trump-Regierung angebliche Narco-Terroristen in der Karibik außergerichtlich hinrichtet zu evidenten Völkerrechtswidrigkeit, gibt es auch einen Artikel, begnadigt sie gleichzeitig den ehemaligen Präsidenten von Honduras, der zuvor in den USA in einem rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren zu 45 Jahren Freiheitsstrafe unter anderem wegen Drogenhandels verurteilt wurde. Die EU könnte hier sich mit Amerika anlegen. Hier werden die Möglichkeiten aufgetan. Da gibt es also eine Blocking-Verordnung aus dem Jahr 1996. Mit der könnte man dafür sorgen, dass EU-Personen nicht von diesen Sanktionen betroffen sind. Es schreibt hier noch eine Wegweisenentscheidung aus dem Dezember 2021. Da geht es darum, das bestätigt vom EuGH, in Übereinstimmung mit den Erwägungsgründen der Verordnung, dass die extraterritoriale Wirkung der US-Sanktionen die Interessen der Union und der bezeichneten Personen beeinträchtigt, indem sie das Völkerrecht verletzen und die Verwirklichung der Ziele der Union-Förderung des freien Handels behindern. Das Verbot, solchen Aktionen nachzukommen, gelte auch dann, wenn seitens der Verwaltungs- und Justizbehörden der Drittländer, die diese Gesetze erlassen haben, keine Weisung zu deren Einhaltung vorliegt. Das heißt also, man könnte auch über diesen Weg gehen. Aber, schreibt dann Amboss, bisher hat sich die EU allerdings noch nicht zu einer solchen formalen Reaktion durchringen können. Nicht nur wegen der rechtlichen und wirtschaftlichen Problematik, sondern wohl auch, weil man fürchtet, dass die US-Regierung dann den Gerichtshof als Ganzes sanktionieren könnte. Einerseits ist diese Befürchtung, wie eingangs gesagt, durchaus berechtigt. Und wenn sie eintritt, stünde die Existenz des Gerichtshofs auf dem Spiel. Andererseits aber können nur verbale Proteste und Solidaritätserklärungen die Wirkung der Sanktionen praktisch nicht abmeldern. Mit anderen Worten, es herrscht hier das Recht des Stärkeren, mit dem das einfach jetzt gemacht wird. Und das ist ein ganz großes Problem. Und deswegen glaube ich auch, was diese anderen Fälle jetzt anbelangt, also jetzt bei Hate Aid, wo da die US-Sanktionen kommen, wenn man das wirklich plausibel kritisieren will, da muss man aber tatsächlich jetzt auch unter Beweis stellen, dass in Europa die Meinungsfreiheit großgeschrieben wird. Das ist dann nicht diese Sanktionen gegen Schweizer Publizisten oder gegen irgendwelche YouTuber oder irgendwelche Vereine gibt mit De-Banking und all das. Dann muss man wirklich sehen, dass man sich einmal anlegt wirklich mit dieser US-Einmischung in europäische Innerlichkeiten. Und man muss aber dann auch wirklich auf europäischem Boden diese Meinungsfreiheit großschreiben. Und das findet dann auch gerade nicht statt. Also das ist alles in allem eine sehr, sehr düstere Aussicht, die wir da immer weiter, glaube ich, hineinschlittern. Dass man sagen kann, ja bald cancelten jeder jeden.
Ich finde, wir sollten jetzt Trump eh auch mal ein bisschen, ich verstehe das nicht, dieses Devote-Verhältnis da irgendwie. Das ist so crazy. Ich meine, das ist einfach so die ganze, also als George W. Bush regiert hat, war irgendwie klar, okay, jetzt zieht gerade das industrielle Ölförderkonstrukt ins Weiße Haus ein und übernimmt einmal den Staat und dann dachten alle so, naja, die vier Jahre halten wir es aus, dann haben wir jetzt irgendwie acht und so. Aber dass dasselbe Prinzip jetzt mit dieser industriellen Pädophilie einfach genauso akzeptiert wird von Europa, ja ist halt so, der mag halt jetzt Polen lieber als wir, er hat die Pommes jetzt French Fries oder so, keine Ahnung, Freedom Fries genannt, ja. Dass es so weggespielt wird und man immer wieder so ein, ja morgen ist ja dieser wichtige Termin von Zelensky im Weißen Haus, wir hoffen, dass danach Trump noch mal ins Telefon geht an Deutschlandfunk, ja. Große Freude darüber, dass ja bei Trump, bei Merz ist er ins Telefon gegangen, bei Macron nicht. Punkt Sieg Deutschland. Dein Bundeskanzler heißt Friedrich Merz, du weißt es, du magst ihn. Nein, nein. Wir kriegen jetzt hier Aufklärung über die Bilanz. Ein Jahr Merz. Robin Alexander greift ein Thema heraus, das uns alle beschäftigt. Wie steht es um die Nähe von Friedrich Merz zur AfD, wo wir doch alle wissen, der Jens Spahn würde sofort und überhaupt und so. Und in dieser Deutschlandfunk, nee, bei Apokalypse und Filtercafé, man ist ja überall eingeladen, redet Robin Alexander mal über Friedrich Merz.
Kommen wir doch nochmal zu den vermeintlich geheimen Absichten von Jens Spahn. Wenn sie einen erkennt, dann ja sicher du, Robin. Ist das, was ihm da unterstellt wird? Er liebäugelt da mit einem anderen Modell, vielleicht mit einer Minderheitenregion, mit einer mehr oder weniger offiziellen Kooperation mit der AfD. Ist da irgendwas dran?
Also, wenn es einer weiß, dann Robin Alexander.
Diese Minderheitsidee wird an die Union herangetragen, aus der Publizistik, von Feuilletonisten und von Leuten aus den Unternehmerverbänden, die sozusagen frustriert sind. In der Fraktion und schon gar bei den führenden Leuten gibt es das eigentlich nicht.
Genau.
Dann schließen wir wieder an. Ja, muss ja auch nicht. Solange die CDU-AfD-Politik macht, ist ja alles gut für die AfD. Und Robin Alexander versucht jetzt mit einem schlagenden Argument.
Weil das auch ein Wahnsinn ist. Also jetzt mal systemtheoretisch mit Niklas Luhmann gefragt, für welches Problem der Union soll die AfD die Lösung sein?
Ja, das macht systemtheoretisch und Niklas Luhmann wird es nie so fragen.
Ich wollte auch gerade wissen, wo das bei Niklas Luhmann so gefragt wird.
Das ist immer, wenn man politischer Berichterstatter ist, sieht man ausschließlich Protagonisten. Und man kennt alle ihren Namen. Wenn man Systemtheoretiker ist, sieht man keine Protagonisten. Vielleicht mal eine Person, interessanter Voraussatz, die Form Person, wie sich die Person halt ergibt, in kommunikativen Zusammenhängen. Von daher lassen wir das mal. Das ist absurd sozusagen. Aber Dieter Breymann, den wir auf Instagram bestimmt alle folgen, ich kenne ihn nicht näher, ich sehe nur seine Videos und sie werden mir besonders häufig immer zugespielt, der hat sich hier kurz geäußert zu diesem Vereins...
Du musst sagen, wer das ist.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wer das ist.
Also das ist ein CDU-Politiker, ohne aber ein großes Amt zu haben aus, ich glaube NRW, der auch ja so im Kulturbereich wohl, aber auch Landesebene, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ich glaube Mönchengladbach sind wir jetzt hier. Er ist jemand, der auch schon einige Artikel gewidmet bekommen hat, weil er sich für die CDU einsetzt in sozialen Medien, sozusagen als der CDU-Opa. Allerdings ein Kritiker von Lerz ist und vielleicht ja so ein bisschen ruckrechtpolens mäßig so in dieser Liga spielt. Auch politisch, also die, sagen wir, die Mitte CDU vertritt. Es hatte sich ja jetzt auch vor ein paar Wochen dieser Verein gegründet, innerhalb der CDU, der sagt, na ja, aber wir wollen schon nicht nur diesen völkischen Populismus jetzt bei uns breit haben, sondern wir wollen eigentlich auch sagen, ja, wir sind doch ein Einwanderungsland und wir haben doch auch das Soziale und all das. Also es rumort ja in der CDU etwas, weil es ja doch in diesem eher bürgerlich liberaleren oder sozialen katholischen Lager, also sehr stark NRW, CDU, Wüst und Co. Oder auch noch ein Daniel Günther natürlich, dass es da so andere Stimmen gibt und er zählt so zu diesen. Also er ist gerade kein Scharfmacher, sondern jemand, der Merz kritisiert, aber jetzt auch was interessantes hinweist mit Blick auf, wo steht Merz und wo steht er zur AfD.
Er hatte das mitzuteilen, fängt aber erst mal eine Minute an über diesen Wendepunkt Deutschland-Verein zu reden. Also Turning Point USA, Wendepunkt Deutschland. Die Kreativität ist jetzt auch nicht so immens.
Der wurde gegründet von?
Also AfD und CDU-Leuten da mit einem junger Unionsvize-Chef irgendwas, der dann plötzlich da Vorsitzender ist und sowas. Das ist immer ganz wichtig. Konservative Vereine sind immer daran zu erkennen, dass es sofort einen Vorsitzenden gibt, während die linken Vereine dazu tendieren, dass man sie erst erfinden muss, um sie überhaupt, um ihnen habhaft zu werden.
Hallo zusammen. Zwei Dinge, die mich beschäftigen, heute am Tag vor Heiligabend. Das eine ist, es gibt einen Verein, der wurde gegründet in Köln, der Wendepunkt Deutschland. Und in dem arbeiten JU, AfD und angeblich auch SPD-Mitglieder zusammen. Derjenige aus der jungen Union, der doch der Vorstand sitzt, soll jetzt aus der Partei ausgeschlossen werden. Das hat zumindest die Kölner Kreisvorsitzende Serap Güler so angekündigt. Allerdings braucht man dafür erst den Beschluss. Das Kreisvorstand ist, der soll im Januar kommen. Auch die SPD will...
Das ist übrigens so Instagram-Wissen. Typischerweise macht Robin Alexander immer. Jetzt müssen wir ins Detail gehen. Hier, wer ist der Kreisvorsitzende? Wer hat da welche? Und so weiter. Und ich glaube, jetzt, wo es immer so ins Kleinglange geht, wer hat mit welcher Bank, wem weggekanzelt und so weiter, wird das Grund-Tenor bei Instagram sein, dass wir das so spezial wissen.
Sich mit dieser Thematik beschäftigen. Das Zweite finde ich viel spannender im Prinzip, weil es passt in Informationen, die ich gestern erhalten habe. Die Zeit, in der Zeit steht eine Kolumne darüber, dass Friedrich Merz auch... Offensichtlich von Neurechtstum Deutschland in der klugen Version, sprich von den Medien. Das sind vor allen Dingen Springer, News und Apollo und wie sie alle heißen.
Das ist das Phänomen, das du ja auch schon besprochen hast. Ja. Plötzlich weht der Wind anders und man beschimpft Friedrich Merz persönlich beleidigend.
Ja, also wir hatten ja diese Clips von News und da war ja der von Apollo zu Gast, weil die Hartmann saß auch noch da. Und sie bezichtigen eigentlich Merz permanent ein Lügner zu sein. Und das bleibt offenbar ohne Konsequenzen. Aber was man da ja vor allem sehen kann, sie haben sich ja besonders eingeschossen auf Wolfram Weimer. Und wir haben ja hier, als Wolfram Weimer bestimmt wurde von Merz, gesessen und sagte, oh Gott, jetzt ist der Rechtsdruck aber wirklich vollzogen. Denn wir gucken uns dieses Pamphlet von Weimer an und wissen, wo der Politische steht. Aber für die Rechten ist er gar nicht rechts genug.
Ja, oder die wissen halt, dass er nichts geregelt kriegt.
Oder das, ja.
Zum Abschuss freigegeben ist. Das kann verschiedene Gründe haben. Die Gerüchte, die ich gehört habe, das sind wirklich nur Gerüchte, sind, dass es wohl ein Treffen gegeben habe mit Friedrich Merz, wo man ihn aufgefordert hat, doch jetzt mal langsam die Türen zur AfD zu öffnen und er dieses Gespräch verlassen hat. Danach habe man ihm gedroht. Und das passt eigentlich zu der Berichterstattung. Wir sollten also immer folgendes bedenken. Auch die, die Friedrich Merz nicht mögen, kritisch sehen. Ich gehöre dazu, zu denen, die ihn kritisch sehen. Er ist ein Bollwerk gegen die AfD. Das darf man nie vergessen. Wirklich nicht. Wenn wir uns selber einen Gefallen tun wollen. Tschüss zusammen.
Ja. Also in diesen Themen würde ich ungern einsteigen. Friedrich Merz ist abzuschießen. Und zwar aus den richtigen Gründen. Und danach ist auch eine Wahl zu machen. Ich weiß, dass jetzt und so. Dann bin ich lieber Axeläterist und sage, okay, dann sind halt die Nazis zurück. Wir sagen der ganzen Welt Bescheid. Alle Europäer sagen auch, wow, Meloni und so, die sind ja eh anders drauf.
Jetzt mach doch mal langsam.
Die AfD ist wirklich hart.
Jetzt mach doch mal langsam. Also wir haben jetzt hier gehört, was Gerüchte halber so herumgetragen wird. Und wir sind auch bereit, das zu glauben, denke ich, dass es sehr starke publizistische Kräfte gibt, die sich eigentlich eine blau-schwarze Koalition herbeisehnen.
Diese wird nicht unter Friedrich Merz sein. Glaubst du, dass jemand Frauen gestaltet den Friedrich Merz betritt, wo eben ne Ansage gemacht wird? Das fällt schon für ziemlich hammer an.
Na, wir haben gehört, naja, das wird nicht so gesagt, aber wir haben ja gehört, wie Gabor Steingart mit anderen aus seiner Riege bei Merkel auftritt und dann sagt, liebe Frau Merkel, Sie müssen das und das mal machen. Und dann ist er nachher bitter enttäuscht. Da ist er enttäuscht darüber, dass sie nicht noch eine weitere Agenda 2010 durchgesetzt hat. Und was ich mir schon vorstellen kann, ist, dass es ein Treffen gibt von Medienschaffenden aus dem Rechten Lager, wo dann auch der Gotthard, wo ja Julia Klöckner schon zu Gast war auch jetzt noch mal vor ein paar Monaten, wo dann Reichelt oder sonst wer noch vielleicht dabei ist und wegen mir auch jemand von Apollo News. Und dass die mit dem sprechen, wie sehr dann wirklich dem die Pistole auf die Brust gesetzt wurde, das weiß ich natürlich nicht, wie diplomatisch man da vorgegangen ist. Was ich mir aber gut vorstellen kann, ist, dass bei diesen Leuten erst mal eine gewisse Euphorie da war, dass Friedrich Merz gewählt wird, weil er ja derjenige war, der im Januar mit der AfD zusammen doch gearbeitet hat, was ja auch Friedmann und ein paar andere dazu bewogen hat, aus der CDU auszutreten. Also dachte man, mit dem ist vielleicht also doch auf Dauer eine Koalition zu machen und das ist nur noch so eine Zwischenetappe mit der SPD. Ich habe aber auch immer gesagt hier, dass ich nicht davon ausgehe, dass Friedrich Merz derjenige ist, aufgrund katholischer Sozialisierung, Sauerland und so weiter, der so eine AfD-Koalition eingehen würde. Und du denkst da ja auch nicht dran, dass Friedrich Merz das wäre, sondern dass wir eher davon ausgingen, dass das dann Jens Spahn und andere wären. Und deshalb würde ich jetzt auch nicht gleich von Bollwerk sprechen, weil das klingt so heroisch, was es nicht ist. Aber ich denke schon, dass wir diese Verschiebungen da gerade sehen. Die Frage wird dann eher sein, wie stark sind eigentlich die anderen Kräfte in der CDU, die das vermeiden? Denn wir haben natürlich mit der NRW CDU eine extrem mächtige Partei, Landespartei, die nicht zum Großteil, denke ich, das mitgehen würden, sondern der Großteil würde eher sich in der Tradition, eher Merkel vielleicht sogar noch als Merz sehen, jedenfalls nicht, sich diesem rechtsradikalen Lager anschließen will. Während wir natürlich auf der anderen Ebene Spahn und so sehen wir das ja. Also wir sehen es ja auch jetzt gerade. Es gibt ja, kann man ja im Spiegel nachlesen, so eine Recherche nochmal über diese Kreditfinanzierung bei Jens Spahn mit seiner Villa. Und da gibt es ja auch einen Unternehmer, Angersmaier oder so heißt der, der mit Petatil natürlich auch zu tun hat. Und der könnte möglicherweise Bürger oder so gewesen sein. Man weiß das alles nicht so genau, aber der Spiegelartikel geht da doch in viele Details rein. Und da erleben wir zum Beispiel, dass diesen, dieses Thema weder von der Bildseite noch von Nios noch von Apollo News oder so aufgegriffen wird. Das heißt, da gibt es schon so eine Schutzglocke, die über gewisse Personen gelegt wird.
Also alles schön und gut, alles richtig, sehr gute Analyse. In dem Falle würde ich aber sagen, Analysen sind halt, was man so macht, wenn man Szenarien durchplant und so. Ich glaube aber, im Nachhinein wird sich das alles so trial and error mäßig entfalten. Es heißt ja immer in so Diskussionen, ne, wenn die CDU das macht, dann zerreißt es die CDU. Und dann fragen immer alle, also keiner spricht es aus, muss das mal wirklich zu fragen, aber was heißt das eigentlich, die CDU zerreißt es? Oder das Land hält das nicht aus?
Ne, das ist, das würde ich sagen, ich weiß auch gar nicht, ob das als erstes von der CDU auskäme oder vielleicht sogar doch von der SPD. Denn es gab auch oder gibt Gerüchte, dass, wenn jetzt die Landtagswahlen anstehen und dort die CDU bereit ist, mit der AfD zu koalieren, dass dann die SPD es krachen lässt und sagt, da machen wir dann nicht mehr mit, mit einer solchen Partei. Also auch das könnte auch aus dieser Richtung natürlich kommen.
Ich würde sagen, wir sind jetzt an so einem Punkt, das ist ein bisschen wie in Amerika, wo einfach Sachen passieren und dann versuchen, noch Leute eine Erklärung zu geben oder irgendeine Herleitung. Dann kommt man mit Alexander nochmal her, das muss man so und so verstehen. Das ist jetzt ganz wichtig hier und da und im März und am 28. Februar, weißt du, als sozusagen die Gewissheiten. Nur in Amerika wird ja jetzt demnächst ja schon Bilanz gezogen, jetzt schon. Also es war da jetzt Weihnachten. Da haben Kinder Geschenke bekommen und wir haben, ich habe auch schon versucht, das ein bisschen rauszufinden, es ist noch schwer, aber es wird ja die Statistiken geben. Es wird ja ernsthafte Statistiken dann bald darüber geben, wo man so ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann, wie ist Weihnachten gelaufen? Also ganz konkret, wie viele Geschenke weniger waren es denn?
Wie viele Puppen?
Wie viele Puppen weniger waren es denn?
Genau.
Wir haben natürlich ein Mediensystem, das immer davon abweicht, uns irgendwas Konkretes über echte Lebenswelten zu sagen. Wir haben es jetzt ausführlich besprochen, gerade heute. Aber das, was er als Szenario, ja, der März wird ja uns davor beschützen. Also solange März noch da, es wird die CDU nicht mit der AfD, aber dann achtet schon oder irgendwie so. Ich denke mir so, ja, wir sind jetzt bitte alle alarmiert und jeder macht mal so ein bisschen. Und ich hätte so eine, also ich würde schon sagen, wir können so Denkangebote machen. Was heißt es denn? Es wird das Land zerreißen. Es wird die CDU zerreißen. Wenn nächstes Jahr diese Landtagswahlen stattfinden, die CDU macht halt, und sei es nur irgendwelches Gesprächsformate, die gefunden werden oder irgendeinen Halbsatz, der dann in dieser Elefantenrunde schiefläuft oder was auch immer, wo einfach klar wird, die CDU kann gar nicht anders. Ach so, die wünschen sich das auch. Ja, dann mal gucken. Dann gibt es irgendwelche Leute, die glauben, wir können uns das ein bisschen kochen lassen. Aber so in drei Monaten machen wir dann einen Koalitionsvertrag, wie auch immer. Das sind doch so Themenlagen, bei der dann wirklich jeder sich bekennen muss. Also wie du es jetzt angedeutet hast. Was wird die SPD im Bund machen, wenn die CDU auf Landesebene das und jenes macht?
Ich hörte mal, dann würde sie das krachen lassen.
So, und jetzt ist ja wieder die Frage, meinen sie das strategisch? Wollen sie, dass das vorher durchsickert? Ist das schon mal eine Warnung, wie auch immer und so, ne? Nur, ich gehe mir doch Situationen, bei denen dieses, es müssen jetzt Bekenntnisse abgelegt werden, auch wenn wir immer dagegen sind, aber wo sich mal Politik dann wirklich niederschlägt, wie sich Anne Wilders jetzt noch nicht vorstellen kann. Also, dass wirklich Familien daran zerbrechen, dass es heißt, ich hab bis jetzt nicht drüber nachgedacht, aber ich kann zu Gerts Geburtstagsfeier nicht kommen, weil ich reise aus Köln an und ich lebe in homosexueller Partnerschaft und ich weiß ja, wie es da zugeht. Diesmal kann ich das Auge nicht mehr zudrücken. Also, wo echte Familien zerbrechen, so wie bislang innerhalb der AfD alle Familien zerbrechen. Also, wer im Bundestag sitzt, hat keine funktionierende Familie mehr in der AfD. Das kann man glaube ich relativ sicher sagen.
Ja, das wäre schön, wenn du auch auf der anderen Ebene damit Recht haben würdest, aber ich befürchte eher, dass es auch hier die große Gewöhnung ist und dass man sagen wird, naja, ganz so schlimm ist es ja dann auch nicht gekommen. Und zwar, wenn es dann auch wirklich nicht das Schlimmste ist, also wenn jetzt nicht der Höcke der Ministerpräsident ist, dann gibt es doch so ein Arrangement in einem Lager, das sich ja hier schon andeutet, wo man sagt, naja gut, also das ist natürlich alles nicht so ganz schön, aber dass man am Ende da ein Modus findet, wie man das bei Meloni auch beobachten kann. Man sagte noch so die ersten acht Monate Postfaschistin, dann hat man irgendwann gesagt, ja Rechte oder rechtspopulistisch und inzwischen ist sie einfach so eine der Ministerpräsidentinnen, die man so hat in der EU. Und dann gibt es so eine ganz große Gewöhnung daran. Und da frage ich mich, ob das, oder ich frage mich nicht, sondern ich würde sagen, dass das das Entscheidende sein wird, wenn man tatsächlich so eine AfD-Republik bekommt. Dann bedeutet das ja nicht, dass jetzt die alle glühende Anhänger der AfD werden, sondern es muss einfach bei genügend Menschen eine Gewöhnung eintreten, dass sie sagen, naja gut, also ich mag die auch nicht so sehr, aber das machen sie doch eigentlich gerade ganz passabel. Und dann frage ich mich, wird zum Beispiel so ein Ton auch in Politikpodcasts kommen, dass man sagt, naja, man kann jetzt viel sagen und ideologisch teile ich das ja auch nicht, aber hier haben sie aber auch mal einen Punkt. Und so was hören wir hin und wieder jetzt schon. Von daher glaube ich, dass das immer weiter ausbreiten wird.
Die Mutter sitzt immer so lange fest auf der Schraube, bis du diesen einen Moment überdreht hast.
Aber gibt es da den Moment?
Ja, also wir haben doch gerade allerbestes Anschauungsmaterial. Wer glaubt, also jetzt, jeder einzelne Hörer kann jetzt für sich kurz dieses Gedankenmodell, man kann danach auch nach googeln einfach dieser Frage wirklich mal, und zwar nicht mit so einem, ah mein Vibe sagt der Deutschlandfunk usw., sondern auf konkreter Ebene, wenn ich jetzt mal richtig reingehe, eine Stunde lang mich von Gemmien einmal durchleiten lasse zu dieser Frage. Wer glaubt, dass jetzt nach einem Jahr Donald Trump sich Amerika gerade dran gewöhnt, oder wer glaubt, dass sich da gerade etwas aufstaut? Ich würde auch sagen, gewöhnt sich Amerika gerade dran, dass im Weißen Haus so ein pädophilen Ring, der die eigene Vergangenheit entdeckt, die Zukunft komplett in die Scheiße reitet, dass man das jetzt einfach auf Dauer stellt, und wenn Trump weg ist, wird JD Vans gewählt. Ist das gerade das Gefühl, das man hat, wenn man nach Amerika schaut?
Im Journalismus nicht. Ich weiß nicht, wie das der Industriearbeiter sieht.
Ich finde, wenn sich einer dran gewöhnt, dann ist es noch der Journalismus, weil er nämlich einfach aussortiert wird. Als nächstes wird CNN aussortiert und so. Das kriegen die alles noch hin in die Rahmzeit. Aber glaubt man wirklich, dass jetzt gerade in Amerika eine große, endlich haben wir unser Modell gefunden für die nächsten 20 Jahre?
Ich bin auch darauf hingewiesen jetzt im Rahmen dieses Podcasts in den vergangenen Monaten, dass Dobrindt AfD-Politik umsetzt. Wo ist dann jetzt der Unterschied, wenn wir einfach einen Innenminister hätten, der von der AfD ist? Dann würde es meines Erachtens noch mal sehr viel härter und schlimmer für einige Leute werden. Aber würden die Menschen in Deutschland, also die Normalbevölkerung, um dieses Wort mal zu verwenden, anders darauf reagieren? Und ich befürchte, für einen Großteil stimmt das leider nicht.
Also die Dobrindt-Innenpolitik, die hier gerade stattfindet, betrifft Bundespolizisten als ausführende Organe, betrifft Menschen an der Grenze und betrifft Afghanen im Ausland. Sie betrifft Industriearbeiter nicht. Die AfD-Innenpolitik, die durchzieht, würde einfach jeden Einzelnen betreffen.
Ja, die durchzieht. Und da sehe ich ja genau die große Gefahr, dass...
Na ja, aber wenn sie nicht durchzieht, dann wird halt Dobrindt gegen den AfD-Innenminister ausgetauscht.
Ja, aber das werden ja, wenn wir von AfD-Regierungen reden, das ist ja das Profil daran. Es ist ja eben nicht der Hebel, der umgelegt wird, sondern das sind die schrittweisen Veränderungen. Und dann dauert das und dauert das und dauert das, aber es wird immer schlechter und immer schlimmer für sehr, sehr viele Leute. Das auf jeden Fall. Nur sehen wir erst einmal dann vielleicht, dass man in einer Koalition zusammenarbeitet, dann gibt es das erste journalistische Lob und da konnten sie aber auch wirklich was machen und so. Also man sieht doch auf europäischer Ebene, wie man sich an Bologna gewöhnt hat. Und das halte ich für hier und da sehe ich wirklich auch diese fundamentale Gefahr, dass sich da nicht mehr ein Widerstand oder so regt oder nicht mal eine grundsätzliche Opposition in der Meinung, sondern dass man sagt, naja, gut, am Ende werden sie es schon machen. Und das funktioniert natürlich auch nur, wenn man einen Teil der CDU mit dem Boot hat. Weil mit einer AfD allein würde das nicht passieren. Und deswegen ist die große Gefahr ja, vor der ja dann auch so Leute wie Breyman aus der Mitte der CDU heraus warnen, dass eben ein Teil der CDU sich öffnen könnte und dann so eine Verbürgerlichung der AfD vorgenommen wird, sodass am Ende alle sagen, naja, aber die tun ja auch was für die Wirtschaft und mit der Kriminalität, das sehen wir doch alle wohl in den Städten und damit hat man eine Gewöhnung geschaffen. Also da sehe ich einfach das Problem bei den extremen Beispielen, die du nennst. Klar, also der, dass jetzt der schwule Kölner nicht ins AfD Nest nach Sachsen fährt, das leuchtet mir ein.
Anders als Robin Alexander und in Stückweiten auch du.
So weit sind wir jetzt schon.
Naja, ich möchte schon anmerken, die Bilder, die ich hier so versuche, wie ein Dirigent der Musik zeigt, irgendwie so für die Zukunft zu machen, die ruhen ja nicht darauf, was irgendwelche Journalisten, irgendwen versuchen einzureden. Dann stellen sie fest, ah, nee, doch nicht. Dann ziehen sie nochmal an und dann ist es so ein Annevilleton zum Jahresende und wie auch immer und alle sind total verwirrt. Und Tina Schmidt-Matern fragt sich, verstehen wir überhaupt, was hier passiert. Ich sage ja, in Amerika fand jetzt ein Weihnachten statt, das Kinder enttäuscht zurückgelassen hat. Die Eltern versuchen jetzt gerade ihnen das Schön zu reden. Wo ich mir wieder denke, ja, ich habe jetzt Bücher darüber geschrieben, dass Eltern das immer versuchen, schön zu reden, was eigentlich nicht schön zu reden ist, aber es ist nun mal die Aufgabe der Eltern. So, was bedeutet, selbst wenn gar keine Protagonisten mehr da sind, die eigentlich die Aufgaben übernehmen sollten, irgendwer wird schon für die strukturelle Befriedung sorgen und sei es die Eltern, die als Fallback einfach klären, was der Staat nicht mehr klärt. So, egal, welche Protagonisten, ob jetzt noch mal in Deutschland ankommt, dass irgendein Hinterbänkler eine Rede gehalten hat, die ja ganz empörend ist und so weiter. Die strukturelle Ebene ist davon unberührt einfach da. Millionen Kinder haben ein enttäuschendes Weihnachten hinter sich gebracht und wahrscheinlich fällt ihr nächster Sommerurlaub aus. Oder es ist nur halb so lang oder sie können doch nicht ins Fernlag, oder was auch immer. Also die materiellen Zwänge sind einfach da. Jetzt hast du ja gesagt, wird das denn der Industriearbeiter merken? Und jetzt gibt es diese Antwort auf zwei Ebenen. Er wird nicht merken, dass irgendein AfDler innenpolitisch irgendeine Maßnahme verkünden, die ihn direkt und so weiter. Und er wird dann denken, die AfD hat das entschieden. Das finde ich nicht gut. So wir werden aber und das ist halt manchmal sind es auch wirklich erst generationale Shifts der nächste Jahrgang, der in den Beruf kommt und sich fragt, wie viele Leute soll ich jetzt einstellen? Für was? Ich habe doch eine KI. Während die alten Unternehmen immer noch KI, was ist das und so. Also der Junge stellt schon gar keine Leute mehr ein. Das sind einfach strukturelle Shifts, die stattfinden. So wenn in Deutschland die AfD regiert, wird alleine das Investitionsklima dafür sorgen, dass wir das nach zwei Jahren merken. Und das merkt dann einfach jeder. Und jetzt ganz wichtig, keine Ausrede zum Thema. Wir brauchen dann aber einen Journalismus, der eins plus eins zusammenzählt und den Leuten erklärt, deswegen merkst du das. Darum geht es mir gar nicht. Darauf warte ich nie.
Nein, die merken es im Portemonnaie.
Genau, sondern wir werden und das ist, du lobst ja mal Franco Milanovic und so. Der erklärt den Leuten, du kannst nicht mehr nach Südtirol in den Urlaub fahren, weil dein Zimmer weggebucht wurde von einem Japaner oder von einem aufstrebenden Vietnamesen oder was auch immer.
Ja, so. Ich kann da nur zustimmen. Meint er auch nur, dass wenn es zu einer solchen Koalition kommt, das merkt man ja nicht innerhalb von 30 Tagen im Portemonnaie, sondern es dauert eine Zeit, bis das da und dort ankommt oder auch nicht überall gleich stark. Aber bis dahin gibt es eben eine Gewöhnung daran. Und wir haben ja ein Vorbild, auch die, grüßen wir alle servus miteinander nach Österreich. Da haben ja schon rechtere Regierungen regiert, als das hier in Deutschland der Fall ist. Und dort haben wir auch gesehen, wie sehr die Bevölkerung sich auch daran gewöhnt. Also nicht, dass es da gar keinen Widerstand gibt oder so, aber man sieht schon, dass auch dort ein Gewöhnungseffekt stattfinden kann, bei denen man erstmal dachte, das wird ja wohl gar nicht durchgehen. Und doch, das geht dann durch. Und das meine ich, dass das am Ende eine Retourkutsche wieder produziert. Insofern, als die Portemonnaies leer bleiben, Versprechungen, die man also machte, überhaupt nicht eingehalten werden, im Gegenteil, es sich noch verschlechtert. Und dass das auch dazu wieder führen kann, dass die nicht ewig an der Macht bleiben, das ist ja auch nochmal wichtig, das zu betonen. Das ist jetzt nicht die eine Schicksalsfrage, die ist dann auf ewig gelöst. Da gehe ich absolut mit dir mit.
Ja, aber ganz wichtig ist der Punkt, die zukünftigen Machtfragen werden nicht einfach innerhalb der Rechten geklärt, so wie die Magers jetzt auf der Bühne steht dort ein Streit miteinander. Sondern dass selbst wir in Europa irgendwie so nach New York schauen und sehen, der Mamdani, ich weiß nicht, was er bringt, aber die Rhetorik ist schon mal cool. Er bringt den Leuten zumindest das richtige Problembewusstsein wieder mit, egal ob jemand eine Lösung mal hat für dieses reiche Problem oder nicht, wie auch immer. Aber so ein Mandami über den, also diese Freude darüber.
Aber schau doch mal Italien. Italien hat doch...
Nein, nein, nein. Stopp. Ich will nicht über Meloni. Meloni reitet Italien auch gerade in Grund und Boden. Die Flüchtlingszahlen explodieren.
Aber geht es der Wirtschaft?
Die Armut rasiert. Und der Wirtschaft geht es sehr schlecht. Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß, ich will nicht bremsen. Aber auch in Amerika hören wir gerade tolle BIP-Zahlen und so weiter. Und dann wird in so einem Halbsatz immer gesagt, ja, 95 Prozent des BIP-Wachstums sind KI-Dinger. Diese KI-Dinger erzeugen nicht nur virtuelles Wachstum, sondern zerstören auch noch Grund und Boden in allen Kommunen, wo sie aufgreifen.
Ich sitze jetzt auch hier nicht, um zu sagen, die Meloni macht doch einen tollen Job, was ich aber festhalten will.
Nee, aber jeder kommt immer mit dieser Meloni. Und in so einem Deutschlandfunkgespräch wäre das der Burner. Wenn du da mit so einer Meloni kommst, alle glühen davor, jeder möchte den nächsten BIP machen zum Thema. Ja, das ist voll krass. Das ist auch ein Szenario für die AfD oder was auch immer. In Deutschland nicht. Meloni gilt europaweit als, wenn wir uns das Spektrum angucken. Und ich sage, es ist die Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung, die den Fächer aufgemacht hat. Was sind die europäischen Rechtskonservativen? Meloni steht auf der einen Seite, die AfD steht auf der anderen Seite. Egal welches Bild wir aus Deutschland haben, wenn in Europa publik wird, dass die AfD mitregiert, dann sehen die Leute eine neue NSDAP an der Macht.
Wer sieht das an der Macht?
Naja, der europäische Diskurs, der schon immer lief mit einer Wiedervereinigung. Was ist, wenn Deutschland zu stark wird? Die Franzosen, die auf Deutschland schauen, die haben uns so platt gemacht, ökonomisch, wir wurden einmal voll verarscht. Wenn jetzt die AfD kommt, haben wir in Deutschland noch einen Diskurs, der läuft unter, ja vielleicht macht ihn ja so ein langsames, der Frosch im Wasser und das köchelt langsam und die Leute merken es gar nicht. Aber in dem Moment, wo klar wird, und du hast die New York Times Berichterstattung auch dazu gesehen, als hier, ja, das AfD-NSDAP, das ist einfach historisch, war da nicht groß. Aber da wissen wir ja, dass wir differenzieren müssen und wir wissen auch, sagst du den Franzosen, sagst du den Italienern, sagst du den Spaniern, die schon immer vor Deutschland zittern, dass sie jetzt nicht die NSDAP sucht.
Aber wieder eine Melodie, noch eine Le Pen hätten irgendein Problem damit, wenn Alice Weidel die AfD hier führen würde und auch Regierungsverantwortung übernehmen.
Also Le Pen und Weidel können miteinander, aber nur, weil sie sich auf die Zähne beißen, sich die Hände auf den Rücken zusammenbinden und nicht miteinander reden.
Das sehe ich eben fundamental anders. Und ich sehe, dass wir bei der AfD möglicherweise eine Melonisierung weiterhin bekommen. Das muss nicht so sein. Da gibt es ja jetzt gerade sehr starke Kräfte in eine andere Richtung wieder. Also auch das Höcke-Lager nimmt ja Anlauf in gewisser Weise zumindest. Aber wir haben nicht den Punkt, wo man sagt, wenn die jetzt da mitregieren, dann würde man irgendwie aus Europa oder so ausgesperrt werden. Das ist ja nicht so, sondern es gibt ja eben dann diese großen Gewöhnungen daran. Und das sehe ich als das große Problem auch an.
Naja, ich sehe immer Gewöhnungen, bis das Pendel die Richtung wechselt. Und Gewöhnung hat halt einen Endlauf. Das weiß jeder.
Ja, ich habe auch nicht gesagt, dass die jetzt das 1000-jährige Reich bekommen.
Die Frage ist immer, wenn du jetzt sagst, wir gewöhnen uns daran, an was denn? Dass wir wirklich wieder KZs aufbauen und eine Million Türken hier einfach vergasseln oder?
Nein, daran wird sich nicht gewöhnt.
Aber woher denn?
Ja, zum Beispiel an eine Politik, wie Meloni sie macht.
Ja, bei Melonis Politik, also ich meine, Italien funktioniert.
Das haben wir aber in Österreich auch. In Österreich hatten wir rechte Regierungen. Und wenn man dann mit Leuten spricht, die sich auskennen, dann können die einem sagen, ja, die haben zwar unglaublich viel Rhetorik in Anschlag gebracht, am Ende haben die aber auch nicht nennenswert weniger Migration dadurch gehabt als vorher. Das heißt, man darf ja jetzt auch nicht das Bild produzieren, dass wenn die AfD mitregiert, dass dann sofort die Lager aufgebaut werden. Genau, wenn man das nämlich auf diese Weise macht, das ist vielleicht mein entscheidender Punkt noch dazu. Mein Problem ist, dass wir jetzt gerade, wenn wir über die AfD reden, immer mit diesen NS-Vergleichen arbeiten, um dann zu sagen, und so würde es sein. Ich kann dir aber sagen, würde die AfD jetzt in einem Bundesland oder sogar auf einer Bundesebene erst einmal an der Koalition beteiligt werden, würde ja genau nicht der NS-Staat nachgebaut werden.
Ja, dem nenne ich.
Und dadurch sagen die Leute, da seht ihr, ist doch gar nicht so wild. Und dieses ist doch gar nicht so wild. Das ist die größte Gefahr, weil die die Gewöhnung dann erst einmal so etabliert, dass man dann von Seiten der AfD immer weitergehen kann, man wird immer noch sagen, es ist doch gar nicht so schlimm. Na ja, so. Also wie die Nazis sind sie ja nicht. Und solange man immer noch sagen kann, so wie die Nazis sind sie ja nicht, kann man sich daran gewöhnen.
Und das sehe ich als Problem. Mich interessiert nicht, was jemand sagt. Mich interessiert das, was am Bewusstsein vorbei strukturell passiert, wenn die AfD hier Regierungsmehrheiten übernimmt.
Ich glaube wirtschaftlich hast du dann Punkt. Und das wäre quasi auch die Rettung dann.
Es zählt ausschließlich, was wirtschaftliche Realität ist.
Ja, aber die wirtschaftliche Realität, das stimmt, aber die wirtschaftliche Realität wird ja trotzdem dann falsch interpretiert. Also es gibt Leute, die haben eine schlechte wirtschaftliche Realität, oder deren Realität hat sich verschlechtert. Und dann sagen sie, die Migranten sind schuld. Und das ist fundamental falsch interpretiert, aber trotzdem hat es noch mit der wirtschaftlichen Realität zu tun. Und das ist eben das Ding, wenn man Leuten dann eintrichtern kann, naja, die AfD will ja eigentlich das Gute, aber seht ihr, die vorherigen Regierungen, die haben so viel und das und das gemacht. Das heißt, die CDU hat es ja sogar geschafft, sich immer noch als Oppositionspartei zu inszenieren, nach 16 Jahren Merkel. Und jetzt regiert man schon wieder. Also das ist ja absurd. Aber deswegen glaube ich, sollte man nicht unterschätzen, wie sehr die Menschen zwar auf der Grundlage der Realität, der ökonomischen Handeln, aber dann trotzdem diese ökonomische Grundlage falsch interpretieren. Und Leuten, die Schulden in die Schuhe schieben, die nichts dafür können.
Ja, also wir haben ja jetzt schon gesehen, wie weit man politische Diskurse treiben kann. Also in Deutschland findet ja echt eine echte Verarmung statt. Ja. Also die beginnt natürlich erstmal so geistig. Also Leute jammern darüber, in welchem Zustand Deutschland ist, kriegen Geschichten von außen und dann heißt es irgendwie, hier ist alles schmutzig und so weiter und so. Und das hat natürlich Gründe. Es ist einfach niemand da, der es aufräumen kann. Also es hat auch kein Budget da, um Frankfurt mal aufzuräumen. Also sieht halt Frankfurt aus, wie es aussieht. So und das wird sich niederschlagen. Es ist ja immer nur die Frage, wie weit. Also wie weit gewöhnt man sich daran, dass irgendwas im Argen liegt und wählt dann trotzdem AfD, weil die, die Wut kanalisieren. So und ich sage ja, Gewöhnung, schön und gut. Also das ist einfach der normale Lauf der Dinge. Man gewöhnt sich an alles, aber so, es sind halt Pendelbewegungen, die Sachen oszillieren. So und ich also ich stelle mir auch die Frage, wie weit kann der Deutschlandfunk, wie weit kann die ARD uns noch vorgaukeln, dass der einzige Maßstab für Erfolge in der Migrationspolitik niedrige Zahlen sind? So ich meine die Demografie und die ökonomischen Kennzahlen, das ist halt wie ein Coronavirus. Mit denen kann man nicht diskutieren. Die schlagen einfach durch. Typischerweise sagt man bei so einem Virus, wir müssen uns jetzt schützen, keine Ahnung, das Gefahrenvollzug, das ist für neu. Und das macht man halt bei ökonomischen Kennziffern nicht, aber die sind halt wie sie sind. In Amerika haben wir jetzt gesehen, wie weit man es treiben kann. Also Death of Despair heißt ja, dass mittelalte weiße Männer einfach 20 Jahre in der Lebenserwartung zurückliegen. Also das sind wie Branko Milanovic sagt nigerianische Zustände. In ganz normalen Mittelklassefamilien. Da werden Männer einfach aussatiert, weil sie, ja, keine Verwendung für sie finden. Genau, man weiß einfach nicht. Sie wissen selber nicht mit sich wohin und dann gibt es ja irgendwie Drogen und Tabletten und was auch immer. Dann sind sie einfach tot. So, das heißt, das Gewöhnungsargument kann man unendlich weit treiben. In Amerika haben sie es so weit getrieben, dass ganze Landstriche verahmend, vereinzelt und wie in afrikanischen Hilfszentren leben, während in Washington relativ wenig Leute, also wo einfach grundsätzlich klar ist, hier tagt das Kabinett alle am Tisch den Milliardären. So, und Milliardär heißt, hier muss man keine konkrete Lebensentscheidung mehr treffen. Wir sehen ja auch, was das bedeutet. Jeder lebt in seiner eigenen Traumwelt. Der eine will zum Mars fliegen, der andere will nie mehr sterben und so. Jeder macht so seinen eigenen Scheiß. Also man kann es sehr weit treiben. Wenn du jetzt sagst, aber die Gewöhnung, die Gewöhnung, die ist eine große Gefahr, sag ich. Die Gewöhnung ist eine riesige Gefahr. So, ich glaube aber grundsätzlich, dass Deutschland, Europa insgesamt, aber Deutschland insbesondere, und ja, da spielt NS-Geschichte schon eine Rolle, anders drauf ist. Die AfD ist halt jetzt so erfolgreich, weil sie Leute einsammelt, die sie wählen. Aber, und ja, da gibt es durchaus einen Punkt, den man machen kann, der wird häufiger gemacht, die AfD hat noch nirgendwo konkrete Verantwortung übernommen, außer auf kommunalpolitischer Ebene. Und weil wir aber in Deutschland immer nur Champions League und Bundesliga und ARD und ZDF und Deutschlandfunk hören, wo wir niemals über Kommunalpolitik aufgeklärt werden, wissen wir halt nicht, wie es gerade desaströs in Landstrichen zuläuft, bei denen schon vor dieser AfD-Wahl 45 Prozent Mindestlohn kassiert haben, also eh schon abgemeldet waren vom Staat. Wenn das jetzt von 45 auf 65 Prozent steigt, weil einfach das Investitionsklima Null ist, wir kriegen das nicht mit. Diese Bilanz wird noch nicht gezogen, aber die Leute dort leiden. Und die Leute haben dort Wut auf die Politik. Und wenn die Politik von der AfD gemacht wird, haben die halt Wut auf AfD-Politik.
Das ist ja auch eine wirklich wichtige Erkenntnis, um das zu sagen, weil manche sind ja wirklich in so einem Untergangsszenario, wenn sie über Deutschland reden und die AfD, dass man sagen kann, ja, aber solche Faktoren können auch dazu führen, dass die Leute sich wieder von der AfD abwenden. Also das muss man auch mal unterstreichen. Also man kann jetzt nicht immer alles schon antizipieren, wie wird es sein, wenn die AfD vier Jahre regiert hat oder so. Erstmal wäre ja gut, dass sie gar nicht regiert. Aber auch da muss man sagen, es muss dann nicht gleich bedeuten, dass damit alles manifestiert ist und nichts mehr bewegt sich, sondern genau das kann dann auch da wieder stattfinden, wenn man nämlich sieht, dass da irgendwas versprochen wurde, was nicht eingehalten wird. Von daher ist da auf jeden Fall ein Spielraum da. Ich sehe nur, jetzt gerade nochmal bezogen auf die CDU, wird es die CDU zerreißen, kann ich so nicht beantworten. Ich sehe schon, dass es da der CDU große Kräfte gibt, die das nicht wollen. Warum aber dann trotzdem Jens Spahn zum Beispiel eine solch mächtige CDU-Position inne hat, das ist mir nicht so ganz klar. Und dann Julia Klöckner und noch einige andere so aus diesem Bereich. Das finde ich höchst verdächtig. Kann ich mir auch nicht so erklären?
Ich kann dir das sofort erklären. In der CDU wird orchestriert. Wenn da einmal eine Kampfkandidatur ist und sei es nur um eine, gehört eigentlich gar nicht zur Parteistiftung, rasten gleich alle aus. Weil ein offensichtlicher Plan, wir machen das doch vorher so, wir sagen doch, wer hier gewählt werden soll und so. Es gibt doch keinen Gegenkandidaten, die Fraktion tritt an und dann wird abgestimmt.
Aber dass jemand wie Spahn so eine mächtige Position erlangen konnte, ist ja schon erstaunlich.
Ja, aber es ist...
Und da kann man sich schon auch medial fragen, wodurch wird das unterstützt? Und ich würde zum Beispiel sagen, dass Jens Spahns Karriere sehr eng auch mit Springer zusammenhängt.
Es ist erstaunlich, dass es funktioniert, aber wir müssen der CDU unterstellen, dass sie auch persönlich in den Einzelfällen wirklich strunzdorf ist. Und das sind sie ja auch. Also so wie sie die von außen an sie herangetragene Agitation gegen die Richterin einfach durchgezogen haben, ohne einmal selber mitzudenken. So machen die dort jeden Wahlgang. Nur diesmal betracht es eine Richterin zur Bundesverfassungsgericht. Aber das ist ein typischer Ablauf für einen CDU-Fraktionsvorsitz.
Das kann aber dann mal in entscheidenden Momenten gefährlich werden.
Das war einmal unterschiedlich mit dem Brinkhaus gegen Kauder, dann hieß es plötzlich Mehrheit-Brinkhaus. Dann hat die CDU wieder, nee, das dürfen wir so auf gar keinen Fall zulassen. Also hier muss ganz klar vorher geregelt sein. Die Ansage kommt von oben. Jeder, der dagegen jetzt muss vortanzen und so weiter. Und man sieht sofort, wer da aus der Reihe tanzt. Und die CDU als Rekrutierungsorganisation weiß natürlich, wie sie Leute aussatiert. Also das hat ja von oben nach unten. Wenn die CDU für eins bekannt ist, dann ja wohl, wie man aussatiert. Merkels großes Erfolgsrezept, die Männer aussatieren, aussatieren, aussatieren, aussatieren. Also ich wundere mich das alles gar nicht. Friedrich Merz Bilanz. Wir halten zugute, oder sagen wir so, erstmal hören wir das Statement von Friedrich Merz über Donald Trump. Er war ja da zu Besuch. Und, ne, er war nicht dort zu Besuch, sondern er hat Botschaften nach Amerika gesendet mit seinem, wenn ihr mit Europa nichts anfangen könnt, dann lasst doch uns euren Partner sein. Was ja zu Recht kritisiert wurde, nur wie das Statement losgeht, finde ich ja schon skandalös.
Merz glaubt zu wissen, wie mit solchen Tiraden umzugehen ist. America First, das hat immer zwei Seiten, unterstreicht der CDU-Chef.
Ich sage in meinen Gesprächen mit den Amerikanern, America First ist fine, aber America alone kann nicht in eurem Interesse sein. Ihr braucht auf der Welt auch Partner. Und einer der Partner kann Europa sein, und wenn ihr mit Europa nichts anfangen könnt, dann macht wenigstens Deutschland zu eurem Partner.
Friedrich Merz wird nachgesagt, einen halbwegs guten Draht zu Donald Trump zu haben.
So, America First ist fine. Für wen? Für die Welt nicht.
Nein.
Für 330 Millionen Amerikaner nicht. Für 20 Millionen Amerikaner durchaus. Für Donald Trump? Aber hallo. So, America First ist nicht fine. Das ist einfach... Also diese Idee, man könnte das, was jetzt das letzte Jahr in Amerika stattfand, die Unis kurzum kleinschlagen, mit irgendwelchen Minivans und maskierter Leute von der Straße fischen, diese Zollschranken hochmachen, jedes kleine Business, das die Produktion nach China ausgelagert ist, in die Knie zwingen. Dass man das auch nur, ich will ja nicht mal von auf Dauer stellen, aber dass man das eine Amtsperiode durchhält, das ist völlig absurd. Also auch ein Gewöhnungsargument, an was soll man sich denn da gewöhnen? Ja, aber offenbar passiert das ja. Dass man morgens so eine Schiebetür...
Also bei Friedrich Merz.
Ja, bei Friedrich Merz, genau. Während wir einfach sagen...
Und könnten wir uns das jetzt mal umgekehrt vorstellen, Deutschland würde AfD regiert werden, dass dann auf europäischer Ebene man sich vielleicht auch einfach daran gewöhnt und sagt, die machen jetzt komische Dinge da, aber naja, wir machen mal weiter so.
Genau. Also Friedrich Merz sagt jetzt, America First is Fine und hat damit eine Meinung bekundet als unbetroffener von außen, der versucht in der Zukunft ein gutes Verhältnis mit Merz zu haben. Unter diesen Gesichtspunkten... Mit Trump, ja. Kann man sagen, okay, das verstehe ich irgendwie. Nur in einem Jahr werden vielleicht auch Amerikaner so Rückfragen an Europa stellen, im Sinne von, das habt ihr alles zugelassen. Also irgendwann wird ja auch Bilanz gezogen insgesamt. Robin Alexander macht gute Sprüche, denn, und jetzt Thema Gewöhnung, also der Springer-Verlag versucht es, uns daran zu gewöhnen. Robin Alexander sagt hier aber schon, nee.
Robin, wenn ihr mit Europa nichts anfangen könnt, dann macht es wenigstens mit Deutschland. Also diese Worte von März, die sind doch fatal, weil sie doch konterkarieren, dass die EU als Einheit geschlossen gegenüber den USA auftreten muss. Und jetzt dieses Angebot, dann mach es halt mit Deutschland. Das ist doch genau das, worauf die Trump-Regierung abzielt, ein Auseinanderdividieren der EU und bilaterale Abkommen mit einzelnen Staaten abzuschließen.
So, bevor wir jetzt hören, was er dazu sagt. Döpfner, Poschardt würden jetzt sagen, Dagmar, sag mal, spinnst du? Das ist unser bester Mann in der Politik. Da kenne ich mich zu wenig aus. Hauptsache, niemand mancht irgendwie in Rechtsstaatlichkeit rum oder sowas her. Komm, irgendwie, dass ich sprüche. Aber das sind doch die größten Fans von, ja, wir sollten mal mehr Miläse suchen. Also, wenn ein Land den Versuch unternimmt, aus Menschen, die 10 Milliarden haben, zwölf-fache Milliardäre zu machen, ist das immer eine gute Idee? Egal, was mit den anderen 200 Millionen passiert. So sehen wir das. Das ist ja Döpfner-Porsche als Linie. Hauptsache, meine Autobahn ist frei für meinen Porsche, sollen noch die anderen alle und so weiter. So, jetzt sagt Robin Alexander folgendes, und das ist halt auch so ein bisschen Sargnagel, so kann man halt bei Springer nicht arbeiten.
Ja, ich muss dir recht geben, das ist ein fatales Zitat, das hätte nicht fallen dürfen. Man kann für Friedrich Merz ins Feld führen, dass er ja real versucht, die EU zusammenzuhalten, er hat diesen E3-Komplex aufgebaut, er hält die Italiener und die Polen dabei. Also er macht das, aber der Satz, den kann man sich nicht schönreden und auch nicht mehr heute Abend schön trinken. Der hätte so nicht fallen dürfen.
Das zeigt auch so ein bisschen, wie man sonst immer umgegangen ist bei Springer. Wir haben heute wieder den Auftrag, uns was schön zu saufen fürs Publikum, holt das Mikrofon, holt den Tequila. Jetzt müssen wir wieder Gewöhnung organisieren. Und jetzt sagt Robin Alexander, nee, sorry, Gewöhnung, ich habe auch gehört, dass der Wolfgang Schmitt da Angst vor hat, aber nur soweit. Lasst mich gerne im Deutschlandfunk nochmal die Linie durchpauken zum Thema Migration und Sozialpolitik. Aber beim Thema Europa, ich weiß nicht. Hier bin ich nicht dabei, wenn es Gewöhnungsprogramm gefahren wird. Stattdessen wird dann abgefeiert, was Donald Tusk sagt.
In so einer Lage muss der deutsche Kanzler sagen, wer für uns wie verhandelt, das entscheiden immer noch wir. Und das ist in diesem Fall die Europäische Union. Und das ist unser Staatenbündnis und das bestimmen wir selbst.
Ja, und wie man als Europäer auch reagieren kann, Robin, das hat der polnische Ministerpräsident Tusk gezeigt. Also er hat via X ein Statement verbreitet, das ich mal zitieren möchte, an die Amerikaner gerichtet. Europa ist euer engster Verbündeter, nicht euer Problem. Wir haben gemeinsame Feinde. Zumindest war es in den letzten 80 Jahren so. Und daran müssen wir festhalten, denn das ist die einzig vernünftige Strategie für unsere gemeinsame Sicherheit.
Recht hatte und so hätte es März auch sagen.
Klingt ja auch gruselig. Ist ja alles furchtbar. Klingt ja alles gruselig.
Was meinst du?
Naja, das von Tusk. Die gemeinsamen Feinde.
Die gemeinsamen Feinde, da müssen wir festhalten. Also wir haben jetzt hier, ich finde, mit Robin Alexander redet so im Podcast und verlässt dann auch Springer. Also dass Robin Alexander Springer verlassen hat, ist strukturell zu verrechnen. Das ist nicht nur Semantik. Der Springer-Konzern, der als Ideen-Propaganda-Apparat davon abhängig ist, dass Leute dort Arbeit machen. So ein bisschen wie Google davon abhängig ist, dass Leute da Programmcode schreiben. Die sehen manchmal, wir haben so Programmierer, die sehen uns 100 Millionen werden, wenn nicht Milliarden. Wenn die gehen, ist das ein echtes Problem. Und es ist hier auch ein bisschen so, dass Robin Alexander nicht mehr als er ist super klug und bei Springer, da muss der Springer auch ein bisschen super klug sein, ne, die haben jetzt Gordon Rapinski. Also die haben eine echte Herausforderung für das nächste Jahr, da weiter mitzuspielen. Wir haben jetzt den Fragesteller Ronzheimer, der gerne Fragen stellt und ins Detail gehen möchte und hier nochmal und was nicht verstanden hat und so, aber wie so ein kleiner Junge. Und halt Gordon Rapinski, der versucht, Israel klein zu machen. Robin Alexander haben sie nicht mehr. Und da ich nur Leute kenne, die Robin Alexander Podcasts hören und das andere nicht, denke ich mir, das ist schon... Also hier haben wir es auf jeden Fall schon mal mit einem, das ist, hier hat Gewöhnung ein End, also hier gibt es eine strukturelle Veränderung. Dagmar Rosenfelds, ja, ich bin auch sehr gespannt, wie sie ihre, ich bin jetzt selbstständig. Ne, also du bist wirklich von Robin Alexander abhängig. Wenn Robin Alexander sagen würde in einem Podcast, ja, Dagmar ist heute krank, die Fragen stellt jemand anderes, würden alle so, ja, okay. Wenn Dagmar Rosenfeld ein Podcast beginne mit, er ist heute krank, er ist nicht da, ich mach das heute, dann wird es schwierig. Also, das finde ich auch witzig, so die Dynamik. Dagmar Rosenfeld ist hier bei Apokalypse und Filtercafé und wieder voll des Märzlobes.
Wie ist deine Einschätzung, hat März da? Wir denken auch an seinen Antrittsbesuch, im Weißen Haus hat er das richtige Maß an Schmeicheln und aber auch Grenzen ziehen gefunden.
Ich werde heute hier zur Märzloberin, nachdem ich erst mit diesem Intro so kritisch begonnen habe, mit Roland Kaiser. Also, er hat es gefunden, sein Antrittsbesuch, er hat das Spiel genau richtig mitgespielt.
Ja, und wir blenden so ein bisschen aus, dass das da um einen Redelsführer der industriellen Pädophilie geht und überhaupt und so. Also, ich finde, diese App-Style-Sachen, die sind schon nicht unterzubewerten.
Auch mal davon weg, was hat denn März durch dieses Mitspielen bewirkt?
Das ist halt Gewöhnungsrhetorik.
Das löst sich jetzt gerne mal aus der schönen Bilder. Aber gibt es irgendetwas, wo man sagt, damit ist er nach Hause gekommen, jetzt werden 100.000 deutsche Autos mehr in Amerika verkauft oder so? Also, gibt es irgendwas vorzuweisen? Ich sehe es nicht.
Hier wird uns Toleranz eingefordert, eine Sache, die nicht zu tolerieren ist. Also, hier gibt es nichts schön zu reden. Merz erreicht nichts in Amerika. Die reden nicht mit uns. Der Drops ist gelutscht.
Markus, ich kriege gerade Knickstarre vor lauter Nicken. Du hast dir den Finger in die Wunde gelegt. Dieser Satz von Friedrich Merz, der ist töricht gewesen, der ist fatal gewesen.
Sie kommen also zurück auf diesen Merz-Europa-Satz. Und hier klingt, also Rosenfeld normalisiert. Sie versucht es schon wieder zu normalisieren, ja? Also sie versucht den, nee, Stefan Schulz hat ja gesagt, hier ist Gewöhnung ausgereizt. Das ist eine strukturelle Veränderung. Versucht, sich wieder zurückzuholen in diesen Gewöhnungsteil.
Das ist ein Scholz-Wort, töricht. Sehr schön.
Was ich heute hier alles bin jetzt, jetzt rede ich schon wie Olaf Scholz.
Ich hoffe, es wird...
Entschuldigung, ich wollte dich nicht unterbrechen. Fahre fort.
Ist, töricht, gewesen. Ich würde ihn als ein Versehen definieren, weil so wie Merz agiert, entspricht es ja nicht diesem Satz.
Das ist ein kleiner Vogelschiss auf der Kanzlerschaft von Friedrich Merz, die ansonsten glatt durchgelaufen ist. Da gibt es gar nichts zu kritisieren. Versucht sie.
Vor allen Dingen, man könnte ja auch so sagen, Friedrich Merz hat da mal ausgesprochen, was sehr häufig deutsche Politik in Europa ist, nämlich Deutschland first. Und dann muss man mal sehen, wie wir den anderen noch unsere Produkte aufschwitzen, die sie uns abkaufen.
Jetzt kommt hier wieder so ein Bit, wo ich mir denke, hier ist Gewöhnung ausgereizt. Hier gibt es Zuhörer, die Ulrike Herrmann beipflichten und die sich auch nicht mehr von Veit Medik, dem Politikchef des Stern, die Sache schönreden lassen. Also da muss ich mal ganz klar sagen, es geht um die Stadtbild, den Stadtbildsatz von Merz.
Das war eine rassistische Aussage.
So, sie sagt jetzt einfach, das war eine rassistische Aussage, womit ja der Bundeskanzler ein Rassist wird. So, 1 plus 1.
Rassismus ist immer dann im Spiel, wenn man eine ganze Gruppe pauschal verunglimpft. Und das ist genau hier passiert. Da wird gesagt, es war völlig klar konnotiert, Stadtbild, das Problem sind Migranten und die sind ein Problem. Und zu sagen, alle Migranten sind ein Problem und jeder, der wie Migrant aussieht, Stadtbild ist ja auch ein visuelles Bild, ist ein Problem, weil er so aussieht, wie er aussieht. Das kann man durch absolut nichts rechtfertigen. Und dann diese ganzen Aussagen, die dann noch kamen, ja fragen sie doch ihre Töchter und wir sehen unsere Bahnhöfe aus. Das war nicht die Ursprungsaussage. Die Ursprungsaussage war in ihrer gesamten Härte rassistisch. Da, finde ich, kann man jetzt auch nichts schönreden, sondern man müsste als März mal in sich gehen und sich fragen, was da eigentlich abgeht.
Also sie sagt jetzt, Gewöhnung bis hierher. Das ist ein Rassist, da gibt es nichts schön zu reden. Das ist sozusagen über die Stränge. Jetzt macht Veit Medik etwas, dass ich mal diesem Gewöhnungsding mit unterordne. Er kommt nämlich jetzt mit dem Argument, na aber wir sind doch schon ausreichend daran gewöhnt, wodurch es kein Rassismus wird. Hört ihr es mal an.
Ist er das ja? Er ist ja sogar in, nein, er ist in sich gegangen. Er hat ja so neulich in diesem ARD-Forum gesagt, ja, vielleicht hätte er es früher erklären müssen, was genau er damit meint. Ich weiß nicht, ich wäre jetzt nicht so schnell mit dem Rassismusvorwurf, ehrlich gesagt. Ich glaube, er hat da schon ein Problem oder ein Gefühl adressiert, was schon in der Gesellschaft existiert. Und das verlange ich auch von einem Kanzler, dass er jetzt nicht so spricht, als wenn er mit den üblichen Gedanken der Menschen, die in seinem Land leben, nichts zu tun hat.
Also es kann ja kein Rassismus sein, weil die Leute denken ja auch so.
Nee, dann ist es natürlich auf keinen Fall Rassismus. Da wir ja wissen, dass es in der deutschen Bevölkerung gar keinen Rassismus gibt, kann es kein Rassismus sein.
Also es ist einfach eine frappierende Logik. Diesen letzten Clip hier, den finde ich ganz interessant, denn diese Leute wissen ja, dass sie offensichtlich lügen. Also sie wissen ja, dass es unvernünftig ist, was sie sagen. Es gibt halt nur Gründe, warum sie es trotzdem sagen. Und sei es das kleine Partikularistische, was sie dann eben auch auf allen Ebenen überall beobachten. Ach so, da ist eine linke Politikerin, die jetzt rechte Politik macht. Klar, als Staatssekretärin so.
Außenpolitik aus einem Guss. Danach hat er sich den Außenminister gesucht. Funktioniert nicht wirklich, wie wir ein paar Mal jetzt erzählt haben, Wadephul, der ein Eigenleben entwickelt hat. Dann hatten wir, damit Merz der Außenkanzler sein kann, wird Kanzleramtchef Thorsten Frei, der sozusagen den Innenkanzler ersetzt. Hat auch nicht funktioniert. Und ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob Merz wirklich lernunfähig ist.
Ja, ich bin mir noch nicht so sicher, ob Merz wirklich lernunfähig ist. Also wenn man das schon so sagt, ist völlig klar, sie halten ihn für strunzdumm. Leider ist es ihr dummer. Und jetzt versucht man einfach, das Beste daraus zu machen. So. Und das macht extreme Arbeit, dem Publikum das als stringent, inherent logisch zu verkaufen. Ja, es geht halt immer weniger auf.
Ja, bin gespannt, wie lange sie durchhalten. Wir müssen ja so langsam zu Tisch, aber ich will dir noch etwas bringen, was dich interessieren wird. Du bist ja ein Freund der Familie, hast dich damit ja publizistisch ausgiebig beschäftigt. Und Familie ist nicht nur für dich, sondern für viele Menschen wichtig. Zum Beispiel auch für Bernard Arnaud, das ist der Chef von LVMH, dem Luxuskonzern, ist der eichste Franzose. Wir haben ihn ja auch bei der Trump-Inauguration auf der Bühne gesehen. Sein Sohn war da, es gibt also eine gewisse Verbindung. Er hat jetzt den Yale Legend Leadership Award bekommen. Das ist von einer Yale-Management-Schule, irgend so ein komischer Preis. Wir wissen, alle verleihen sich gegenseitig irgendwelche Preise. Zu Gast war dann aber Bernard Arnaud gar nicht selbst. Er wurde zugeschaltet, er hatte nämlich leider keine Zeit, bei diesem wichtigen Preis zu sein. Das ist eine Veranstaltung, die dauert eine Stunde. Die sind in einem sehr dunklen Raum, mit sehr dunklen Möbeln und da ist ein Rednerpult. Und dann tritt erst ein Moderator ans Pult. Dann kommt Anna Vintur, die ehemalige Chefredakteurin der Vogue, die nochmal lobt, wie prächtig Arnaud und seine Kinder sind. Dann kommt ein Herr, der mit Arnaud auch schon zu tun hatte, der minutenlang erzählt, wie toll Berner Arnaud Tennis spielen kann. Und das er wohl auch schon mal Stunden bei Roger Federer genommen hat. Grüße nochmal an die Schweiz in dieser Stelle. Und dann ist es aber soweit, dass noch eine dritte kommt, die dann diesen Preis feierlich übergibt. Und das ist Ivanka Trump.
Genial.
Berner Arnaud, also dieser großen Luxusmarken, da unter sich vereint, ein angeblich genialer Unternehmer, der sehr kompetitiv ist, wie er immer betont. Aber was stellt man an einem solchen Festtag eigentlich heraus, an diesem Ausnahmemenschen? Nun, Folgendes.
Die Qualität, die ich am meisten in Bernard erfreue, hat nichts mit dem Geschäft zu tun. Es ist seine Devotion zur Familie. Jede Woche, ohne Ausnahmemenschen, die ganze Arnaud-Familie sammelt sich zusammen zum Mittagessen bei der Heimat von Bernard und seiner wunderschönen Frau Helene. Alle seiner Kinder, alle ihrer Kinder, jede Woche. Vor dem Mittagessen besuchte Bernard oft sein Geschäft, wie er es seit Jahrzehnten gemacht hat, mit einem seiner Kinder an seinem Seite. In einem Welt, das schnell bewegt, wählt Bernard die Presence. In einer Leben, die durch Innovation definiert wird, wählt er die Ritualität. Eine gründende Kraft, die zeigt, wer er ist, viel mehr als ein Headline oder sogar ein Gewinn. Ich bin froh, alle von Bernards Kindern zu kennen, und ihre Partnerin und Freunde zu zählen. Intention, Disziplin, Stolzigkeit, Effektion, Qualität, die er sich auf den Saturndagessen schiebt, und miriert, wie er geht.
Ivanka aus der Familie Trump, die ja wirklich auch eine Musterfamilie ist, betont hier nochmal die familiären Werte. Und das ist eigentlich das, was dem Unternehmen Stärke verleiht ist, die Familie jeden Samstag zusammenkommt und zu Mittag ist. Das ist das, was auch überdauert über diese wechselhaften Zeiten. Man hört sich diese Stunde da an und denkt sich, wenn man jetzt zu irgendeinem Karnevalsverein gehen würde, in dem gerade jemand geehrt wird für 30 Jahre Prinzengarde oder so, würde jede Rede mindestens doppelt so geistreich sein. Also es ist so interessant, dass diese so sehr erfolgreichen, sehr mächtigen und sehr reichen Leute intellektuell so unbedarfsinn einen solchen Stuss von sich geben. Denn wir hören jetzt Anna Anno, der sich bedankt.
Das ist ja sehr interessant, wie viele Brüche hier drin sind. Sie hat an dem Rednerpult von Yale dastehen. Yale ist überhaupt nur wegen der Universität bekannt, die ihr Vater gerade bekämpft. Dann redet sie dort als Tochter eines Politikers mit einem Business-Typen über die Familie. Es gab dieser Tage einen Text im Spiegel mit der Historikerin Inke Schmidt-Foggs, die ich nicht kenne, wurde gesprochen. Sie hat folgenden Bit, den finde ich hochinteressant. Ich muss dem mal nachgehen, denn das scheint ja wirklich ein Ding zu sein. Ich habe Argumente schon gemacht, in meinen Kinderbüchern zum Thema Verhältnis Politik und Familie und dass die Politik immer die Versuche hatte, die Kinderentziehung auf seine Seite zu ziehen. Aber egal wie Rote Kmär, NS-Staat, DDR, am Ende war es dann doch die Familie. Und sie sagt, der Rückzug in die Kleinfamilie, die wir ja immer den Nationalsozialisten unterstellen, mit hier das Mutterkreuz, wie Putin heute, die Familie des Jahres hat natürlich acht Kinder und so, er hat er wieder verkündet. So, sie sagt jetzt, der Rückzug in die Kleinfamilie war eine Antwort auf den Nationalsozialismus, zu dessen Ideologie hatte es gehört, die Erziehung der Kinder aus der Familie auszugliedern. In der frühen Bundesrepublik bildete sich gewissermaßen eine Gegenbewegung, man stellte die Familie unter den Schutz des Staates. Ich lese das auch vor, um zu sagen, wie sehr Semantik und Struktur immer krass auseinanderfallen können. Wir haben alle dieses Bild, Familie hat es schon immer gegeben, es ist Gott und Natur gegeben, die Nazis haben es ein bisschen übertrieben und die AfD ist dafür zu kritisieren, wie sie es wieder so haben will, wie es die Nazis hatten, nämlich die Familie ist alles und die Mutter und Tier und so weiter. Und nein, stimmt gar nicht. Das Familienbild, wie wir es heute erleben, ist überhaupt nur als Opposition zu dieser NS-Herangehensweise entstanden, in der, wie ich es ja dann beschreibe, industriellen Erweckungszeit des Wirtschaftswachstums, als man die Fabrik dann richtig hatte und sagte, so, jetzt muss Deutschlands kohlesgetriebenes Wirtschaftswachstum entstehen. Also braucht jeder Kohlearbeiter so eine Familie zu Hause, die sich um ihn kümmert. Und wenn es wirklich stimmt, dass unser elementares, soziales, kleines Leben einfach so sehr allen Erzählungen und Narrativen, die wir so haben, dazu widerspricht, dann liegt ja einfach Spannung in der Luft, die zu irgendetwas führt. Und wenn ich Ivanka da sehe, wie sie in der Yale-Universität über Familie spricht, brauche ich gar keine weitere Argumentation, um zu sagen, wow, liegt da Spannung in der Luft.
Was ja auch interessant ist, dass wir hier es mit Leuten zu tun haben, die die ganze Zeit betonen, wie hochkompetitiv sie sind, dass sie also die Gesellschaft sich ja nur als Ellenbogengesellschaft vorstellen können, dann aber diesen Rückzugsort Familie haben. Wir haben das auch schon mal bei Christian Lindner in einem Podcast so gehört, wo man sagt, hier jetzt nicht, hier sitzen wir jetzt mal alle zusammen, hier schocken wir uns ab vor der Gesellschaft, dort draußen tobt der kompetitive Wahnsinn, den ich als Ivanka mit der Familie Trump noch weiter schüre, den ich als Bernard Arnaud durch Lohndruck, durch kompetitive Kräfte am Markt noch weiter schüre, den ich aber jetzt hier aus meiner eigenen Familie draußen halte. Und manchmal werde ich so kritisch gefragt, warum kritisierst du so häufig die Familienideologie in Filmen? Und da meine ich genau das. Also erst mal muss man ja nicht noch mal eigens betonen, dass Menschen, die Familien haben, diese Familien an sich gut finden. Also es ist ja auch eine natürliche Nähe, die man hat zur Familie. Ja, also das ist jetzt nicht etwas, ja, aber man muss jetzt nicht noch mal die Liebe der Eltern zu ihren Kindern besonders betonen, weil das eher mal nahe liegt.
Ja, aber es gehört eben auch dazu, dass sie nach 15 Jahren erkältet und abflacht.
Auch das.
Und dann trifft man sich trotzdem wieder zu Weihnachten.
Richtig, aber dass man jetzt noch mal so betont, dass ihm die Familie wichtig ist, wo er Kinder hat, naja gut, warum soll es ihm auch nicht wichtig sein? Aber dass man daraus ableitet, also das macht ihn eigentlich aus. Während er natürlich sonst die ganze Zeit in einem entsolidarisierten Terrain unterwegs ist und sie eine Politik mit ihrer Familie betreibt, der Entsolidarisierung. Da ist es so lustig, wenn man dann nochmal die bearmende Familie hervorhebt. Was aber dann Bernard Arnault in seiner Dankesrede auch tut, er bedankt sich vor allem bei Ivanka Trump.
Und Ivanka Trump, für die extraordinaryen Worte, die ich ein paar Minuten vorhin gehört habe. Ich möchte auch die Trump-Familie anerkennen, denn meine Familie und ich haben uns vor mehr als 40 Jahren kennengelernt, seit dem Zeitpunkt, als ich in den USA in den 80ern lebte. Über diese vielen Jahre habe ich die wichtigsten Trump-Präsidenten auf Loyalität, Kompetenz und Familie, die stark mit meinem eigenen Leben und Arbeit ausreisen. Ich habe immer diese außergewöhnliche Energie und seine Entscheidungswege und seine Wille, mit Konjunktur zu tun.
Ja, das dazu führt, dass jetzt gerade 100.000 Anne Frank-Schicksale erlebt werden in Amerika?
Tausende Familien werden zerstört, aber Familie war ihm immer wichtig und ein Mensch, der Überzeugungen hat, erfahren wir auch. Also man kann ja auch immer sehen, diese reichen Menschen, der reichste Mensch Frankreich ist zugleich auch der unfreiste Mensch Frankreich. Weil er muss jetzt da stehen und nochmal betonen, wie wichtig Donald Trump die Familie und der Zusammenhalt ist und wie sehr er von Überzeugungen immer getrieben ist. Wo wir alle wissen, genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Und auch damit nicht Schluss, sondern er wird dann noch befragt, wer könnte dann bei all diesen Kindern, ja drei Fragen natürlich, nur drei Fragen vorher abgemacht und wir hören uns auch gar nicht die Fragen an, sondern es geht jetzt auch nur um die dritte Frage, wird dazu gefragt, wer könnte denn als dann der Nachfolger werden? Wer hat da so außergewöhnliche Kinder und sie können so viele Sprachen und sind so kultiviert? Und dann sagt er, dass er jetzt noch zehn Jahre weiter macht erst mal und dann muss man sich die Frage stellen, also er ist jetzt, glaube ich, 73. Jedenfalls kommt er dann noch mal auf die Familie zu sprechen, jetzt aber auf die gesamte Familie, denn sein Unternehmen, du ahnst es, ist auch wie eine Familie.
Was ich versuche zu tun, ist, dass Elvenmatch zuerst einmal ein Familiengruppe ist. Und nicht nur mit meinen Kindern, sondern es ist eine Art, ein Unternehmen zu gestalten. Es ist nicht, wie wir es in der französischen Gesellschaft anonymen.
Man managt also, wie eine Familie, so managt er das Unternehmen. Also ich kenne das jetzt zum Beispiel aus Familien nicht, dass man sagt, du, ich habe da jetzt gerade keine Verwendung für dich, du bist draußen ein bisschen entlassen. Sondern das ist ja gerade der Unterschied, dass man mit der Familie verbunden bleibt.
Zu dem Gegenteil, es ist eine Familie. Also, alle, die in LVMH entlassen sind, entlassen nicht nur eine große und sehr erfolgreiche Firma, sondern sie entlassen eine Familie. Also, sie sind Mitglied der Familie und wir kümmern uns um sie, wie in der Familie. Wir haben mehr als 200.000 Menschen, also ist die Beziehung nicht so nahe wie in einer kleinen Familie, aber es ist eine Familie.
Ja, er hat jetzt 17 Mal in einer Minute Familie gesagt. Ihm fällt dann noch kurz auf, 200.000 Mitarbeiter, sind die alle Familie? Ja, die sind alle Familie. Es ist irgendwie alles Familie. Das ist auch eine Form der Elitendämmerung, die wir dann hier sehen können. Diese Leute regieren uns. Diese Leute regieren uns. Er sagt an einer Stelle auch noch, er sieht sich selbst als ein Botschafter.
Liebe Journalisten, diese Leute lügen. Die haben nicht ausversehen Irrtum, den ihr später dann, aber kann man ja auch aufklären. Hier wird man einfach belogen. Okay, machen wir also den letzten Punkt. Jetzt, weil er passt, können wir ihn nicht verschieben. Anthony Scaramucci war unter Trump 1 für 20 Tage mal der Kommunikationsdirektor. Er kam wie so ein Zampano rein in den Presseraum des Weißen Hauses, aber es war noch nicht bereit. Heute würde es wunderbar funktionieren. Damals war das so ein bisschen alle dachten so, sorry, das übertrieben. Daran sind wir noch nicht gewöhnt. Also hat man ihn wieder aussortiert. Er ist aber heute sehr redselig und erklärt, also heute muss man ihm folgen. Ich finde, heute ist er eigentlich der Sprecher des Weißen Hauses, weil er einfach immer wieder glasklar erklärt, wie man das im Weißen Haus zu verstehen hat. Das ist einfach ein Typ, der hat keine Ahnung von nichts, der lässt sich auch nichts erklären, der will auch nichts wissen, der will einfach nur irgendwas machen. Und dann stellt er immer fest, dass das mit dem Machen gerade nicht funktioniert, also macht er halt was anderes. Das ist die Erklärung. Und er hat einen Podcast, in dem er eine Gästin hat, und zwar Ray Madoff, eine Professorin, die das Buch geschrieben hat zum Thema, wieso ist der LVMH-Typ so reich? Warum ist Trump so reich? Also wie wird und bleibt man eigentlich so reich?
Joining us today is Professor Ray Madoff. She is a legal scholar and professor at the Boston College Law School. And the title of the book is The Second Estate, How the Tax Code Made an American Aristocracy.
So, Scaramucci ist also irgendein reicher Millionär, der jetzt mal auch einen gewissen Hass auf die Milliardäre hat, weil die sich da so abkapseln und überhaupt und so. Erklärt sich das jetzt erklären, wie das funktioniert.
Ich denke, das Problem ist die enormen Fähigkeiten, die wir Menschen geben, um die Wälder in der Zukunft zu kontrollieren. Und das ist, wieder einmal, nicht der Fall. In unseren Geheimdiensten, und das ist etwas, wieder einmal, zurück zu Thomas Jefferson, hat er beruflich gesagt, die Welt, na gut, lass mich das sagen, in meinem Leben, hat er gesagt, die Welt gehört in Jusufruct für das Leben. Und Jusufruct bedeutet, dass Menschen es während ihrer Leben nutzen können, und nach der Todeszeit haben sie keine mehr Kontrolle darüber. Er glaubte, dass die Regeln und die Kontrolle der Wälder und alles in den Händen von lebenden Menschen sein sollte.
Das, was sie jetzt beschreibt, wie das funktioniert, ist ganz einfach zu verstehen. Und die Fragestellung ist, ja, jemand soll die Chance haben, superreich zu werden. In Amerika gibt es ja auch viele Milliardäre, die es in ihrer eigenen Lebenszeit wurden, also irgendwelche Silicon Valley Gründer oder Sonstige und so. Die sind also superreich geworden. Die Frage ist nur, kann man das Geld auch wieder, also kann man auch wieder super verarmen? Spätestens mit dem Tod, hat Thomas Jefferson gesagt, ist sozusagen Gründungsidee Amerikas. Amerika hat so Traum und so weiter. Jeder hat das Recht, glücklich zu sein. Also jeder darf, aber spätestens mit dem Tod war es das. Nichts vererben. Das ist eigentlich die Losung. Jetzt ist hier die Frage, wie haben es die amerikanischen Superreichen, und es gilt genauso auch für Europa, wie haben die es geschafft, nicht wieder zu verarmen, sondern das dann einfach durch die Generation weiter zu erben, sodass wir so eine riesige neue Aristokratie haben, die einfach gar nicht angekoppelt ist an irgendetwas, sondern dann so dasteht und Familienreden hält und hier und also Ivanka und ihn da zu sehen, ist ja wirklich absurd.
Die Grundlage, warum die wöchentlichen Amerikaner die Taxe zu verhindern können, ist, weil sie die Inhaltstätten zu verhindern können. Aber die Hauptwache, die sie tun, ist, dass sie die Inhaltstätten zu verhindern können, Ich nenne sie das Tax-Avoidance-Playbook.
So, das Tax-Avoidance-Playbook, keine Einkommenssteuerzahlen.
Denn wir wissen, die Einkommenssteuer ist recht hoch.
50% fallen dem typischen, was man so, ne? Also einfach die Hälfte fällt so aus.
Ja, also in Deutschland machen wir es ganz konkret. Der Spitzensteuersatz, Spitzengrenzsteuersatz liegt bei 45%. Das heißt, der wird bei Single-Haushalten so ab 270.000, bei Verheiraten ab 500.000 fällig. Dann kommen ab, ich glaube, 90 oder 80.000 im Jahr kommen 3% Solidaritätszuschlag drauf. Das heißt also, man ist da in dieser absoluten Spitzenverdienerriege, ist man bei 48%. Das heißt, da wäre also ordentlich Progression. Man kann dann darüber diskutieren, dass es eigentlich noch höher gehen müsste mit einem höheren Einkommen. Aber gut, das war mal, hat man dann nicht mehr. Jedenfalls wollen genau diesen Steuersatz die Reichen entgehen. Also sie sagen nicht, ja dann zahle ich das halt, aber ich verdiene ja auch dick. Sondern sie versuchen jetzt mit Konstrukten, da eine UG, da dies, da das, genau das zu umgehen.
Genau. Also es gibt immer zwei Steuern, die man eigentlich als normaler Mensch nicht vermeiden kann. Das eine ist die Einkommenssteuer, das andere ist die Umsatzsteuer. Und wenn man da jetzt die 20% auf alles und dann 30% Einkommenssteuer auf Arbeit mit Sozialabgaben und so weiter, ist man immer so bei 50% irgendwo. Also das ist so das Standardniveau. Eigentlich lässt dir der Staat nichts, er nimmt dir sofort 50%, außer hier. Und die erklärt jetzt das Playbook.
Und diese drei Schritte sind, der erste ist, dass sie die Ziele und andere übliche Formen von bezahlten Einkommen verhindern. Wenn du als Kind, als du mit blutgenösser Hintergrund begonnen hast, war der einzige Weg, um Geld zu bekommen, durch Arbeit. Und diese Arbeit ist sehr stark bezahlt. Und es ist bezahlt bei den höchsten Raten, bis zu 37%, und es ist verantwortlich für eine zweite Länge von Bezahlen. Es gibt auch payroll-Taxe, die geheimen Taxen genannt werden, weil es in allen Bereichen Menschen nicht bewusst davon sind. Und also, du hast, dass Erneuerungen sehr, sehr schweren Taxen verursacht werden. Und deshalb ist der erste Schritt des Tax-Aufwechslungs-Klicks der richest amerikanischen ist, taxable Einkommen zu verhindern. Und wenn du dir einen Blick auf einige unserer der berühmsten, richest Menschen hast, wie Warren Buffett, Jeff Bezos und . Die Erinnerungen sind, dass die.
Und die nimmt er dann auch noch in Anspruch. Also Jeff Bezos kassiert noch mal 15.000 Euro im Jahr oder so.
Das ist so unklar bisher.
Kannst du dir das nicht vorstellen? Zuckerman und andere sind Dollar pro Jahr, Leute. Ein Jahr hat Elon Musk nur 0 Euro gewonnen und die Staaten von Kalifornien sind nach Tesla gegangen, um zu sagen, hey, du zahlst nicht genug hier.
Da greifen plötzlich linker arbeitspolitik geronnenen Kämpfe mit, sorry, du musst deinen Gehalt erhöhen, du verdienst jetzt so wenig.
Du musst dir mal einen Mindestlohn zahlen.
Genau, zahl dir mal einen Mindestlohn.
Aber die Grundlage, warum sie so kleine Zahllarie nehmen, ist nicht, weil sie generelle Wesen sind, sondern weil sie wissen, dass Zahllarie für Hörer sind. Zahllarie, du wirst einen sehr schweren Taxi bezahlen. Also machen sie stattdessen, dass sie Zahllarie vergeben und sie in Form der wachsenden Werte ihrer Zahllarie in die Kompensation nehmen. Der zweite Schritt des Tax-Avoidance-Playbooks ist, dass sie ihre Zahllarie und andere Zahllarie in Werte haben, aber sie nicht verkaufen. Wenn sie es verkaufen, müssen sie die Kapital-Grenzen-Zahllarie bezahlen. Aber unter unserem System, wenn sie es nicht verkaufen, müssen sie nie die Zahllarie bezahlen. Wenn sie es ihren Kindern oder ihren Kindern verschenken, müssen sie nie die Zahllarie bezahlen. Man könnte sagen, ja, aber wie werden sie ihre wunderschönen Lebensstile unterstützen? Die Antwort ist, dass sie gegen den Stock bezahlen, und das ist der Weg, dass sie taxfreie Zugang zu ihrem Wohl haben. Alle diese Menschen machen massiv die Zahllarie.
Das ist die Variante, die es gibt. Es gibt noch die andere mit Immobilien in Deutschland. Bekommt man das auch wunderbar hin, dass man dort sogar noch Zuschüsse bekommen für Renovierungen und dass man dann zehn Jahre wartet und dann kann man das steuerfrei verkaufen. Und ich habe ja einmal mit solchen Herren, der das als Großgeschäftsmodell hat, zusammengesessen und der hat dann auch erzählt, dass er sich ein kleines Gehalt auszahlt. Das wird wahrscheinlich auch in dieser Diga sein.
Genau. Und hier liegt eine spezielle Pointe drin, denn dieses Buy, Borrow, Die, also Borrow nur auf Schuldenleben. Du kriegst ja extrem niedrige Zinsen, wenn du dein ganzes Vermögen als Sicherheit hinterlegst. Also wenn du einfach zwei Milliarden hast, kostet dich jeder Kredit, egal in welcher Höhe, fast nichts. Jetzt dieser Zinslage vielleicht 3-4 Prozent oder so, aber jedenfalls nicht 50 Prozent wie auf der Einkommenssteuer. Diese 3-4 Prozent Zinsausgaben sind ja gleichzeitig negative Kosten, die du hast. Für die kriegst du ja wieder Steuervorteile. Also bezahlst du im Grunde gar nichts. Du kannst einfach unendlich viel Geld ausgeben, bis der Schuldenberg deinen Vermögensstand erreicht und die Bank dann sagen kann, ab jetzt haben sie keine Sicherheiten mehr, dann wird es natürlich teuer. Wie für normale Leute so. Was bedeutet, jedes Mal, wenn in Deutschland jemand behauptet, wir können die nicht besteuern, weil das sind ja Betriebsvermögen, müssen wir sagen, ja natürlich sind das Betriebsvermögen. Nur deswegen wollen wir das den ja wegnehmen.
Ja klar.
Also es ist genau das Gegenteil, ein Argument, wie die es immer benutzen. So, wir wollen das Betriebsvermögen haben, weil die das als Sicherheit benutzen, um sich dann für 0 Euro Zinsen, also für 0 Euro Kosten Geld zu verschaffen.
Ja genau, richtig.
Und da muss man jetzt ran. Insbesondere, ich will es noch mal sagen, wir haben im Sommersalon geklärt, dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat, Vermögensstau darf so nicht erhoben werden, weil alle Vermögensgüter ordentlich verrechnet werden, außer Immobilien. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht sagte 1997, die Bewertungsmaßstäbe sind zu gering, teilweise wird nur ein Zehntel der tatsächlichen Kosten von Gebäuden verrechnet. Das ist ungerecht gegenüber den anderen Vermögenswerten, die verrechnet werden. Eine Goldkette geht mit 100 Prozent rein und ein Haus nur mit 10 Prozent des eigentlichen Wertes. Das ist ungerecht. Dann hat die Politik gesagt, ja, dann setzen wir sie aus. Dann einfach zu sagen, nehmen wir jetzt mal den ordentlichen Bodenrichtwert gesteuerten Wert dieses Hauses und sagen, wir haben aber jetzt neu vom Bundesverfassungsgericht eine in den meisten deutschen Bundesländern abgenickte Grundsteuererhebungsmethode. Das heißt, das, was früher gesagt wurde vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, es geht nicht, die Gebäude sind zu niedrig bewertet. Die werden gerade verfassungskonform bewertet. Wir könnten also die Vermögensteuer einfach wieder einschalten.
Nur mal so als Idee zum Jahresabschluss.
Für den Fall im Deutschlandfunk, dass man sich noch die Frage stellt, wo hat es denn hier, was kann man sich denn nicht erklären?
Wo kriegen wir dann noch ein paar Millionen her?
Also Betriebsvermögen ab sofort ist das der Betrug, der hier stattfindet. Das ist Einkommenssteuervermeidung. Das ist nicht, oder arbeiten Leute, wenn derjenige dieses Betriebsvermögen weggeben muss, dann werden die alle gekündigt. Nein, für Betriebsvermögen finden wir immer Käufer. Und das sind dann auch einfach Eigentümer. Wir tauschen deswegen nicht das Management aus oder sowas. Das ist ja immer eine völlig absurde Idee.
Wir haben doch nicht die Häuser abgerissen und die Maschinen kaputt geschlagen.
Also Betriebsvermögen sind Einkommenssteuervermeidungsbetrug im Grunde. Würde ich jetzt mal sagen, ist Betrug. Und wir haben hier eine Grundsteuer.
Es ist legal, aber ja.
Die Grundsteuerreform ist durch, Verfassungsgericht hat es abgenickt. Die Bodenwerte hauen so weit hin. Ich will jetzt nicht auf den Clip kommen, wie der Deutschlandfunk sich nochmal erklären lässt von irgendeinem Grund- und Bodenlobbyisten. Die Bayern machen das schon voll gerecht. Die sagen einfach, pro Quadratmeter wird hier abgerechnet. Egal, ob das jetzt München Innenstadt oder auf dem Lande kurz vor Thüringen ist.
Leuchtet ja total ein.
Ist doch total logisch, dass diese Gleichheit ganz gerecht ist.
Wir bedanken uns ganz herzlich für dieses Jahr, machen im Januar dann weiter mit dem Salon The Meritocracy Trap von Daniel Markowitz. Wird dann das Thema im Salon sein. In den Salon kommt man.
In dem man auf neuezwanziger.de geht. Wir sind ein Podcast mit eigener Webseite. Dort ist ein goldener Button. Da kommt man zu Steady. Alle Fragen, die man hat, werden bei Steady beantwortet oder beantwortet Steady auf Nachfrage. Wir bekommen auch immer mal Mails. Dann schreibe ich einfach nur zurück. Schreib Steady. Danach höre ich nie wieder was davon, weil Steady sich gekümmert hat.
Aber in der Regel passiert auch gar nichts.
In der Regel passiert nichts. Oder man bucht einfach mit einem Klick bei Apple, wenn man es da einfach so sieht. Oder man hat schon einen Patreon-Account, weil man amerikanischen Linken-Podcasts folgt oder sowas. Dann kann man natürlich auch uns folgen.
Genau. Dann sehen wir uns im neuen Jahr und wünschen einen guten Rutsch.
So ist es.